ever wondered how google translates an
entire web page to a different language
in a matter of seconds or your phone
gallery groups images based on their
location to achieve ai through
algorithms trained with data and finally
deep learning is a type of machine
learning inspired by the structure of
the human brain in terms of deep
learning this structure is called an
artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stem on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits but what if a
computer had to recognize them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels now that amounts to a
total of 784 pixels
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them the information is
transferred from one layer to another
over connecting channels each of these
has a value attached to it and hence is
called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias this bias
is added to the weighted sum of inputs
reaching the neuron
which is then applied to a function
known as the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues up till the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations
the first as we discussed earlier is
data while deep learning is the most
efficient way to deal with unstructured
data a neural network requires a massive
volume of data to train let's assume we
always have access to the necessary
amount of data processing this is not
within the capability of every machine
and that brings us to our second
limitation computational power training
in neural network requires graphical
processing units which have thousands of
cores as compared to cpus and gpus are
of course more expensive and finally we
come down to training time deep neural
networks take hours or even months to
train the time increases with the amount
of data and number of layers in the
network some of the popular deep
learning frameworks include tensorflow
pytorch keras deep learning 4j cafe and
microsoft cognitive toolkit considering
the future predictions for deep learning
and ai we seem to have only scratched
the surface in fact horus technology is
working on a device for the blind that
uses deep learning with computer vision
to describe the world to the users
replicating the human mind at the
entirety may be not just an episode of
science fiction for too long the future
is indeed full of surprises last summer
my family and i visited russia even
though none of us could read russian we
did not have any trouble in figuring our
way out all thanks to google's real-time
translation of russian boards into
english
this is just one of the several
applications of neural networks
neural networks form the base of deep
learning a subfield of machine learning
where the algorithms are inspired by the
structure of the human brain
neural networks take in data train
themselves to recognize the patterns in
this data and then predict the outputs
for a new set of similar data
let's understand how this is done
let's construct a neural network that
differentiates between a square circle
and triangle
neural networks are made up of layers of
neurons these neurons are the core
processing units of the network
first we have the input layer which
receives the input the output layer
predicts our final output
in between exists the hidden layers
which perform most of the computations
required by our network here's an image
of a circle
this image is composed of 28 by 28
pixels which make up for
pixels
each pixel is fed as input to each
neuron of the first layer
neurons of one layer are connected to
neurons of the next layer through
channels
each of these channels is assigned a
numerical value known as weight
the inputs are multiplied to the
corresponding weights and their sum is
sent as input to the neurons in the
hidden layer
each of these neurons is associated with
a numerical value called the bias which
is then added to the input sum
this value is then passed through a
threshold function called the activation
function
the result of the activation function
determines if the particular neuron will
get activated or not
an activated neuron transmits data to
the neurons of the next layer over the
channels
in this manner the data is propagated
through the network
this is called forward propagation
in the output layer the neuron with the
highest value fires and determines the
output the values are basically a
probability for example here our neuron
associated with square has the highest
probability
hence that's the output predicted by the
neural network
of course just by a look at it we know
our neural network has made a wrong
prediction but how does the network
figure this out
note that our network is yet to be
trained
during this training process along with
the input our network also has the
output fed to it the predicted output is
compared against the actual output to
realize the error in prediction the
magnitude of the error indicates how
wrong we are and the sign suggests if
our predicted values are higher or lower
than expected
the arrows here give an indication of
the direction and magnitude of change to
reduce the error
this information is then transferred
backward through our network
this is known as back propagation
now based on this information the
weights are adjusted
this cycle of forward propagation and
back propagation is iteratively
performed with multiple inputs
this process continues until our weights
are assigned such that the network can
predict the shapes correctly in most of
the cases
this brings our training process to an
end
you might wonder how long this training
process takes honestly neural networks
may take hours or even months to train
but time is a reasonable trade-off when
compared to its scope
let us look at some of the prime
applications of neural networks facial
recognition cameras on smartphones these
days can estimate the age of the person
based on their facial features this is
neural networks at play first
differentiating the face from the
background and then correlating the
lines and spots on your face to a
possible h forecasting neural networks
are trained to understand the patterns
and detect the possibility of rainfall
or rise in stock prices with high
accuracy music composition neural
networks can even learn patterns in
music and train itself enough to compose
a fresh tune with deep learning and
neural networks we are still taking baby
steps the growth in this field has been
foreseen by the big names companies such
as google amazon and nvidia have
invested in developing products such as
libraries predictive models and
intuitive gpus that support the
implementation of
by simply learn my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
and today we're going over the deep
learning tutorial what is deep learning
deep learning is a type of machine
learning that works on the basis of
functionalities of human brain it trains
machines to work on vast volumes of
structured and unstructured data
deep learning uses the concept of neural
networks that is derived from the
structure of a human brain and if you've
ever seen images of a human brain
network you have dendrites inputs you
have cell which is a nucleus as your
nodes you have synapses which create
weights
and an axon which create an output
now this is a very simplified version of
the human brain
and there are
certain sets of cells that are strung
together very similar to how today's
neural networks
perform but they still have a long ways
to go and the human brain is still
significantly more complex
with
hundreds of different kinds of cells and
different interactions we don't see yet
so what is deep learning artificial
intelligence
so you have your ai is a method of
building smart machines that are capable
to think like human and mimic their
actions
be careful with that definition we're a
long way from a human cyborg coming in
and taking over
when we talk about this we're usually
talking about automating uh
single kind of instances or things going
on how do we automate a new process how
do we automate a small robot to do
something how do we get a drone to fly
out when it loses contact to turn around
and come back in the direction it came
from
those are very simple processes and
significantly lower than the scale of
like what human thinking does
now a subcategory of artificial
intelligence is machine learning
machine learning is an application of ai
that allows machines to automatically
learn and improve with experience
there's a lot of tools out there to use
with machine learning
and you'll see really regression models
and things like that they're much more
common when dealing with straight
numbers a linear regression model and
there's other models that just
do basic math functions quite well
but then we get into one of the
subcategories deep learning deep
learning is a subfield of machine
learning that is used to extract
patterns from data using neural networks
and again we're talking about
complicated patterns
we talk about image processing and
things like that they're not as
straightforward as the numbers in stock
exchange so you start looking at another
way to solve these problems and figure
out is that a raccoon in the picture or
something
much more complicated if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
deep learning performance
so when you have we talk about
performance of deep learning and the
amount of data
the performance goes up the more data
you have the higher the performance
when we talk about a lot of machine
learning platforms they kind of peak out
at a lower level so
again you can think of this as having
thousands of pictures of raccoons like i
said before versus the numbers in a
stock exchange which are very uh rigid
and very clear there you have a close
and an open in the stock exchange kind
of thing where you have an image of a
raccoon the color shading all kinds of
things go into trying to figure out is
it a raccoon
so we look at what is a neural network
we really look into
kind of a nice image of it
today's neural networks usually have a
layer of inputs and you'll see here we
have input 1 2 and 3 with x1 x2 x3
so you have your input layer you have
your hidden layers this might have
multiple layers depending on what you're
working on
then you have your output layer which in
this case we have two outputs y1 and y2
and you can also see the connectivity
here
so everything in the first row connects
with everything in the second row in the
hidden layer and if you had another
hidden layer everything in the first
hidden layer would connect to the second
hidden layer and then everything in the
second hidden layer would connect to
each of the outputs and then
make calculations based on that and this
is interesting because there's so many
different aspects of neural networks
nowadays that are changing this basic
configuration
they find that if you skip a hidden
layer or two
with your input going through
that that actually changes the results
and
works better in some cases there's also
convolutional neural networks which look
at windows and adding up the numbers in
them there's a lot of complexity when we
start getting into the different aspects
of what you can do and how you build
neural networks and again it's very very
much in an infant stage so this basic
diagram does a great job of capturing
what it looks like now
the input layer is responsible to accept
the inputs in various formats
the hidden layers again there's that s
could be multiple layers is responsible
for extracting features and hidden
patterns from the data
and you know a hidden patterns and
features is important we want to look at
features you usually talk about features
as your input you have input one is one
feature input two is another feature if
you're looking at the iris data it might
be the width and length of the pedal
each one of those would be a feature
you have these nodes which generate a
number that doesn't really have a
specific representation
but it becomes a way of looking at it of
the adding the features together and
creating an importance value there
and the output layer produces the
desired output after completing the
entire processing of the data
what is a perceptron
a perceptron is a binary classification
algorithm proposed by frank rosenblatt
and you'll see here we have our
constants come in and our inputs we have
a constant 1 for the bias the bias is
important you can go back to euclidean
geometry where you have a line
y equals mx plus b
b being the y-intercept that's what that
constant is is there needs to be some
kind of adjustment
that basically is the y-intercept
and you have your inputs you have your
weights you have your weighted sum your
activation function and an output of 0
or 1.
and so here we have we'll go ahead and
walk through these we have x1 x2 x3 are
the inputs
w naught w1 w2 w3 are the weights
weights are values that determine the
strength of the connection between two
neurons
and if we go back
to the slide let me just flash back here
to this slide
you can see how each one of these nodes
has multiple inputs so when you look at
the hidden layer of the outputs they
have multiple inputs so each one of
these nodes
has these inputs they might be the
original features coming in they might
be the layer of nodes before so you have
your x1 x2 and x3 are the input into
your node your weights are the weighted
values that determine the strength of
the connection between two neurons
the input neurons are multiplied with
the weight and a bias is added there's
that one which is weighted the
y-intercept in euclidean geometry
to give the resulted weight sum
the activation function applies a step
to check if the output of the weighting
function is greater than 0 or not
there's a lot of ways to do an
activation function but this is the most
common or the most not common but the
most easy to see way of doing an
activation on here
so we look at here we go another go
walking back through this diagram and
taking a closer look at it
we have the predicted output is compared
with the actual output
so once you go through the step and it
adds everything together in there and
these are your weights are multiplied
they're just multiple so you have
feature of x1 times weight of 1
plus feature of x2 times weighted 2 so
on plus the weight times the bias and we
go ahead and compute all those all the
way through the node comes out and we
have
the actual output
and then
we go ahead and have a predicted output
what do we think it's going to be
and this is on each note so keep in mind
we're zero in and on the node this isn't
the whole process
because this actually goes through all
the notes but there's a there's another
step in here when we get to that part
the error in the network is estimated
using the cost function and back
propagation technique is used to improve
the performance
so when we look at the
in the back propagation algorithm the
cost function is minimalized by changing
weights and biases in the network and
you can see here we have our input layer
we have our hidden layers
and we have our output layer and so you
can think of this as we have our actual
output we predict what it's going to be
in this case we have two outputs we
might predict that it's either nothing
there
or a raccoon
so one of them comes up and says i don't
see any kind of animal and the other one
says this is a raccoon
so it's either yes or no and if it gets
it wrong it says that's wrong it sends
that error back
and that error goes through the first
set of weights
which then goes to the hidden layers and
their set of weights which goes back to
b1 the other layer
and their set of weights and it adjusts
those weights as it goes backwards and
it says hey this is the error on the
output
we kind of adjusted a little bit
the part that we don't adjust in the
first set of weights we say there's
still an error so we send it to the
second set of weights and so forth
what happens is as we adjust these
weights each one of these nodes
starts creating kind of a category
or something to look for in whatever
image or
data we have going in
and so for making a better predictions a
number of epochs are executed where the
error is determined by the cost function
now epic is a important thing to keep
track of epics is if you have a large
or any data set
and let's say you split out your test
date and your training data set you're
running your data through how many times
do you have to run all of that data
through
before you start getting something that
is usable till the error goes down you
can't adjust the error anymore it's the
lowest error you can get
so each time you go through a full set
of data
before you repeat and go through the
same data that's called an epic
the error is backward propagated until a
sufficiently small error is achieved
and again that's what we're talking
about we're trying to minimize the error
so we get to a point where that error
really isn't changing anymore
you just have the same error coming out
and there's other ways to weight that
error too
the cost function or loss function
measures the accuracy of the network the
cost functions tries to penalize the
network when it makes errors
you can see here we have a formula for
the cost function c equals one-half of
the y predicted minus the y the actual y
squared and of course the squared value
removes the sign because we don't know
whether it's plus or minus when you look
at an error and then the c this is your
cost function how much is it going to
cost how much of an error do we really
have that we're sending back and so we
have with the cost function we can look
at this we can look at it as a loss and
the epic again that's every time we go
through the data that's an epic how many
epic runs are we going to go and so we
have a nice graph here that shows like a
very high learning rate low learning
rate
different data is going to
change depending on what you're working
on
they put the yellow as a good learning
rate
because it has
a nice slope to it and you think yeah
the more epics i go in the lower the
loss so that means you're going in a
good direction there
and as you curves down he gets to the
the best answer has the lowest loss on
there
so uh looking at types of neural
networks uh we have the gan
we have the dbn the rbfn the auto
encoder the rnn the lstm
this is a flash
of some of the main ones that are out
there there are now so many variations
that there's variations on the
variations
and so just
quickly jumping into these as you can
see we have a number of them here listed
these are just like a flash of some of
the more common ones
like the gan general adversarial network
where you have two different models
competing against each other until they
find which one can beat the other one
can i think of a chess game where you
keep flipping who's in charge
and then we might look at the
dbn
which is a deep belief network
and they're used to recognize clusters
and generate image video sequences
generally
and we have the rbf
network rbfn
which is your radial basis function
network which uses a different set of
activation functions
to figure out which is the right weights
auto encoder the auto encoder is a
little different
than the other ones in that
it looks for an error but the error is
based in finding data that groups
together uh so it's a way of sorting the
data out without knowing the answer
that's what an autoencoder does
rnn rnn
has a couple different definitions uh
most the time you now see it as a
recurrent neural network
where the output
part of the output goes back into the
input
so they call it this was recurrent
there's also another rnn which deals
with
learning step by step as opposed to over
a set of data and weighting it as you go
and there's the
ls
tm or long short term memory recurrent
neural network it's also an rnn
which deals with how do you
sort something like a sentence out
where the last word depends on what the
first word was and so it slowly waits
things as it goes through to figure out
what's being said
again these are just a quick flash and
even as i was describing them you should
have been like well why don't you hook
an auto encoder into again and then run
that with a dbn
well there are tools to go ahead and mix
and match these things so
you will actually see
when you start doing layers you might
have the layers of one type of neural
network feed into the next neural
network and that's actually pretty
common
and we talk about deep learning
libraries there's a lot of different
things out there
but the big ones that they usually talk
about
and most of these are dealing with
larger data is like tensorflow cross
cross and tincture flow play nice with
each other and cross kind of is is
usually integrated with tensorflow
cafe
theno pytorch dl 4j
these are all different deep learning
libraries and there's many more out
there there's a scikit has a deep
learning library in it under python
scala has one that they've been building
on there
so these aren't the only ones
tensorflow is probably the most
robust one at this time
but that's not to say the other ones
aren't catching up and there's not all
kinds of other stuff out there now going
through and talking about these things
is all
fun
but until you get to roll up your
sleeves and take a look at the code and
see what's going on it's really hard to
see what we're talking about so we're
going to do a deep learning demo on text
classification
now to do this there's a lot of
different editors you can use for
python
currently my favorite my favorites
always one i'm currently using
which changes from month to month or
year to year depending what projects
we're doing
we want to look at
anaconda navigator which is a nice job
building your different packages and
environments and go into jupiter
notebook and so we'll go and go into
jupiter notebook and create our
our setup in there to run a neural
network
and so we open up our jupyter we'll go
ahead and create a new python three
and let me just bring this out to the
top
there we go
uh so now we already have our jupiter
three and i like to always give it a
setup on here so this is the text
classification we're doing today
we'll go ahead and rename that
and we were talking about if you
remember from the beginning of the thing
i said some of the the more the most one
of the most robust packages out there
right now is
tensorflow along with keras which
usually works nicely with tensorflow so
we're going to go ahead and be working
with the tensorflow and the cross
we want to go ahead and do
a number of imports in here
this is just set up on this a lot of
this really isn't necessary for what
we're going to do there's different
things we can do so we're going to go
ahead and from future we're going to
import absolute import division print
function
these really don't do a lot other than
they help us kind of display things
later on
you don't really need them you can just
do some basic print on this if you want
to
so i'm not going to dig too deeply into
that setup
but we do want to take a look at
iteration tools
because we're always iterating over
things
again you don't really need the
iteration tools because a lot of
tensorflow will do this for you
but it's a lot of times when we're
building these packages we don't think
about it we just bring in all our tools
that we might need
the big ones though is our pandas db
and let me switch to a draw thing it's
always nice to kind of
give us arrows here uh
there we go
uh so we're looking at you can see here
here's our pandas panda sits on top of
uh numpy our number array pandas is our
data frame just makes it really easy to
bring in the data view the data and kind
of
work with the file that's what these two
are for and of course our matplot
library up here is for displaying it and
then we have the sklearn
these are for doing metrics and
pre-processing
some of this you can actually pull off
of tensorflow i tend to bounce back and
forth between the sk learn setup
and by the way the sk learning has its
own neural network a real simplified one
compared to what tensorflow does
but we want to go ahead and do this in
tensorflow where we're going to be using
tensorflow cross and cross
is nice because it sits on top of
tensorflow
but uh it's easier to use it's a little
bit like you could think of tensorflow
as being the back end which you can
program in and cross being a higher
level language which makes it easier to
do things in
and you can see here we went ahead and
printed out tf version we're using
tensorflow
as the back end and you have the
tensorflow version 2.1.0
always important to double check your
versions you never know what's
not going to work with what version of
python and so forth so it's important to
check those
this is python36
i don't know if tensorflow is fully
integrated with 37 or 38 yet
i'm sure if it isn't it soon will be
and so we're going to go ahead and bring
some data in this is
consumercomplaints.csv and if you want a
copy of this file just for your own to
play with you can
put a note send a note to simplylearn
and they'll be happy to send you a copy
of that
and then df stands for data frame that's
very common and we're using the pandas
to go ahead and read this
comma separated variable file in
and we'll go ahead and print what they
called the head if you've never worked
with data frames usually when you see
head it means the first five rows of
that data frame so you can see what's
going on in there
and
give it just a moment to read that in
there it goes
and you'll see in here that we have uh
a date received a product mortgage
credit reporting consumer loan credit
card sub product other mortgage nan nan
whatever that means whatever it is
missing data right there there's nothing
in there vehicle loan and so forth and
then of course different columns and
this is a data frame data frame has rows
and columns
and a lot of times when you're
processing data frames you can think of
mapping
map and reduce as a terminology we're
mapping we're either mapping each of the
rows like you might be running a process
on each row or you're running a process
on each column
and then one of the most common things
would be say to some parts of the row
together and have a total value of cost
or maybe some
the total uh you may come over here
wherever i'm sure there's a value in
here
um complaint id yeah they don't actually
have a value
but it'd be something you would process
by column you might want to find out how
many different companies are listed here
so that might be something you'd run on
the column
so that gives you an idea we have our
data frame
df head on there
and if you remember we're looking at
text classification so that makes sense
that we don't have any dollar values in
there
and we're going to look at just a couple
of these columns
certainly you can do this
with a number of different objects on
here but we're going to take just the
columns consumer complaint narrative
and the product column
and in this case when we handle null
values there's a lot of different ways
to handle null values
but in this case we're just going to go
ahead and
do just the not null we only want those
that are not null in the consumer
complaint narrative
and let's go ahead and print that
do the df head
in
jupiter
the last line if you just have a
variable it automatically prints it out
um so
you could put print and put brackets
around df head and do the same thing
and you can see here we have our
consumer complaint narrative
i have outdated information on my credit
report
and then you have your credit reporting
and so forth on each one of these an
account on my credit card was mistaken
the company refuses to provide me
verification the complaint regards to
square to something
so we're going to be looking at these
complaint narratives and trying to
understand them
and can we write a code to
optimize that
and then one of the things we always do
like up here you'll see where we already
removed the null values
i would go ahead and just double check
uh sum up the null values are there any
null values in our data frame
and this is just a simple way of looking
at every cell this includes consumer
complaint the product and so forth
and you can see here we have
zero null values so that's good we're
not we're not going to play with the
null values today and then we can also
go ahead and take a look at uh our end
aspect we might be looking for which is
our product we have credit reporting
consumer loan credit reporting debt
collection debt collection
uh let's go ahead and just take a look
at this
and see how many accounts we have
and you can see here that there is under
debt collection 47 000 entries under
mortgage there's 36 000 entries under
credit card uh we have over 18 000
entries so this is a pretty big
database
and you can see it going down all the
way down here with the different
uh entries that go underneath of product
so we have and one of the things we
don't spend a lot of time on in some of
these demos
is what is really defining what we're
looking for
now if you're doing a data science
project you usually start by exploring
the data and then you define what you're
really looking for and so we're kind of
skipping through that really that
particular process
it does
constitute a small amount of time
but as far as the importance is one of
the most important things you can do in
data science
is
ask the right questions so even though
you're spending 80 percent of the time
cleaning data
building your models and everything that
20 percent of asking the right questions
has a higher impact and so you really
should be making sure that you
understand what the questions are
that's domain knowledge so we're talking
in this case banking
and so in this case it might be that as
consumer complaint comes in
we can start looking at these consumer
complaints and what product they're
attached to what that means
we're not going to dig too much into the
domain in asking the question you know
what exactly we're looking for we really
want to look into the process
as far as building a neural network
and so
uh the first thing we do is go ahead and
split our data uh we need a train set
and a test set
the train size in this case we're going
to do 80 of the data is going to be for
training our neural network
um and then we'll go ahead and use the
we'll switch that over for the test size
to be the 20 percent let me go and run
that
and you can see here train size has 15
159 000 entries and then we'll test that
on we've held out roughly 40 000 of
those entries for our test size
and then for this example
we're just going to split it
the first part of the data will be for
training our data and the second part
will be for testing our data so we're
not really doing a random
setup in here which is okay because this
is an example
a lot of times you might split this
one of the things i do with neural
networks is i will split it into three
sections
and i will test
two as training and the third as um the
test this is obviously not big data you
don't want to do this on something that
might take days to process
um and then i flip it and then so i'll
run it three times and those three times
will give me a nice narrative of how
good my model is and then i'll actually
run the the final product on all three
sections to program it to train it
uh so it gives me a good basis of what
kind of error i have versus you know on
test models while having a very robust
model to publish
in this case so we're just going to go
ahead and split it based on
the first part goes to the train and the
second part goes to the test
so
one of the next things whenever we deal
with text and this is such an important
line
i want to go ahead and just highlight
the tokenize you'll see the word
tokenize
tokenizer setting it up
we're taking the words and putting them
into a format
the computer can understand
there is a lot of ways to tokenize words
in some cases you call them 0 1 2 3 4.
depending on what you're doing it might
just be a zero or one
um so when we talk about the encoder
we're usually talking about as far as
tokenize
we actually are looking at in this
particular case we'll be looking at each
word
as its own feature
so when we looked up here remember right
up here let's see here we go money
transfer let me let me go back up just a
note here turn that off so i can go back
up if you remember up here we have
this right here consumer complaint
narrative so i would be a feature have
would be a feature outdated would be a
feature information would be a feature
on feature my feature credit feature
report
and you think wow that's a lot of
features yes in running through bills
put out by the united states that are
being voted on in this in the government
it comes out roughly 2.4 million
different words are used in those bills
that's a lot of features
and so we're going to go ahead and look
at uh max words tokenize and tokenizing
words there's a lot that is happening
here in the tokenized setup so we'll go
ahead and let me just
put together some of this code here
so the tokenize is an actual object in
here text tokenizer
and it has number of words equals max
words so we're going to limit it to a
thousand words character level equals
false fit on text train narrative only
fit on the training data and so this is
kind of interesting because it drops a
lot of these words uh why would it drop
a word well on on is probably used a
bunch and really doesn't have any value
so that's would be one of the words
they'll probably drop
and also there's other things it can do
like you can also combine combinations a
word it might be that this company this
complaint these might be
always together so at some point it
might actually bundle some of these
words as a single feature
there's a lot of things that go into
that
we're not going to go into too much
detail because you really have to go
through the api on these to understand
all the different uh encoding and setups
you have
this is just a really fast way to do
this and it works
i like easy and i like things that work
i don't know about you but what i'm
running through and doing a lot of
different models
i might start tweaking these once i have
an answer
but until then
we want to go ahead and
run the encoder and do something simple
like this
and so uh using sk learn utility to
convert the label strings to number
index and so here's our encoder label
encoder encoder fit
and this is sklearn of course
everything's fit
and then we do y train equals the
encoder transform train product y test
equals encoder transform test product
now what's going on here now up here we
did the x where we have
let me view up here where we were
looking at um
here we go uh i have outdated
information on my credit card report
now we're looking at this
credit reporting consumer loan credit
reporting and if you remember this is
our list of those debt collection here's
our list of them they're not a huge
number
and so we're going to encode these
differently
this is just 0 1 2 3 4 and so on not
necessarily in that order by order by
the way
so be a little careful on order so we're
going to convert the labels to
one hot representation as our next step
and that's what this is doing so we have
our number classes in p max y train plus
one
our weight y train equals utilities to
categorical
so here's where we're taking our y value
in the training set and we do the same
with the test set
and we go ahead and run that so now
we've created a y train and a y test
where we've numbered our categorical
we've created a categorical data so it's
easy to
read the answer and translate it back
and we've encoded
up here our x
and we used a tokenizer
so a little different encoder puts in 0
1 2 3 for the different listings an
encoder or token
you can get tongue tied on these a
tokenizer takes and creates a huge in
this case we've limited to 1 000 words
each word is its own token and to really
see what we're looking at let me go
ahead and we're going to inspect the
elements and see what we ended up with
uh let me run this and so we have our y
train shape
there's our 1000 what is that 1000
maximum words so we've tokenized the top
thousand words
as each as its own feature
and the same thing with the x tests
those are x train and x test we have our
y train shape and our y train test shape
and um i thought the encoder depending
on how you set it
um
either to zero one two three or in this
case it actually puts it out as 18. so
it did the same thing as a tokenizer
as far as putting it as a zero one so
you have 18 choices there
and if we count these i'm guessing
there's 18 there now
this is the part which is we look at the
encoders and the tokenizers
these are the tools you need to process
text
the computer doesn't see
the hello on
you have to give it a zero or one in
each one of those and so this is all
about the text classification part
this is how we classify text
is we have to give it something that has
a number representation so once we've
sorted out our data and we've converted
it into something the computer can read
for doing text we want to go ahead and
create our model
and when we create our model one of the
things to be aware of is this is what we
call a black box model
now they've come a long ways in
understanding how these different
processes are created and so they're
starting to understand how you can put
these together and go back and say why
why does it pick this why does it pick
that how does it balance that
but it's black boxing that it's really
hard to do it's really hard to go in
there and figure out why it picks one
over the other
just by looking at the neural network
itself
there are other machine learning tools
like decision tree which make it much
easier to see those
changes and how it branches down but
they don't perform as well in many cases
and so we're going to go ahead and build
a model we'll go ahead and run this just
because it builds the model doesn't
actually
start fitting it yet let's take a look
at these different pieces
so we have our model which is going to
be sequential
that's a cross so we imported that at
the beginning from the cross setup
this
tells us
what's going on um that we're going to
be running this from top to bottom
and we're going to add a dense layer so
each time you see add
let me do
we look at these ad each one of these
we're adding a row
so these are all rows
and then of course our
rows you're like what is a row
uh so we talk about row these are your
layers
we have you can see right there input
layer we're going to add an activation
to this layer and we're going to use the
relu activation then we're going to add
a dropout rate and what this does is
they found that when they process a
neural network
instead of processing every neuron each
time you do the back propagation to
train it
you only process some of them so only
some of them are being trained by doing
that it's able to create the
differentiation between different
categories and it actually trains much
better instead of trying to train them
all at once
so that's what this is right here with
the drop out point five and then we
added add dense number classes
and the dense number classes is another
layer up here we have our add an
activation relu layer so we have our
input our relu layer with a dropout of
0.5 then we have a dense layer
which uses a soft max
activation there is a lot going on with
cross and these models you can get lost
in just the activation
here's our two activation
relu
is one type of activation softmax is
another
they work differently you can see when
we were talking about earlier we talked
about the different kinds of neural
networks
in cross and tensorflow each of those
layers can be a different neural network
layer and can function differently and
you can stack them on top of each other
and feed them into each other
and then the final thing of course is
your compile
we have what we're using for loss
remember we want to minimize loss so
category this is a type of way of
minimizing that loss
atom is an optimizer
you'll find there's a number of
optimizer atom is used for larger data
sets as you get to smaller data sets
you actually use a very different
optimizer in here
and we look at the accuracy
that's just when do we stop compiling
this data
how far do we go until it starts
building what they call a bias it starts
it's over fitted we want to stop at the
right moment
and then finally we get to
actually training our model this is that
black box we're going to fit it to the
data we don't know what's actually going
on in there but we want to go ahead and
run it
and i'm going to go ahead and start it
running because it takes a moment for it
to run through and you'll see the epic
feed down here as it goes through epic
105
and so forth we'll freeze this just for
a second
there we go
um so let's take a look at this we have
batch size um batch size oops i meant to
do that in an arrow
there we go
batch size
is how many rows of data we're going to
feed at a time
so you can feed larger rows there's
there's different reasons to feed them
at different sizes
um
really a lot of times people just leave
this as a default
depending and let it choose four of them
i'm not sure why they picked 32 in this
case there's probably when they were
messing with this 32 probably was a good
batch size for fitting it
the back end math deals with
differential equations
and some calculus which we won't get
into
so being aware of that that this batch
size affects how it does that that back
end differential equation in the reverse
propagation
um
tells us that this is actually a pretty
important number if you get it too big
it's going to not it's not going to fit
as well and if you get it too small it
takes way too long to process
and a lot of times there's what they
call a
reinforced learning neural network where
it's batch size of one what does that
mean well that means every action you
take has a feedback you program the
neural network so you can guess what
your next action is
that's very common like in trying to
beat video games with a
automated
setup in a neural network the epic says
we're going to go through
all the data in the training set
five times so that's what this remember
we talked about epics
that's what the epic is
and we can see when i let it go out here
we're on epic two five
so we'll go ahead and pause this i'm
gonna go ahead and pause it for a second
let it finish running
or while we're waiting we can actually
take a look at some of this data here
and see what it's actually generating
for us
and so we look at this
accuracy
loss
so we want to minimize loss
the metrics is accuracy and you can see
that we're going to want the accuracy to
go up and we want the loss to go down
and the loss is going to be
what we want to minimize and this is
just some of the metrics
and it talks about like
value loss
value accuracy and how they're changing
with each time we run it
and so you get to a point where no
longer gets better or worse and at that
point you really want to stop running it
you can overfit it and over fit it means
it's going to miss some of the
generalities that you need when solving
some of these solutions
and then i didn't talk too much about
what's actually going on here what are
we doing in the domain of this
particular one which it looks like it is
trying to figure out based on a consumer
complaint narrative maybe they send in a
complaint
what product is it connected to so maybe
they get the complaints before the
product or something like that i'm not
sure why you do this particular setup
that would be again a domain knowledge
in here so what we're doing is we're
using the consumer complaint narrative
to predict what product they're talking
about someone comes sends in an email
and says i have outdated information on
my credit report they're probably
talking about a credit card reporting if
you get a random email that says i
purchased a new car on blank the car
something something probably alone
that's what we're trying to do is if you
get a random input from the consumer
complaint narrative you can point to the
product that they're referring to
without having to call them up and ask
them i guess
that might be useful not sure
now that we've gone through all five
epics
let's go ahead and evaluate the accuracy
of our trained model
and so we have um we're going to go
ahead and do a score for the
model.evaluate
a nice crass
setup
where we can do the x test and the y
test the batch size verbose and then
we're going to it's going to generate a
score
and one of the things let's just go
ahead and print
so you can see why they broke out the
score let me just go ahead and print the
score in here let's go ahead and run
that
so it's testing the score it's going to
take a moment to go through all the data
and it gives us a nice score and it says
the test accuracy these can mean a lot
of different things but we have a 0.5
to be honest without looking at the data
i would have to look and see exactly
which things it missed on and how it how
it scored on there but it's it's getting
about you know half of it it's able to
pull in half of it and say hey
if this is the complaint this is what
it's connected to
keep in mind when we're talking about
text
that's really good can you imagine some
of the stuff i don't know if you've ever
worked in tech support or i.t or at a
counter in a in the mall or even in
taking orders someplace as a waiter or
waitress or fast food or whatever
when you try to understand people it
gets pretty crazy so even an accuracy
score like this is probably pretty good
for understanding some of this text
and there might be steps you could do to
improve that
and so let's go ahead and go through
here and look at actually using it
and we'll punch this and it says
how to generate prediction on individual
examples we have our text labels in our
encoder class
and we'll just go through a prediction
equals model predict np array of x test
of i
predict label text labels prediction
print test narrative
so forth this is just let's go ahead and
run it because reading through print
statements can be very painful sometimes
unless you actually see what's going on
so when the president came out with the
harp program dot dot dot the actual
label was mortgage the predicted label
was mortgage so when this person sent
this this complaint in maybe you don't
know what it's connected to yet you can
guess it's probably a mortgage i filed a
dispute with capital one bank on dot
and it says oh credit card well it turns
out it's actually debt collection it was
what it predicted
um
so yeah missed a little bit uh if a lot
of times when you dispute something
it probably is a debt collection
in this case it was specific to a credit
card okay so we missed that one
i am disputing account number xxs with
midland whatever
actual test label debt collection was
debt collection i opened a barclay card
on to help rebuild my credit credit card
credit card mortgage mortgage
so forth we can go through all of these
and you can see it does a pretty good
job it gets close or
in fact most of these are pulled in
correctly credit card reporting
this is a lot of what we talk about with
text
setup sentiment's a really big one
there's a whole sentimental libraries
out there
whether someone is positive or negative
towards something if you're pulling off
twitter feeds
uh you might want to look that up you
might want to look at connection towards
postings in what was it there was
running stock
i actually do some some stock
programming code so i end up coming back
to that a lot
finding sentiment feeds on different
stock values and different stocks out
there on
out of national publications
really helps trying to predict what the
stock's going to do what are people
going to do in buying and selling stock
same thing with this we can now predict
their
complaints and try to figure out what it
is they're complaining about
now that wraps up our deep learning demo
on text classification
and gives you a nice introduction to
deep learning as opposed to shallow
learning
bad joke on my part
but you can see how a deep learning
model can go in and do a lot of things
that you might not be able to do using
basic linear regression or many of the
other machine learning models
and text classification is one of those
where neural networks really shine
because they can pick up things that you
don't see you can't really measure in
other ways so what is a neural network
so hi guys i heard you want to know what
a neural network is here we have looks
like you just went shopping in a red tag
cell my robot's back so as a matter of
fact you have been using neural network
on a daily basis and today's world is
just amazing how much we use our new
technology we're not even aware of it
when you ask your mobile assistant to
perform a search for you you know like
saying your google or siri or whoever
you use amazon web self-driving cars so
that's the newest thing coming out
they're just now trying to make those
legal and different states in the u.s
and around the world even in the uk they
now have a self-driving cars going up
and down the streets pretty amazing
these are all neural network driven
computer games use it it's a lot of
computer games are driven by neural
networks in the back end as part of the
game system and how it adjusts to the
players and it's also used in processing
the map images on your phone so every
time you do a navigation someplace and
it opens it up they now use neural
networks to help you find the quickest
way to get there neural network a neural
network is a system or hardware that is
designed to operate like a human brain
in today's development this is so
important to understand because we don't
have anything else to compare it to i'm
sure someday in the future the computer
will redefine or the neural network or
the ai artificial intelligence will
redefine what these mean but as far as
we can today's world in today's
commercial development we have to
compare it to what humans do so it's we
want to compare and how it operates to a
human brain and how it solves problems
like a human does what can a neural
network do and really we're just going
to dive in deeper to we just covered and
look at other examples so what can a
neural network do well let's list out
the things neural networks can do for
you translate text boy we got google
translate and microsoft has their own
translate they have some really cool
they actually have an earpiece it's
supposed to start translating as you
talk what a cool technology what a cool
time to live identify faces can you
imagine all the uses for facial
identification in the case of our
sample or our code that we're going to
look at later we'll be identifying dogs
and cats so not quite as detailed as uh
understanding whose face belongs to who
i'm waiting for the google glasses to
come out so i can see who's who and
identify faces as i'm walking around
have a little name tag over them not out
there yet but boy we are close we can
identify the faces and they have all
kinds of technologies to bring that
information back to us recognize speech
goes along with the translate text so
now as you're talking into your
assistant it can use that to do commands
turn lights on all kinds of things you
can do with recognizing speech read had
written text they're starting to
translate all these old text documents
that they've had in storage instead of
doing it individually where somebody's
going through each text by themselves in
a room picture like an old raiders of
the lost ark theme where he's in the
back you know archaeologists studying
the text now it's fed into a computer
they take a picture they even use neural
networks to take a scroll that is so
messed up that they can't undo the
scroll and they x-ray it and then they
use that x-ray to translate the text off
of it without ever opening the scroll i
mean just way cool stuff they're
starting to do with all this and of
course control robots what would be a
neural network without bringing in the
robots and we have our own favorite
robot in the middle who goes to our red
tag cell and go shopping for us so you
know these are just a few of the
wonderful things that neural networks
are being applied to it's such an infant
stage technology what a wonderful time
to jump in and there are a lot of other
things it goes into i mean we could
spend just forever talking about all the
different applications from business to
whatever you can even imagine they're
now applying neural networks to help us
understand so now we talked a little bit
about all the cool things you can do
with the neural network let's dive in
and say how does a neural network work
so now we've come far enough to
understand how neural network works
let's go ahead and walk through this in
a nice graphical representation they
usually describe a neural network as
having different layers you'll see that
we've identified a green layer an orange
layer and a red layer the green layer is
the input so you have your data coming
in it picks up the input signals and
passes them to the next layer the next
layer does all kinds of calculations and
feature extraction it's called the
hidden layer a lot of times there's more
than one hidden layer we're only showing
one in this picture but we'll show you
how it looks like in a more detail a
little bit and then finally we have an
output layer this layer delivers the
final result so the only two things we
see is the input layer and the output
layer now let's make use of this neural
network and see how it works wonder how
traffic cameras identify vehicles
registration plate on the road to detect
speeding vehicles and those breaking the
law they got me going through a red
light the other day well last month
that's like the horrible thing they sent
you this picture of you and all your
information because they pulled it up
off of your license plate and your
picture they shouldn't have gone through
the red light so here we are and we have
an image of a car you can see the
license plates on there so let's
consider the image of this vehicle and
find out what's on the number plate the
picture itself is 28 by 28 pixels and
the image is fed as an input to identify
the registration plate each neuron has a
number called activation that represents
the grayscale value of the corresponding
pixel range and we range it from zero to
one one for a white pixel and zero for a
black pixel and you can see down here we
have an example where one of the pixels
is registered as like .82 meaning it's
probably pretty dark each neuron is lit
up when its activation is close to one
so as we get closer to black on white we
can really start seeing the details in
there and you can see again the pixel
shows this one up there it's like part
of the car and so it lights up so pixels
in the form of arrays are fed to the
input layer and so we see here the pixel
of a car image fed as an input and
you're going to see that the input layer
which is green is one dimension while
our image is two dimension now when we
look at our setup that we're programming
in python it has a cool feature that
automatically does the work for us if
you're working with an older neural
network pattern package you then convert
each one of those rows so it's all one
array so you'd have like row one and
then just tack row two on to the end you
can almost feed the image directly into
some of these neural networks the key is
though is that if you're using a 28 by
28 and you get a picture of this 30 by
30 shrink the 30 by 30 down to fit the
28 by 28 so you can't increase the
number of input in this case green dots
it's very important to remember when you
work on neural networks and let's name
the inputs x1 x2 x3 respectively so each
one of those represents one of the
pixels coming in and the input layer
passes it to the hidden layer and you
can see here we now have two hidden
layers in this image in the orange and
each one of those pixels connects to
each one of those hidden layers and the
interconnections are assigned weights at
random so they get these random weights
that come through that if x1 lights up
then it's going to be x1 times this
weight going into the hidden layer and
we sum those weights the weights are
multiplied with the input signal and a
bias is added to all of them so as you
can see here we have x1 comes in and it
actually goes to all the different
hidden layer nodes or in this case
whatever you want to call them network
setup the orange dots and so you take
the value of x1 you multiply it by the
weight for the next hidden layer so x1
goes to hidden layer one x1 goes to
hidden layer two x1 goes hidden layer
one node two hidden layer one node three
and so on and the bias a lot of times
they just put the bias in as like
another green dot or another orange dot
and they give the bias a value one and
then all the weights go in from the bias
into the next node so the bias can
change we always just remember that you
need to have that bias in there there's
things that can be done with it
generally most the packages out there
control that for you so you don't have
to worry about figuring out what the
bias is but if you ever dive deep into
neural networks you got to remember
there's a bias or the answer won't come
out correctly the weighted sum of the
input is fed as an input to the
activation function to decide which
nodes to fire and for feature extraction
as the signal flows within the hidden
layers the weighted sum of inputs is
calculated and is fed to the activation
function in each layer to decide which
nodes to fire so here's our feature
extraction of the number plate and you
can see these are still hidden nodes in
the middle and this becomes important
we're going to take a little detour here
and look at the activation function so
we're going to dive just a little bit
into the math so you start to understand
where some of the games go on when
you're playing with neural networks in
your programming so let's look at the
different activation functions before we
move ahead here's our friendly red tag
shopping robot and so one is the sigmoid
function and the sigmoid function which
is 1 over 1 plus e to the minus x takes
the x value and you can see where it
generates almost a 0 and almost a 1 with
a very small area in the middle where it
crosses over and we can use that value
to feed into another function so if it's
really uncertain it might have a 0.1 or
0.2 or 0.3 but for the most part it's
going to be really close to 1 and really
close to this case 0 0 to 1. the
threshold function so if you don't want
to worry about the uncertainty in the
middle you just say oh if x is greater
than or equal to zero if not then x is
zero so it's either zero or one really
straightforward there's no in between in
the middle and then you have the what
they call the relu relu function and you
can see here where it puts out the value
but then it says well if it's over one
it's going to be one and if it's less
than zero it's zero so it kind of just
dead ends it on those two ends but
allows all the values in the middle and
again this like the sigmoid function
allows that information to go to the
next level so it might be important to
know if it's a 0.1 or a minus 0.1 the
next hidden layer might pick that up and
say oh this piece of information is
uncertain or this value has a very low
certainty to it and then the hyperbolic
tangent function and you can see here
it's a 1 minus e to the minus 2x over 1
plus e to the minus 2x and it's very
much along the same theme a little bit
different in here in that it goes
between -1 and one so you'll see some of
these they go zero to one but this one
goes minus one to one and if it's less
than zero it's you know it doesn't fire
and if it's over zero it fires and it
also still puts out a value so you still
have a value you can get off of that
just like you can with the sigmoid
function and the relu function very
similar in use and i believe the
original used to be everything was done
in the sigmoid function that was the
most commonly used and now they just
kind of use more the relu function the
reason is one it processes faster
because you already have the value and
you don't have to add another compute
the one over one plus e to the minus x
for each hidden node and the data coming
off works pretty good as far as putting
it into the next level if you want to
know just how close it is to zero how
close is it not to functioning you know
is it minus 0.1 minus 0.2 usually
they're float values you get like minus
point minus 0.00138 or something so yeah
important information but the relu is
most commonly used these days as far as
the setup we're using but you'll also
see the sigmoid function very commonly
used also now that you know what an
activation function is let's get back to
the neural network so finally the model
would predict the outcome of applying a
suitable activation function to the
output layer so we go in here we look at
this we have the optical character
recognition ocr is used on the images to
convert it into a text in order to
identify what's written on the plate and
as it comes out you'll see the red node
and the red node might actually
represent just a letter a so there's
usually a lot of outputs when you're
doing text identification we're not
going to show that on here but you might
have it even in the order it might be
what order the license plates in so you
might have a b c d e f g
you know the alphabet plus the numbers
and you might have the one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
places so it's a very large array that
comes out it's not a small amount of you
know we show three dots coming in eight
hidden layer nodes you know two sets of
four we just saw one red coming out a
lot of times this is uh you know 28
times 28 if you did 30 times 30 that's
900 nodes so 28 is a little bit less
than that just on the input and so you
can imagine the hidden layer is just as
big each hidden layer is just as big if
not bigger and the output is going to be
there's so many digits yeah it's a lot
there's it's a huge amount of input and
output but we're only showing you just
you know it would be hard to show in one
picture and so it comes up and this is
what it finally gets out in the output
as it identifies a number on the plate
and in this case we have 0 8
d
0 3 8 5 8. error in the output is back
propagated through the network and
weights are adjusted to minimize the
error rate this is calculated by a cost
function when we're training our data
this is what's used and we'll look at
that in the code when we do the data
training so we have stuff we know the
answer to and then we put the
information through and it says yes that
was correct or no because remember we
randomly set all the weights to begin
with and if it's wrong we take that
error how far off are you you know are
you off but is it if it was like minus
one you're just a little bit off if it's
like minus 300 was your output remember
when we're looking at those different
options you know hyperbolic or whatever
and we're looking at the rel the rel
doesn't have a limit on top or bottom it
actually just generates a number so if
it's way off you have to adjust those
weights a lot but if it's pretty close
you might adjust the weights just a
little bit and you keep adjusting the
weights until they fit all the different
training models you put in so you might
have 500 training models and those
weights will adjust using the back
propagation it sends the error backward
the output is compared with the original
result and multiple iterations are done
to get the maximum accuracy so not only
does it look at each one but it goes
through it and just keeps cycling
through these the data making small
changes in the network until it gets the
right answers with every iteration the
weights at every interconnection are
adjusted based on the error we're not
going to dive into that math because it
is a differential equation and it gets a
little complicated but i will talk a
little bit about some of the different
options they have when we look at the
code so we've explored a neural network
let's look at the different types of
artificial neural networks and this is
like the biggest area growing is how
these all come together let's see the
different types of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so
here's a human brain i feel sorry for
that poor guy so we have a feed for
forward neural network simplest form of
a they call it a n a neural network data
travels only in one direction input to
output this is what we just looked at so
as the data comes in all the weights are
added it goes to the hidden layer all
the weights are added it goes to the
next hidden layer all the weights are
added and it goes to the output the only
time you use the reverse propagation is
to train it so when you actually use it
it's very fast when you're training it
it takes a while because it has to
iterate through all your training data
and you start getting into big data
because you can train these with a huge
amount of data the more data you put in
the better train they get the
applications vision and speech
recognition actually they're pretty much
everything we talked about a lot almost
all of them use this form of neural
network at some level radio basis
function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched a
sesame street as a kid that dates me so
it brings things together and this is a
great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six they keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns and data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict what your next change you need
to make is to get to where the drone
wants to go applications text-to-speech
conversation model so i talked about
drones but you know just identifying on
lexis or google assistant or any of
these they're starting to add in i'd
like to play a song on my pandora and
i'd like it to be at volume 90
so you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so that
it can do a face recognition on each
person applications used in signal and
image processing in this case i use
facial images or google picture images
as one of the options modular neural
network
it has a collection of different neural
networks working together to get the
output so wow we just went through all
these different types of neural networks
and the final one is to put multiple
neural networks together i mentioned
that a little bit when we separated
people in a larger photo in individuals
in the photo and then do the facial
recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are and do the facial
recognition applications still
undergoing research this is a cutting
edge you hear the term pipeline and
there's actual in python code and in
almost all the different neural network
setups out there they now have a
pipeline feature usually and it just
means you take the data from one neural
network and maybe another neural network
or you put it into the next neural
network and then you take three or four
other neural networks and feed them into
another one so how we connect the neural
networks is really just cutting edge and
it's so experimental i mean it's almost
creative in its nature there's not
really a science to it because each
specific domain has different things
it's looking at so if you're in the
banking domain it's going to be
different than the medical domain than
the automatic car domain and suddenly
figuring out how those all fit together
is just a lot of fun and really cool so
we have our types of artificial neural
network we have our feed forward neural
network we have a radial basis function
neural network we have our cohenin self
organizing neural network recurrent
neural network convolution neural
network and modular neural network where
it brings them all together and no the
colors on the brain do not match what
your brain actually does but they do
bring it out that most of these were
developed by understanding how humans
learn and as we understand more and more
of how humans learn we can build
something in the computer industry to
mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
a dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python
3.6 it's always nice to tell people the
version of python because that does
affect sometimes which modules you load
and everything and we're going to start
by importing the required packages i
told you we're going to do this in
karass so we're going to import from
karas models sequential from the cross
layers conversion 2d or conv 2d max
pooling 2d flatten and dense and we'll
talk about what each one of these do in
just a second but before we do that
let's talk a little bit about the
environment we're going to work in and
you know in fact let me go ahead and
open a
the website cross's website so we can
learn a little bit more about cross so
here we are on the cross website and
it's a k-e-r-a-s dot io that's the
official website for cross and the first
thing you'll notice is that cross runs
on top of either tensorflow
cntk and i think it's pronounced thanos
or thiano what's important on here is
that tensorflow and the same is true for
all these but tensorflow is probably one
of the most widely used currently
packages out there with the cross and of
course you know tomorrow this is all
going to change it's all going to
disappear and they'll have something new
out there so make sure when you're
learning this code that you understand
what's going on and also know the code i
mean look when you look at the code it's
not as complicated once you understand
what's going on the code itself is
pretty straightforward and the reason we
like karas and the reason that people
are jumping on it right now is such a
big deal is if we come down here let me
just scroll down a little bit we talk
about user friendliness modularity easy
extensibility work with python python is
a big one because a lot of people in
data science now use python although you
can actually access cross other ways if
we continue down here is layers and this
is where it gets really cool when we're
working with cross you just add layers
on remember those hidden layers we were
talking about and we talked about the
relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size there
we go that's big i can add in an r e l u
layer and then i can add in a soft max
layer in the next instance we didn't
talk about soft max so you could do each
layer separate now if i'm working in
some of the other kits i use i take that
and i have one setup and then i feed the
output into the next one this one i can
just add hidden layer after hidden layer
with the different information in it
which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part i'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note i'm
using anaconda with python in it and i
went ahead and created my own package
and i called it the cross python36
because i'm in python36 anaconda is cool
that way you can create different
environments real easily if you're doing
a lot of different experimenting with
these different packages probably want
to create your own environment in there
and the first thing as you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipy the scikit-learn
pillow and h5py are both needed for the
tensorflow and then putting the cross on
there and then you'll see here and pip
is just a standard installer that you
use with python you'll see here that we
did pip install tensorflow since we're
going to do cross on top of tensorflow
and then pip install and i went ahead
and used the github so git plus get and
you'll see here github.com this is one
of their releases one of the most
current release on there that goes on
top of tensorflow and you can look up
these instructions pretty much anywhere
this is for doing it on anaconda
certainly you'd want to install these if
you're doing it in ubuntu server setup
you'd want to get i don't think you need
the h5py and ubuntu but you do need the
rest in there because they are
dependencies in there and it's pretty
straightforward and that's actually in
some of the instructions they have on
their website so you don't have to
initially go through this just remember
their website on there and then when i'm
under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can say i have
python 30.5 and python 36. i used to
have a bunch of other ones but it kind
of cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupyter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my in this case
i'm using google chrome and in here i
could go and just create a new document
in here and this is all in your browser
window when you use the anaconda do you
have to use anaconda and jupiter
notebook no you can use any kind of
python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequential it's
under the models because that's the
model we're going to use as far as our
neural network and then we have layers
and we have conversion 2d max pooling 2d
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly i talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two-dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this has just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you notice i'm always sipping coffee i
always have a in my case latte next to
me an espresso so the next step is to go
ahead and initialize we're going to call
it the cnn or classifier neural network
and the reason we call it a classifier
is because it's going to classify it
between two things it's going to be cat
or dog so when you're doing
classification you're picking specific
objects you're specific it's a true or
false yes no it is something or it's not
so first thing we're going to create our
classifier and it's going to equal
sequential so their sequential setup is
the classifier that's the actual model
we're using that's the neural network so
we call it a classifier and the next
step is to add in our convolution and
let me just do a let me shrink that down
in size you can see the whole line and
let's talk a little bit about what's
going on here i have my classifier and i
add something what am i adding well i'm
adding my first layer this first layer
we're adding in is probably the one that
takes the most work to make sure you
have it set correct and the reason i say
that this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 64 by 64 by 3. what
does that mean well that means that our
pictures coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that keras knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the relu model like
i said that is the most commonly used
now because one it's fast doesn't have
the added calculations in it it just
says here's a value coming out based on
the weights and the value going in and
from there you know it's uh if it's over
one then it's good or over zero it's
good if it's under zero then it's
considered not active and then we have
this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple of things it's doing in here a
little bit more in depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64 by three and
we're just converting it to two
dimensional kind of setup so it's very
aware that this is a photograph and that
different pieces are next to each other
and then we're going to add in a second
convolutional layer that's what the conv
stands for 2d so these are hidden layers
so we have our input layer and our two
hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing with
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a max pooling 2d and we put a pool
size equals 2 2. and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the big data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because it's a 2d photograph but we had
you know two dimensions by we actually
have 64 by 64 by three so now we're just
getting it down to a two by two just the
two dimension two dimensional instead of
having the third dimension of colors and
we'll go ahead and run these we're not
really seeing anything in our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes cross
so nice is i can with just a couple
flips of code put in a whole new layer
that does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flattened setup and
then we're going to also add a layer a
dense layer and then we're going to add
in another dense layer and then we're
going to build it we're going to compile
this whole thing together so let's flip
over and see what that looks like and
we've even numbered them for you so
we're going to do the flattening and
flatten is exactly what it sounds like
we've been working in a two-dimensional
array of picture which actually is in
three dimensions because of the pixels
the pixels have a whole another
dimension to it of three different
values and we've kind of resized those
down to two by two but now we're just
going to flatten it i don't want to have
multiple dimensions being worked on by
tensor and by keras i want just a single
array so it's flattened out and then
step four full connection so we add in
our final two layers and you could
actually do all kinds of things with
this you could actually leave out this
some of these layers and play with them
you do need to flatten it that's very
important then we want to use the dents
again we're taking this and we're taking
whatever came into it so once we take
all those different the two dimensions
or three dimensions as they are and we
flatten it to one dimension we want to
take that and we're going to pull it
into units of 128. they got that you
just say where did they get 128 from you
could actually play with that number and
get all kinds of weird results but in
this case we took the 64 plus 64 is 128.
you could probably even do this with 64
or 32. usually you want to keep it in
the same multiple of whatever the data
shape you're already using is in and
we're using the activation the relu just
like we did before and then we finally
filter all that into
a single output and it has how many
units one why because we want to know
whether true or false it's either a dog
or a cat you could say one is dog zero
is cat or maybe you're a cat lover and
it's one is cat and zero is dog if you
love both dogs and cats
you're gonna have to choose and then we
use the sigmoid activation if you
remember from before we had the relu and
there's also the sigmoid sigmoid just
makes it clear it's yes or no we don't
want any kind of in-between number
coming out and we'll go ahead and run
this and you'll see it's still all in
setup and then finally we want to go
ahead and compile and let's put the
compiling our classifier neural network
and we're going to use the optimizer
atom and i hinted at this just a little
bit before where does adam come in where
does an optimizer come in well the
optimizer is the reverse propagation
when we're training it it goes all the
way through and says error and then how
does it readjust those weights there are
a number of them atom is the most
commonly used and it works best on large
data most people stick with the atom
because when they're testing on smaller
data see if their model is going to go
through and get all their errors out
before they run it on larger data sets
they're going to run it on atom anyway
so they just leave it on atom most
commonly used but there are some other
ones out there you should be aware of
that that you might try them if you're
stuck in a bind or you might floor that
in the future but usually atom is just
fine on there and then you have two more
settings you have loss and metrics we're
not going to dig too much into loss or
metrics these are things you really have
to explore cross because there are so
many choices this is how it computes the
error there's so many different ways to
on your back propagation and your
training so we're using the atom model
but you can compute the error by
standard deviation standard deviation
squared they use binary cross entropy
i'd have to look that up to even know
what that is there's so many of these a
lot of times you just start with the
ones that look correct that are most
commonly used and then you have to go
read the cross site and actually see
what these different losses and metrics
and what different options they have so
we're not going to get too much into
them other than to reference you over to
the cross website to explore them deeper
but we are going to go ahead and run
them and now we've set up our classifier
so we have an object classifier and if
you go back up here you'll see that
we've added in step one we added in our
layer for the input we added a layer
that comes in there and uses the relu
for activation and then it pulls the
data so this is even though these are
two layers the actual neural network
layer is up here and then it uses this
to pull the data into a two by two so
into two dimensional array from a
three-dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our outer
flattened and then we add another dense
what they call dense layer this dense
layer goes in there and it downsizes it
to 128 it reduces it so you can look at
this as we're mapping all this data down
the two-dimensional setup and then we
flatten it so we map it to a flattened
map and then we take it and reduce it
down to 128 and we use the relu again
and then finally we reduce that down to
just a single output and we use the
sigmoid to do that to figure out whether
it's yes no true false in this case cat
or dog and then finally once we put all
these layers together we compile them
that's what we've done here and we've
compiled them as far as how it trains to
use these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it where you
already know the answer but you don't
want to use that as part of the training
set so in here we jump into part two
fitting the classifier neural network to
the images and then from cross let me
just zoom in there i always love that
about working with jupiter notebooks you
can really see we're going to come in
here we do the cross pre-processing and
image and we import image data generator
so nice of course it's such a high-end
product right now going out and since
images are so common they already have
all this stuff to help us process the
data which is great and so we come in
here we do train data gin and we're
going to create our object for helping
us train it for reshaping the data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255. so we want to divide it by 255
and it will generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with if the
photos are different shapes and sizes
like i said it's a wonderful package you
really need to dig in deep to see all
the different options you have for
setting up your images for right now
though we're going to stick with some
basic stuff here and let me go ahead and
run this code and again it doesn't
really do anything because we're still
setting up the pre-processing let's take
a look at this next set of code and this
one is just huge we're creating the
training set so the training set is
going to go in here and it's going to
use our train data gen we just created
dot flow from directory it's going to
access in this case the path data set
training set that's a folder so it's
going to pull all the images out of that
folder now i'm actually running this in
the folder that the data sets in so if
you're doing the same setup and you load
your data in there and you're doing this
make sure wherever your jupyter notebook
is saving things to that you create this
path or you can do the complete path if
you need to you know c colon slash etc
and the target size the batch size and
class mode is binary so the class is
we're switching everything to a binary
value batch size what the heck is batch
size well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64.
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using twenty percent of the images as
test and eighty percent to train it and
then finally we've set up all our data
we've set up all our layers which is
where all the work is is uh cleaning up
that data and making sure it's going in
there correctly and we're actually going
to fit it we're going to train our data
set and let's see what that looks like
and here we go let's put the information
in here and let's just take a quick look
at what we're looking at with our fit
generator we have our
dot fit generator that's our back
propagation so the information goes
through forward with a picture and it
says oh you're either right or you're
wrong and then the air goes backward and
reprograms all those weights so we're
training our neural network and of
course we're using the training set
remember we created the training set up
here and then we're going steps per epic
so it's 8 000 steps epic means that
that's how many times we go through all
the pictures so we're going to rerun
each of the pictures and we're going to
go through the whole data set 25 times
but we're going to look at each picture
during each epic 8 000 times so we're
really programming the heck out of this
and going back over it and then they
have validation data equals test set so
we have our training set and then we're
gonna have our test set to validate it
so we're gonna do this all in one shot
and we're gonna look at that and they're
gonna do 200 steps for each validation
and we'll see what that looks like in
just a minute let's go ahead and run our
training here and we're going to fit our
data and as it goes it says epic one of
25 you start realizing that this is
going to take a while on my older
computer it takes about 45 minutes i
have a dual processor and we're
processing uh 10 000 photos that's not a
small amount of photographs to process
so if you're on your laptop in which i
am it's going to take a while so let's
go ahead and go get our cup of coffee
and a sip and come back and see what
this looks like so i'm back you didn't
know i was gone that was actually a
lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8 000
25 epics and validation steps 2 000 and
i changed these to 4 000 epics or 4 000
steps per epic
10 epics and just 10 validation steps
and this will cause problems if you're
doing this as a commercial release but
for demo purposes this should work and
if you remember our steps per epic
that's how many photos we're going to
process in fact let me go ahead and get
my drawing pin out and let's just
highlight that right here well we have 8
000 pictures we're going through so for
each epic i'm going to change this to 4
000 i'm going to cut that in half so
it's going to randomly pick 4 000
pictures each time it goes through an
epic and the epic is how many processes
so this is 25 and i'm just going to cut
that to 10. so instead of doing 25 runs
through 8 000 photos each which you can
do the math of 25 times 8 000. i'm only
going to do 10 through 4 000 so i'm
going to run this 40 000 times through
the processes and the next thing i know
that you'll you'll want to notice is
that i also changed the validation step
and this would cause some major problems
in releasing because i dropped it all
the way down to 10. with the validation
step does is it says we have 2 000
photos in our trainings or in our
testing set and we're going to use that
for validation well i'm only going to
use a random 10 of those to validate so
not really the best settings but let me
show you why we did that let's scroll
down here just a little bit and let's
look at the output here and see what
that what's going on there so i've got
my drawing tool back on and you'll see
here it lists a run so each time it goes
through an epic it's going to do 4 000
steps and this is where the 4 000 comes
in so that's where we have we have epic
one of 10 4 000 steps it's randomly
picking half the pictures in the file
and going through them and then we're
going to look at this number right here
that is for the whole epic and that's
241
seconds and if you remember correctly
you divide that by 60 you get minutes if
you divide that by 60 you get hours or
you can just divide the whole thing by
60 times 60 which is 3600. if 3600 is an
hour this is roughly 45 minutes right
here and that's 45 minutes to process
half the pictures so if i was doing all
the pictures we're talking an hour and a
half per epic times 36 or no 25 they had
25 up above 25
so that's roughly a couple days a couple
days of processing well for this demo we
don't want to do that i don't want to
come back the next day plus my computer
did a reboot in the middle of the night
so we look at this and we say okay let's
we're just testing this out my computer
that i'm running this on is a dual core
processor runs point nine gigahertz per
second for a laptop you know it's good
about four years ago but for running
something like this is probably a little
slow so we cut the times down and the
last one was validation we're only
validating it on a random 10 photos and
this comes into effect because you're
going to see down here where we have
accuracy value loss
value accuracy and loss those are very
important numbers to look at so the 10
means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important let me just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down
and the value accuracy continues to go
up that means there's a bias that means
i'm memorizing the photos i'm looking at
i'm not actually looking for what makes
a dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these and of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go and take a look at that and
see what that looks like in code and put
that in our jupiter notebook all right
and let's paste that in here and we'll
start by importing numpy as np numpy is
a very common package i pretty much
import it on any python project i'm
working on another one i use regularly
is pandas they're just ways of
organizing the data and then np is
usually the standard in most machine
learning tools as a return for the data
array although you know you can use the
standard data array from python and we
have cross pre-processing import image
fish that all look familiar because
we're going to take a test image and
we're going to set that equal to in this
case cat or dog one as you can see over
here and you know let me get my drawing
tool back on so let's take a look at
this we have our test image we're
loading and in here we have test image
one and this one hasn't data hasn't seen
this one at all so this is all new oh
let me shrink the screen down let me
start that over so here we have my test
image and we went ahead and the cross
processing has this nice image set up so
we're going to load the image and we're
going to alter it to a 64 by 64 print so
right off the bat we're going to cross
as nice that way it automatically sets
it up for us so we don't have to redo
all our images and find a way to reset
those and then we use also to set the
image to an array so again we're all in
pre-processing the data just like we
pre-processed before with our test
information and our training data and
then we use the numpy here's our numpy
that's uh from our right up here
important numpy as np expand the
dimensions test image axes equal zero so
it puts it into a single array and then
finally all that work all that
pre-processing and all we do is we run
the result we click on here we go result
equals classifier predict test image and
then we find out well what is the test
image and let's just take a quick look
and just see what that is and you can
see when i ran it it comes up dog and if
we look at those images there it is cat
or dog image number one that looks like
a nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but according to
our software says it's a dog and uh we
have a second picture over here let's
just see what happens when we run the
second picture we can go up here and
change this uh from dog image one to two
we'll run that and it comes down here
and says cat you can see me highlighting
it down there as cat so our process
works we are able to label a dog a dog
and a cat a cat just from the pictures
there we go cleared my drawing tool and
the last thing i want you to notice when
we come back up here to when i ran it
you'll see it has an accuracy of 1 and
the value accuracy of 1. well the value
accuracy is the important one because
the value accuracy is what it actually
runs on the test data remember i'm only
testing it on i'm only validating it on
a random 10 photos and those 10 folders
just happened to come up one now when
they ran this on the server it actually
came up about 86 percent this is why
cutting these numbers down so far for a
commercial release is bad so you want to
make sure you're a little careful of
that when you're testing your stuff that
you change these numbers back when you
run it on a more enterprise computer
other than your old laptop that you're
just practicing on or messing with and
we come down here and again you know we
have the validation of cat and so we
have successfully built a neural network
that could distinguish between photos of
a cat and a dog imagine all the other
things you could distinguish imagine all
the different industries you could dive
into with that just being able to
understand those two difference of
pictures what about mosquitoes could you
find the mosquitoes that bite versus
mosquitoes that are friendly it turns
out the mosquitoes that bite us are only
four percent of the mosquito population
if even that maybe two percent there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of industries sprouting up
and i said it before i'll say it again
what an exciting time to live in with
these tools and that we get to play with
what is deep learning again this video
is not about deep learning but there are
other videos we have created in detail
about what is deep learning in this
video we'll just touch upon the basics
so that that's like a nice segue into
tensorflow so deep learning is
in a way a subset of machine learning
and we use
primarily neural networks in deep
learning and the underlying technology
behind artificial intelligence is deep
learning and here we teach them how to
recognize let's say images or voice and
so on and so forth so it is a learning
mechanism but here unlike traditional
machine learning the data is far more
complicated and far more unstructured
like it could be primarily in the form
of images or audio files or text files
and one of the core components of deep
learning is neural network and a neural
network somewhat looks like this there
is something known as an input layer and
then there is an output layer and in
between there are a bunch of hidden
layers so typically there would be at
least one hidden layer and anything more
than one hidden layer is known as a deep
neural network so any neural network
with more than three layers altogether
right is known as a deep neural network
all right so what are the functions of
the various layers let's take a quick
look so the input layer accepts the
input so this could be in the form of
let's say if it is an image it could be
the pixel values of the images so that's
what the input layer does and then it
passes on to the hidden layers and the
hidden layers in turn perform certain
computations and they have what is known
as
as a part of the training they have
these weights and biases that they keep
updating till the training process is
complete and each neuron has multiple
weights and there will be one bias and
these are like variables and we will see
when we go into the tensorflow code what
we actually mean by that and so that's
what the hidden layer does it does a
bunch of computation and passes its
values to the output layer and then the
output layer in turn gives the output it
could be in the form of a class so for
example if we are doing classification
it tells us which class a particular
image maybe belongs to for example let's
say if this is a image classification
application then the input could be a
bunch of images of maybe cats and dogs
and the output will be like it will say
okay if this is activated this gives a
zero and this gives a one that means it
is a cat if this gives a one and this
gives us zero that means it is a dot so
that is a kind of a binary
classification and that can be extended
with multiple neurons on the output side
to have many more classes for example or
it can also be used for regression as
well not necessarily only classification
again since this video is not about deep
learning or machine learning or neural
network we will probably not go into a
lot of details but you can check other
videos where we have given a lot more
details about neural networks and deep
learning and so on so in order to
develop a deep learning application how
do you go about primarily there are two
or three components that are required in
order to develop deep learning
application you need obviously a
programming language so typically python
is used and that's what we are going to
use in this particular video but you can
also use other languages like java or c
plus plus and so on and there are some
libraries that are readily available and
for primarily for doing um machine
learning and deep learning programming
so these are a list of libraries these
are by no means the exhaustive list but
some of the most common ones like keras
theano tensorflow and so on and so forth
tensorflow has
nowadays become very very popular this
is developed by google and it is an open
source library and keras was there
before now keras has actually now become
a part of tensorflow as well so it is
one player about tensorflow so in that
sense they're well integrated so
combination of keras and uh tensorflow
is uh pretty good then of course you
have a torch and tl4j and so on and so
forth so there are multiple libraries
but this video is about tensorflow and
we will be focusing on tensorflow what
are the benefits of tensorflow and what
are its components and our towards the
end we will show you a code in python
we've written a code in python by the
way tensorflow can be used with multiple
languages it supports multiple languages
though python is by far the most popular
language so let's take a look at what
exactly is tensorflow and why we are so
excited about tensorflow so tensorflow
offers
apis now we can earlier without when
these libraries none of these libraries
were there even then we were doing
people were doing machine learning and
deep learning and so on but the coding
mechanism was much more complicated what
these libraries like tensorflow offer is
they provide kind of a high level api so
that we don't have to go really deep
into writing all the stuff that is
required let's say to prepare a neural
network and to even configure or even to
program a neuron and so on right so
these are done by the library so all you
need to do is they offer a higher level
api you need to use that api and call
that api and maybe pass the data and
that would pretty much it's much easier
rather than actually going down and
writing everything by yourself so
tensorflow that way it offers apis for
to write your code in python or even c
plus plus and so on other languages java
as well it has an integration with r as
well apparently okay and it supports
cpus as well as gpus now deep learning
applications are very compute intensive
especially the training process needs a
lot of computation it takes very long as
you can imagine because the the data
size is large and there are so many
iterative processes there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal cpu typically it would take
much longer but gpus are graphical
processing units you must have heard
gpus in the context of games and so on
because where you need the screen needs
to be of high resolution and the images
need to be of high resolution and so on
so gpus that as the name such as
graphical processing unit were
originally designed for that but since
they are very good at handling this kind
of iterative calculations and so on now
they are kind of they are being used or
leveraged rather for doing or developing
deep learning applications and
tensorflow supports gpus as well as cpus
so i think that's one of the major
advantages of tensorflow as well now
again what is exactly tensorflow it's a
open source library developed by google
and open source and primarily for deep
learning development but tensorflow also
supports traditional machine learning by
the way so if you want to do some
traditional machine learning we can do
it however it is probably a bit of a
overhead to use tensorflow for doing
traditional machine learning and this is
really good for performing deep learning
activities and again if you want to get
into more details about what's the
difference between machine learning and
deep learning there is another video
about it you can probably take a look at
that video what else it is developed
originally for large numerical
computation so originally when
tensorflow was developed they never
thought of it as a keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really very good for deep
learning development and therefore
google has open sourced it and
tensorflow as the name suggests the data
is in the form of what is known as
tensors these are like multi-dimensional
arrays and they are very handy in
handling large amounts of data and we
will see that as well as we move forward
and then of course the execution
mechanism is in the form of graphs so
that makes it much easier to execute
this code in a distributed manner across
a cluster of computers and and also
using gpus and so on and so forth right
so that's a quick overview about what is
uh tensorflow we will see a little bit
more detail the two major components
that is basically the tensors and the
graphs let's take a look at what they
are so what are tensors tensor is as i
mentioned earlier it is like a
multi-dimensional array in which the
data is stored now when we are doing
deep learning especially the training
process you will have large amounts of
data and the data is in typically in a
very complicated format and it really
helps when you are able to put this use
this or store it in a compact way and so
tensors actually offer a very nice and
compact way of storing the data handling
the data during computation this is not
really for storing on your hard disk or
things like that but in memory when you
are doing the computation tenses are
really really very handy in terms of
keeping the data compact because they
are like multi-dimensional arrays so the
data is stored in tensors and then it is
fed into the neural network and then you
get the output all right so there are
some terms associated with tensors let's
get ourselves familiarized one is uh the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically dimension is
like the number of elements in a way so
for example this is a five by four
dimension tensor and then you can have
again the multi dimensions right so you
can this can be like three by three by
three so that is uh the dimension and
then you have ranks so what are tensor
at ranks ranks are basically
traditionally we would have thought of
as dimensions that is actually in this
case it is called rank so it becomes
easier when we see examples so a
tensor's rank is supposed to be zero
when there is only one element we also
call this as scalar so just one element
and this is not really a vector it's
just an element like 200 it's also known
as a scalar so such a tensor is supposed
to be having a rank of zero then you
have let's say one dimensional array
this is a vector with a row of elements
this has rank of one now if you have
traditionally what we called as a two
dimensional like a matrix for example
then the rank is two and in this case
the rank is 3 and it can have more ranks
as well as i mentioned it is like a
multi-dimensional array so you can have
rank 5 6 and so on okay so those are the
terminologies in tensorflow terms
dimensions and ranks so this is just to
make sure that we are picking the same
language so whenever we talk about the
rank of a tensor you understand what
exactly is meant by that now in addition
to tensors in which the data is actually
stored all right so the data is stored
in the tensors and then once you have
the data there is a computation that
needs to be done now the computation
happens in the form of graphs so what we
typically in a tensorflow program what
we do is it's not like traditional
programming where you just write a bunch
of lines and then everything gets
executed in sequence here we prepare
graphs various nodes and then these are
executed in the form of a session and
they use the data from these tensors now
i know this is a slightly new concept
for a lot of you so it may be a little
difficult to probably understand in the
first cut but when we look at the code
when we go into the tutorial the code
walkthrough i think that time it will
become much clearer as well but to start
with just uh we need to keep in mind
that we have to first prepare a graph
and when you're preparing the graph no
none of the code is actually getting
executed you write the code to prepare
the graph and then you execute that
graph so that's the way by creating a
session that's the way tensorflow
program works so and each of these
computation is represented as what is
known as a data flow graph and we will
also see that whenever you start
tensorflow when you create an object
tensorflow object there will be what is
known as the default graph and then if
required i know probably in the
beginning it may not be required but in
more advanced programming you can
actually have multiple graphs instead of
the default graph you can create your
own graph and have multiple graphs and
use it as well but there is always
whenever you create a tensorflow object
there will be a default graph and this
will be very nicely illustrated in the
example code that we will take to
explain this so there it becomes much
clearer than in these slides so the
graph gets executed and it processes all
the data that we are feeding all the
external data will be fed in the form of
what is known as placeholders and then
you have variables and constants again
this will also become clear when we take
a look at the code and once you have the
graph then the execution can be enabled
either on regular cpus or on gpus and
also in a distributed mode so that the
processing becomes much faster as i
mentioned the training of the models in
deep learning takes extremely long
because of the large amount of data and
therefore using tensorflow actually
makes it much easier to write the code
for gpus or cpus and then execute it in
a distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is uh
you need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for preparing the
graph and then you create what is known
as a session and then in that session
you ask the session to execute this
graph so this will again become much
clearer when we look at the code as some
of you may be aware it's not that easy
to set up the tensorflow environment
there are several components there are
several possibilities for example
you can set up on windows you can set up
on ubuntu now ubuntu has multiple
versions which version to use and then
you have python which release of python
to use whether to do a pip install
whether to do install using anaconda and
how do you then link it up with jupiter
notebook these are multiple
possibilities and it takes up a lot of
time to try all of these so today what
i'm going to do is show you a tried and
tested method of setting up the
tensorflow environment and this will
help primarily those who are starting
with tensorflow so that they don't have
to waste so much time on setting up the
environment in experimenting with the
installation and setting up of the
environment now what we are going to do
is i will show you a method by which you
you know it is a tried and tested method
and of course tensorflow home page has a
install page and it shows you some ways
to install but again the challenge is
the same there are multiple versions
multiple methods shown there so it's
highly confusing for somebody who is new
as to decide which one which path to
take so in today's session what we are
going to do is we will set up tensorflow
on ubuntu and i'm going to show you in a
virtual box but then if you are using a
laptop with ubuntu installed you can
straight away use the same method
however we need to keep one thing in
mind that the various releases and
versions of ubuntu and
python and tensorflow not all of them
are compatible with each other so these
versions and releases need to be very
specific so i will tell you which is the
version and releases what combination is
best suited for you to get started and
later on of course you can then
experiment with other possibilities and
other releases and so on once you get
familiar with tensorflow to start with i
would also like to mention that it is a
good idea to install or start with
ubuntu environment or linux any other
linux also but here we will focus on
ubuntu rather than windows so for those
who are already let's say using a
windows system the question may arise
what do we do but there is a easy option
as you can see i'm actually using a
virtual box so you need to install
virtualbox let me just show you so this
is the virtual box oracle vm virtual box
and there are tons of videos on youtube
how to install a virtual box and how to
create ubuntu image i think we will not
spend time on that but if you're using
windows and my preference would be to
set up a virtual box and set up your
environment in ubuntu image so we will
start by assuming that you have an
ubuntu environment especially release
14.04 lts there are multiple ubuntu
versions and again we will not try to
get the latest and the greatest versions
or latest and greatest releases but the
focus here is to take the releases and
versions which are working and where you
will not waste time so the setup process
will be smooth if you stick to these
releases you can of course experiment
later on with other versions and try out
but here we will be working with ubuntu
1404 lts and we will use python 3.4 and
we will use tensorflow 1.5 this is a
tried and tested combination and i would
also recommend that you use the same if
you want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that
let me login to my
ubuntu system okay so we have the ubuntu
system running here now if you go to
tensorflow.org there is a page which
mentions how to install tensorflow and
as you can see there are multiple
possibilities you have ubuntu you have
windows and
mac os and so on and so forth and if you
go to ubuntu for example further you
will get
multiple options whether you want cpu or
gpu and
whether you want to do a pip install or
using a virtual native pip virtual env
anaconda and so on and so forth so all
these options are
very complicated or rather very
confusing i would say not complicated
depending on whether you're expert or of
course i am talking about beginners here
but if you click on some of these
options they may look very easy so for
example if you go back and
if you select for example native pip it
may appear like oh this is just you know
one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install it
you say three install tensorflow and
everything gets installed unfortunately
it doesn't work that way so it's not as
easy as so don't get kind of fooled by
the simplicity of the of the
documentation here again it's not their
fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what i am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course i
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as i said i will show you
the steps which are again sure shot to
work whereas
here again if you follow just this
document there will be some variations
which they have kind of not documented
so that's the reason i will show you the
steps separately all right so these are
the main four steps you need to download
and install anaconda and then create a
virtual environment with python and the
release as i mentioned is python 3.4 and
we will install tensorflow version 1.5
and then we will install and configure
jupiter which will be our development
environment all right so let's get
started this is our ubuntu and let's get
a terminal started here and
okay yes so
all right so we started the terminal and
then what we'll also do is we'll go to
the anaconda website because we need to
install anaconda we need to download and
install anaconda so for that you need to
go to the anaconda website so you can
just open a browser and
google and you will find anaconda
website
so this is the site anaconda
anaconda.org
click on this link and it will take you
to the anaconda website
you don't have to sign up or anything
like that just look for the download
anaconda
so just click on that it will take you
to the download pages and it
automatically recognizes that you are on
ubuntu so it will show you the links to
download all right so as you can see it
is
recognized that you are on a linux
operating system so
you can just click on this download and
it will start the download there are two
versions of course python with python
3.6 and 2.7 i recommend you start with
python 3.6 now just want to clarify that
we will be actually using python 3.4
this is just for
the
initial installation but subsequently
when we set up the virtual environment
you will see there is one more step
where we set up the virtual environment
there we will actually be using python
3.4 so just that you are not confused
all right so
it has started the download we just say
no thanks for this and it is downloading
while it is downloading you can
click on this
link saying how to install anaconda so
there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's taking time all right so
once the download is done we will be
using the options that are mentioned
here now the first step of course is we
we are already doing the first step
which is downloading the installer for
linux the second step is not mandatory
so it's an optional step most often you
can actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and since we are
using at this point we are using python
3.6 we should use this command so
basically the terminal we have opened
here is is to use or to run this command
that's the reason i opened this terminal
however make sure that the download is
complete before you run this command so
we'll just wait for a couple of minutes
and we'll come back once the download is
done all right so as you can see the
download is done this is a fairly large
file so if you are on a slow internet or
low internet bandwidth then it might
take quite a while it's about uh
578 mb and so this is the file now what
you need to do is
you need to go back to this installation
steps and let me minimize this and
yeah so
this is the command that you need to run
so you can just directly copy and paste
this command from here
okay so i do copy right mouse click
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so
most of them you need to just say enter
or yes and that's about it except for
the last step i will just show you what
i mean and here you need to do press
enter multiple times just to make sure
you agree to all these
agreement
the license agreement and so on and so
forth so once you do
multiple
enters it will
bring you to the next step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press enter and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press enter to confirm you just
say press enter and
this is primarily when it will
pretty much start the installation
process of anaconda this might take a
little while depending again on your
internet speed so you need to have some
patience we will also probably come back
once this installation is done or if it
asks for any further questions
all right so here you'll get again one
more question do you used to
wish the installer to prepend so you
just say yes for this question and
keep going now the last question
i think we are pretty much at the end
and that is about microsoft
vss i guess yeah vs code so for this you
can just say no because we will not be
using this
and
that's it you're done so this is a
completion of installation of anaconda
so it's always a good idea to exit and
start a fresh terminal
okay so
let's start again terminal
so we are done with the
installation of anaconda the next step
is to create a virtual environment with
python 3.4 so for that this is the
command conda create dash n and this is
the name of your virtual environment you
can give any name but for easy reference
i have given us tensorflow and we have
to specify the python version as i
mentioned earlier we will be using the
combination of python 3.4
and
tensorflow 1.5 now this is not the
latest version python has probably 3.6
at this point at the time of creation of
this video and even tensorflow probably
has the latest version as 1.7 but then
these combinations sometimes may not
work and i found that after several
trials and errors 3.4 with 1.5 seems to
be most reliable and that's the reason i
have chosen this i would recommend you
to try with this first if you are a
beginner and later on maybe you can try
out the other permutations and
combinations all right one step i just
wanted to show you is before we do the
installation or creation of the virtual
environment
if you want to just clarify or confirm
whether anaconda has been installed or
not you can run what is known as
anaconda navigator so just say anaconda
[Music]
navigator okay we need to edit this part
hold on one second i guess it is
all right so you see here when you start
anaconda navigator
this
anaconda navigator will open up that is
the indication that anaconda has been
installed
properly so that's just a quick check
and you don't have to do anything just
you can go back and close it
once this comes up and
then in the meanwhile let me just open
one more terminal
for the creation of the
virtual environment and
yeah so this is your anaconda navigator
and you can just say okay don't show me
just say okay
and
then you can close this
you can say file you can do a file exit
or you can click on close button
whichever
all right so we will exit from here
we have a
terminal open here we will use this for
our next steps all right so what we have
to do now is type in
this
piece of
code or this command
for some reason copy paste is not
working so
it's a small command so it shouldn't be
that big of an issue so we say conda
[Music]
and we say
create
so this is the command for creating a
new environment slash dash n
and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for uh
convenience i'm just calling it
tensorflow
but you can actually name it anything
and then we need to specify with the
which version of python so we say pip
[Music]
python and then that is equal
3.4 okay so it will create an
environment this will take a little
while it will ask you a question just
say yes and then it will be done
so this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that
and
for the question that it asks you just
say yes and i think you should be good
all right so it says do you want to
proceed you say yes then enter
this will again take a little little
time so we will probably move forward
and then come back once this is done
all right so
the environment has been created now
it's always a good idea to whenever some
of these steps get over or each step
gets over you just exit the terminal and
start afresh with the new terminal for
some reason sometimes it causes problem
if you continue so i found that it is
a safe practice to each time exit the
terminal and start afresh now that we
have an environment created
we can by the name tensorflow
you can
enter that environment by calling the
command source
activate
tensorflow to name whatever name you
have given so you'll see here once you
do that you will get this the name of
the environment will be shown here so it
is like your own again a special
environment within within the system and
uh from here onwards you can do other
stuff like actually installing
tensorflow and so on and you will see
that it has installed python 3 here so
3.4 right so it is installed that's what
we during creation of this environment
we wanted python 3.4 so that is what it
is showing but we are not yet done so we
need to still install tensorflow so in
this environment you need to
run a command which will actually
install the correct combination of
tensorflow now this is as you can see
it's a slightly complicated command with
install
dash dash ignore install so
what we can do is uh from within here we
can go and
go to tensorflow install page and there
is a sample code there you can pick up
from there so that you don't have to
type in
so much
so we say
tensorflow tensor
flow
dark and i'll also open up probably a
notepad here so that we can construct
that command and go here
you say
ubuntu
if you come further down there will be
by the way we are doing cpu installation
i think
that is clear we are not there is a
possibility to do gpu as well we will
probably create a separate video for
that and
if we go here
yeah so
again you probably if you follow the
entire document out here it may still
not work so i do not recommend that for
now at least for beginners but just to
copy this command because this is a
fairly complicated command so this is
much easier to copy it from here that's
the reason i'm
on this page
and we will
then modify it according to yes okay
let's say
copy
and don't do it directly here because
that is probably not yet the right
command let us go and create a notepad
page
empty document
i'll just say
tf.txt
okay this is just a temporary file what
we need to do here is we need to adjust
this command to suit the
versions that we are installing here so
let me just explain what it is what you
need to do
so
first thing you can get rid of
this one
yes okay now here these parts you can
simply ignore
here you need to go and change it to
version
1.5
and i think we are good with that okay
so
the cp34 indicates your python 3.4
so later on when you're trying to
experiment and if you want to
do other combinations of tensorflow and
python version then you can change this
for example you can change this to 3 6
both these places you need to change
this to 3 6 if you are using with python
3.6 and similarly if you want the latest
version which is of tensorflow which is
1.7 you need to change this to 1.7 and
so on but at this point to start with if
you're a beginner i would recommend that
you stick to this tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4 this is tried and tested and
it works okay just a word of caution
that just by changing these versions
the whole thing
will not work there may be other places
where you may have to some of the steps
may change
so just a word of caution that just by
changing this if you want to try out
with a different version some of the
steps may also change so don't think
that just by changing this just one
particular command you will be
fine okay so
that's been my experience so to start
with i would recommend use this
particular combination all right so it
looks good
uh tensorflow 1.5 and
let me
just reconfirm with my notes and i think
it looks good so this is install ignore
1.5 cp34 cp34
and so on okay
okay so let's hit enter
so it started the process again this
might take a little while so we will
pause the recalling and then get back
when the installation is done okay so
looks like this installation is done
and as always let us
exit and then come back now
you are currently in the environment
virtual environment um and it's a good
practice before you exit out of the
terminal to come out doctor out of the
virtual environment so just like you did
source activate you need to do source
deactivate
and
the name tensor
flow okay you will come back to the
original command prompt and then from
here you can
do an exit now we need to validate
whether the tensorflow installation has
gone through properly or not so
the way to validate is to
first start python and then import
tensorflow library see if it imports
without error so that's the best way to
validate so we'll open a terminal
and whenever you want to get into the
environment this is how you have to do
come to environment and then say source
and obviously you can also use existing
so source activate
tensorflow okay
so we do this and you need to run python
from here remember you should say
python3 because you have installed
python 3.4 now here when you say import
tensorflow
as tf
when you get back a prompt like this
without any errors that means tensorflow
installation has been successful if
tensorflow was not installed properly
you will get an error saying tensorflow
is not available or module doesn't exist
or something like that so tensorflow
installation is done but now we will go
through the process of installing
jupyter notebook so that you can do your
development so let me just exit
and in order to install your jupiter
notebook which is your which is going to
be your development environment we will
first
install ipython using conda so conda
install ipython and then pip install
jupiter so let's first do the
ipython conda
install
hide python
again it will ask you a question saying
these are the components do you want to
install you just say yes
all right you say yes
[Music]
once again it will take a little while
so we might pause the recording and come
back once it is done
great so that did not take much
time anyways so we will
as usual we will
exit which is
source deactivate
tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal
in order to install
jupiter
now in some places uh they may say
install jupiter using pip3 but in my
experience it did not work with p3 and
that's the reason we will use pip
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so
source activate
tensorflow
and you need to use this command which
is pip install jupiter usually when
you're on python 3 you use pip3 but as i
said it did not work so
in my experience it works with pip
install and not pick 3 so pip install
[Music]
i hope you already noticed that it is
jupy per
and not jpi
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done
okay so jupiter installation is also
done
once again
you need to it's a good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to
come out of this terminal session and
then start afresh
so we exit and we have a fresh terminal
already available here
and
we will once again
go to tensorflow
and we say
jupiter
notebook
that's how you start your jupyter
notebook
so this looks good now only thing is
since we are running uh for the first
time what you need to do is if you come
back to your command prompt
it will show you that if you are running
it for the first time it will say that
you need to copy paste this link so
you you can just for the first time only
once you need to do this copy this
and
paste it in your
browser
and remember this is only the first time
when you're running jupiter you need to
do this
subsequently you don't have to it will
automatically
open up all right so now that we have
jupiter installed and
it starts up we need to test whether
tensorflow
is working fine or not and in order to
do that
you can create a new
notebook
and you say
import
tensorflow
as tf and shift enter if everything is
fine tensorflow is installed properly
you don't get any errors and then it
works fine this is
an indication that tensorflow got
installed successfully and that's about
it so
that's all about installing tensorflow
with python 3.4 so remember this is
installation of tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4
on ubuntu and uh once again in case you
have a windows system in fact i have
also done it on a windows system you can
use virtual blocks to create a virtual
environment ubuntu environment and then
follow these steps and there are tons of
videos to create virtual box and that's
the reason
we have not included those steps in this
and if there are any comments there are
better ways to do this please mention it
in the comment section below or if you
need any further help just mention it
and with your email we will respond to
you now what are the various elements of
a tensorflow program as i mentioned
tensorflow program is slightly different
from regular programming that we do so
even if you're familiar with python this
may still be new for you the way you
write a tensorflow program is different
from the regular python programming that
you would have done or even machine
learning program you would have written
some machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but in tensorflow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are there is a lot of
difference between these types and we
will see how they vary and how they are
used and so on so constants are like
variables which cannot be changed so for
example if you define a constant like
this this is how you define a constant
by the way the simplest format is like
this like for example b is equal to
tf.constant and then you give a value
here a slightly more advanced version is
you also specify the type so you say
tf.constant 2.0 tf load 32. so the type
is of type float now in case of
constants you cannot during the
computation you cannot really change
these values so for example if you want
to change the value of b from 3 to 5 or
any other number it is not possible so
that is the meaning of constant all
right so then we have variables so
variables we are all familiar with what
are variables whenever we use
programming we use variables so this is
pretty much the same this is the way you
define variables df dot variable now one
thing you need to note is this is the
only type in which we have v capital
okay constant has c the small c and
placeholder as small p but variable as
capital v and tf.variable and then you
give the a value and then you can
specify what is the type and then you
can use the variable change the variable
at any point in time with a different
value and so on you can update the
variable and so on so we will see all of
this in the code i will illustrate how a
variable is defined and how it can be
changed whereas the constant cannot be
changed and so on and so forth and then
we have placeholders placeholders
are really a special type and this may
be something completely new for many of
us who have been doing programming but
in tensorflow this is a completely new
concept so this is very important to
understand this placeholders are like
variables but only thing is that they
are used for feeding the data from
outside so typically when you are
performing some computations you need to
load data from a file or from an image
file or from a csv file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle memory and so
on so i think that was the reason they
came up with this mechanism where you
can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this feed dig feed
underscore dick and this is a parameter
name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you
handle data within the tensorflow
program and then you create a graph and
once you create a graph then you have
what is known as a session and then you
create a session object and you create a
session and then you run a particular
computation or a node or an operation
and so typically what you need to do is
every variable or a computation that you
perform is like an operation or a node
within a graph so initially the graph
will be what is known as the default
graph the moment you create a tensorflow
object or tf this tf here you see this
is the tensorflow object and again in
the code when we go into the code it
will become much easier to understand so
when you create a tensorflow object
there is like a default graph which
doesn't have any operations no nodes or
anything like that so it's like a clean
slate the moment you assign variables or
constants or placeholders each of them
is in tensorflow terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you are just creating a
constant or a variable but and this c is
equal to a into b would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation here
you're actually performing an operation
but in tensorflow terms each of these
everything is an operation so if you're
creating a constant that is an operation
another constant or variable that's an
operation so you can actually run each
of these and they are also known as
referred to as nodes and when you are in
your session you will actually run each
of these you can potentially run each of
these nodes okay so a typical example
would look like this so you have two
constants created a is equal to
tf.constant its value is 5 b is equal to
this and then you say c is equal to a
into b and then you create a session now
remember all this you are just creating
a graph at this point no execution has
happened all right so only at this point
once you create a session and then you
say session or says dot run c is when
actually this whole thing will get
executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing programs
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward and when we look in the
jupyter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the
lab and take a look at the various
examples that are there and starting
from the very basic one how you create
variables and so these are some of the
slides that are showing so this is about
how to create variables how to create
constants and the variables or constants
can also be strings so this is like our
first hello world program and we will
talk about placeholders how to define a
placeholder and how to execute and
populate the placeholder values into
placeholder we will see these examples
in the lab actually i will run the code
and
we will also perform a small computation
of adding and multiplying these
variables and
we will in the end we will take up a use
case implementation using tensorflow so
let's first go and see those examples
and then come back and i'll explain this
use case and then we will execute the
use case in the lab so let's go and
check our lab okay so i'm in the jupiter
notebook environment and this is one of
the development environments we can use
this is regular python
anytime you do python programming we use
jupiter notebook or there are rather of
course there are other ways of using
other tools like pycharm and so on but
for this particular tutorial i'm
comfortable using jupyter notebook so i
will show you in jupyter notebook so
this is the very basic example to
demonstrate how to create variables and
constants and placeholders and what is
the difference between them how they
behave and so on and as i mentioned the
assumption here is that you know at
least some basic python programming or
some programming language so at least
you understand the code here and first
two pieces of code you will not need
machine learning background but when we
do the use case of the case study there
it is expected that you know at least
some basic machine learning concepts so
in case you need to brush up the machine
learning part you may have to do that
before you go to the third one but here
just at least some idea of programming
will be sufficient so what are we doing
here in this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is uh as i mentioned it is
a library so we are importing tensorflow
and we are calling it tf so this is this
just a name you can give it any name but
it is very common and everywhere
wherever tensorflow programming is done
it is always named as tf but you can
name anything actually okay so this will
import the tensorflow into my session
now this is the way to create a variable
so let's start by creating a variable
and this is the name of my variable i am
starting by giving a name called zero
and i say zero is equal to tf dot
variable and then i'm giving the value
of the variable here so this is the very
basic way and the simplest way to create
a variable we will see a little later
there are other formats as well but the
bare minimum way of creating a variable
is this so i'm creating a variable by
the name zero and as i mentioned you
need to pay attention to the capital v
here in case of variable it is a capital
v uppercase constant and placeholders
are
lowercase now i'm creating a constant
then the constant i'm naming it as one
and the way to create a constant is tf
dot constant and then you give the
value of the constant so the value of
the variable here is 0 and the value of
constant here is 1. and again constant
you can also have additional parameters
like a name and so on probably you must
have seen in other tutorials or in other
places where the code is written but the
basic format construct to create a
constant is this this is sufficient to
create a constant so i created one
variable and one constant now what else
can we do again here there is no real
execution happening we are just building
a graph we have not yet executed any
tensorflow code we are building a graph
and i will show you how the graph looks
as well first let us understand the
constants and variables and so on and
then i will show you how the graph is
generated and so on so what i want to do
here is i want to add
0 and 1 and put it into a new variable
called new value so what i do here
tensorflow offers these methods like add
assign multiply or
you have matrix multiplication matmul
and so on right so i will use one of
those methods which is tf.add and then
pass these two as parameters so we can
add a variable and a constant there are
no restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if i
do this it will be okay i did not
execute this code so it is giving an
error now we are good okay so what it
has done is new value will be equal to
tf dot add 0 1 so then we have one
variable and one constant now let's say
i want to change the value of the
variable because that is possible right
so we want to change the value of the
variable to something some new value so
we have in this case new value has one
because we added a zero and a one so new
value has one now i want to assign this
to this originally what we called as
zero so i will call that as update is
equal to tf dot assign so assign is
basically changing the value so that's
what we are going to do here now it has
not complained we'll just say fine right
there are no issues now let us try this
something similar
with this 1 as well so 0 is a variable
so we were able to change the value and
we will in a little while we will see
what exactly those values are but before
doing that now let's say i will
uncomment this part and i want to do
something similar for my constant right
1 is a constant now i want to let's say
change the value of the constant and
make that also something different okay
so if i execute this piece of code it
will give an error now again the error
message may not be very intuitive this
doesn't say that you cannot do this for
a constant it will just say tensor
object has no attribute assign now that
sometimes may be confusing especially
when you're starting but the meaning
here is that one is a constant and
you're trying to modify the constant so
it will not allow that's the reason it
is complaining so let's put that back in
the comment and
okay so that is done so only variables
you can modify now what you have to do
let's skip this piece of code i'll come
back to this in a bit
but let's say we start by creating you
remember i told you we need to create a
session so the way to create a session
there are a couple of ways of creating a
session but this is for beginners this
is the easiest way all you need to do is
assign a variable called says or you can
give any name and that is equal to tf
dot session that is the session method
here and you create a session object by
the name says now what i'll do is i'll
skip this as well i there is a purpose
behind that now let's go ahead and run
this piece of particular operation
remember i mentioned that everything you
need to run so as of now the code has
not really got executed tensorflow code
has not got executed you only created
the graph so only when you
run through the session is when that
actually the program gets executed so
when you do this now you see observe
that it is giving an error okay the
reason behind that is remember we skip
these two lines of code for variables
okay this and then this now this is
something very very important to observe
if you have variables in your code what
i mean by that is let's say you are not
using variables but you have only
constants and placeholders then this
will not complain and you will not get
this error but in our case we also have
variables so whenever you have variables
in that case you need to do an
initialization and this is just a
standard code there is nothing that we
need to add or modify or anything like
that this is a standard piece of code
you create this name of course can be
anything you can give us any name but
this global variables initializer is
what you need to call tf.global
variables initializer this will kind of
initialize all the variables that you
may be using and then again remember
this doesn't execute anything right so
all you're doing here is you're creating
an operation but in order to run that
operation you need to also run this
known as
run init underscore op so this operation
you need to run after creating the
session all right so we executed this
now let us execute this and now when i
run this piece of code it will run
successfully okay i hope you observed
that so it is whenever you use variables
these two lines of code one is the
operation you need to create an
operation for saying global variables
initializer and then you need to run
before running anything else you need to
do a session.run this operation okay
again only if you're using
variables of course you invariably in
all your programs you will use variables
you cannot just write a program with
constants and placeholders so you can
pretty much assume that this has to be
there in pretty much all the programs
now again why
this has not been taken care of in the
library that's a different question but
you need to keep in mind and always
remember if you don't do this for
whatever reason if you're forgotten you
will get an error and the error won't be
intuitive so you need to remember this
that this could be because of the
variables okay good so we have seen how
to create a constant and we have seen
how to create a variable and we have
seen that you cannot modify or update a
constant and we have also seen if you
have variables that you need to execute
or have these two lines of code to
initialize the variables and then we
have seen that after creating a graph
how to run the graph in a session and i
will show you a little bit more in
detail how exactly the graph gets
created and how it gets executed but
this was the first very quick code on
creating variables and constants now we
will keep going and
we will also show you or i will show you
the placeholders but before that one
more small piece of code so this is how
you write a for loop okay so we are
saying five times you run this piece of
code now like any python program this is
nothing different so you have a for loop
and this is indented that's the reason
and therefore you say session.run update
so this will run five times and it will
get printed that's all so update will
run for five times each time it will
come and do this particular operation
that's all we are we are asking the
system to do so let me just run that and
show you let me yeah so it will okay so
it has done five times
one that's for it is basically adding if
you recall it starts from 0 it adds 1 to
0 then 1 to 1 1 to 2 and so on so it's
nothing but it is generating five
numbers one two three four five that's
it okay so then
you can also have your constants as
strings for example so you can also work
in a similar way you can work with
string so most of the computation
happens
mainly on numerical values so we
normally hand handle numbers but
there will be situations where you may
have to handle strings as well or text
as well so this is an example of text
operation so you can similar to numbers
you just create strings or store
in constants instead of a number you say
hello is equal to tf.constant and then
you assign the string that you want it
to be assigned and then the next one is
one more string which is for world and
then you say add these two so it is
nothing but concatenation of these two
words hello and
world
so we will do that and remember this is
only creation of the graph right so in
order to actually execute this graph you
need to run the session now you need to
keep in mind we don't have to create the
session once again because once you
create a session till you close the
session it remains valid okay so we have
created this session here now till you
say says dot close it will remain for
you so that's why we did not create one
more so we are just reusing that session
says dot run hello world so in this
hello world what is the operation that
we are doing here the operation is add
these two concatenate these two so if i
run this it will print hello world okay
now that's string operation now we will
take a look at placeholders so this is
slightly more complicated and something
new even for people who have been
writing programs so but i'll just
explain it with uh with a quick example
first of all how do you declare or
create a placeholder you just do
tf.placeholder and the p is lowercase
only in case of variables the v is
uppercase but otherwise constant and
placeholders it is lowercase and you
just say because as i mentioned this is
a placeholder it doesn't have any value
so you unlike a constant or your
variable you can't usually you will not
specify any value you just say what type
of placeholder you want and very often
most of the cases it is a floating point
so we just say placeholder of type
float32 so this tf.float32
tells the system that it is a floating
point okay and then so let me just run
this and then you can do some or define
some computation like for example b is
equal to a into 2. now remember here
right now a has no value but what we are
saying here is at any point later on
when a gets some value then b should be
equal to twice the value of a that's all
we are saying here okay and also as i
mentioned earlier we are not yet
executing anything we are just creating
the graph here okay so now you have that
now how do you feed the value or
populate the placeholder there is a
certain syntax in which you can populate
the placeholder and you do that using
what is known as a dictionary you're all
probably familiar those with python
especially must be familiar with the
dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that
in order to feed the placeholder so in
this particular example if i want to run
something if i want to calculate or
compute b obviously i need to feed the
value of a so the value of a i'm feeding
using this dictionary and i'm saying
that a is equal to 3. now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single a scalar value like in
this case right remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or or a tensor very
often it is a tensor so we will see step
by step so we can start with the very
basic example where a can be a scalar so
in this case a is equal to 3 that's what
we are saying feed underscore dict in
this case feed underscore dict is the
name of a variable by the way so you
can't give anything else here so if you
just say feed is equal to this it will
give you an error all right so keep that
in mind either you specify feed
underscore dick is equal to and give the
dictionary pass the dictionary or you
straight away like in this case this is
another format so let's see first let me
execute this it has given 6 okay i think
let me see if i can clear out this
particular cell so it becomes easier to
understand okay so it is giving you 6.
let me do that once again clear out this
and then okay and let me change the
format so this is one way of doing it
another way is you don't even have to
specify the name of this parameter feed
underscore dict you just pass the
dictionary and it will
execute okay but typically this makes
the code readable so that's the reason
most of the places whenever you find
tensorflow code you will see that they
explicitly mention feed underscore date
so that the code is readable otherwise
it can get confusing so i will also
comment this and retain the other format
okay so i hope it's clear so what we are
doing here we are running the operation
b and what exactly is bb is twice a a
into two so therefore what we are doing
and a therefore b gets a value of 6 and
that's what is being fed into result and
that's what is getting printed here okay
now as i mentioned a need not be just a
scalar value it can be a vector with a
multi-dimension
array and so on and so forth so let's
start showing you examples of that again
let me just clear out the outputs let me
clear this and let me also clear this
for now okay you can also do before
running up this you could we could also
do clear all output all output clear it
will clear everything but that will
we'll have to start all over again so
i'm just doing individually all right so
in this example we are taking a one
dimension array where rank is equal to 1
and i am feeding 3 4 5. now let us see
what happens if i run this right as you
can imagine it gets multiplied each
number gets multiplied so the result is
6 8 10 okay now as i said it can get
more complicated now let's say this is a
multi-dimensional vector so if you what
happens if you feed this okay so as you
can see this is pretty complicated now
but if you feed this again all you're
doing is
there is okay there is a slight change
here again you can also
create your dictionary outside and feed
that here you don't have to directly do
it here like in this case you see there
are variations of the exact syntax in
the way you write it right so there is a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straight away
here kind of inline but here you created
the dictionary separately because it is
more complicated and then you you're
passing that dictionary here so i said
dictionary is equal to a and then i'm
saying this is what should be the value
of a
this is and i'm feeding that and then
i'm using directly that dictionary here
okay so this is equivalent to putting
this code here right so if we execute
this what happens same so you get
because a was a let's say this is a
3 by
4 by 2 right so that is one yeah 3 by
four by two right so you see here this
is a multi-dimensional array so you feed
that and the values you see here there's
one two three it became two four six
four five six became eight ten twelve
seven eight nine became 14 16 18 and so
on and so forth okay i hope now you got
an idea about placeholders and in real
life what happens is you typically won't
create these dictionaries manually and
since this is a quick demo we did this
you will actually read the data into
this dictionary and then you feed that
when you're doing the computation okay
so it could be a csv file or it could be
a image file so the input is basically
read and fed in
usually it is also done in patches so
you don't read the entire thing because
they can be large amount of data so that
is the idea behind having these
placeholders and the way we feed these
placeholders there is a provision
there's a deliberately that has been
made a provision for
this kind of getting data into the
program in chunks okay now in this
particular example we will close the
session here and then i will show you
what is the other way of creating a
session right so now if i close the
session here now if i try to do anything
with the session it will give us an
error so i will probably not do that
right now now there is another way or
another format and this is a very common
way of using the session but i didn't
want to start off with this because this
could get a little confusing the a
simpler way was to create session saying
s is equal to tf.session but typically
you will do it in what is known as a
width block this is a very common way of
creating session so once you have the
graph you would execute the graph in a
session using a width block and this is
the syntax so you say with df dot
session as says all right and then you
put all your code here so what will
happen is you don't have to explicitly
close the session the moment this width
block gets
completed the session gets closed okay
so let's just take a quick look at this
example now if i uh let me clear this
current output be clear okay so this is
the hello world example a little bit
earlier we did that so i'm doing
with tf.session assessment result is
equal to says dot run hello plus world
and then i say print result okay so
within this with block i'm doing all my
computation and this gets executed now
let's say i try to run remember i
created a session here now if i want to
let's say do something like run sesh dot
run a it is giving an error because the
session is no longer valid
right so you cannot either you have to
run this if you want to run this you
have to run this in this with block
or you shouldn't have closed the session
here right you remember this we said
session dot close so since we have
closed the session there is no active
session therefore it is giving an error
okay now there is a third way
of creating a session but for now i will
skip it because that is very very
specific to the notebooks and and so on
so we will just avoid it you start with
for beginners i think the best way is to
start with creating a separate session
and then writing your code and then
closing your session now of course
remember if you don't do this part says
dot close it will not give any error or
anything like that only thing is that
it's a good practice and your resources
will get released otherwise
if you do multiple of these programs if
they are running then your resources
will get blocked that's the only thing
and to start with it is it is simpler to
do it this way so initially when you're
doing you start with this but as you
move forward as you become familiar with
tensorflow programming i would recommend
all of you to get into this model most
of the programming tensorflow
programming is done like this with df
dot session as ss okay all right so that
was one book or one page of a code that
we have done explaining about variables
constants and placeholders now let me
explain how the graph works so in this
example we are going to see how the
graph is created how the graph gets
executed and so on okay now that we got
a understanding of constants and
variables and placeholders okay so we
will start as usual by importing our
library and as i said whenever you
create a tf or tensorflow object there
will be what is known as a default graph
and you can get a handle of that by
saying get default graph so let's do
that and you can display the operations
remember every node in the graph is
considered as an operation right so as
of now as you can see
we have not done anything we have not
created a constant or variable or
nothing right so there was there is no
operation so by the way let's do one
thing let's start with the
all output clear so that
i don't have to again do individually so
we i'll just run these two lines of code
okay now so yeah so we have the default
graph and as of now there are no
operations so there is a method called
get underscore operations which will
kind of display
or show what are the various operations
that have been performed on the graph so
as i said to start with they have no
operations being performed so when i try
to display it's empty there are no
nothing is there no operations okay now
let's see what happens when we slowly
step by step start writing or building
the graph so my first step may be to
create a constant okay remember in the
previous example i have shown you how to
create a constant in the most simple or
the simplest way which is like constant
and then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same i can say a is
equal to name and xyz i can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for simplicity
because there is a purpose why i am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensorboard otherwise it doesn't have
much value this additional name doesn't
have much value in this our case also we
will be seeing the graph and that's why
i'm using this but otherwise this having
additionally a name usually doesn't add
much value all right so let's create a
constant i created a constant now let us
see what's going on in the graph so i
will just say operations is equal to get
operations and if you see here now
you remember here it was blank now you
see the first operation is showing up
and this a that's the reason i put here
so it is showing as a and it says that
okay you have performed an operation
and there is a constant you have created
a constant okay all right so let's move
on let's say we want to create a second
constant and this is b so if i see what
does what are the operations list of
operations that have been performed you
see here there are two of them so you
have operation a which is a constant
then you have an operation b another
constant you recall we in the term
operation here is not very intuitive
right so we are just creating constants
or numbers or variables and it is saying
it's an operation but that's that's a
terminology in tensorflow everything is
an operation here okay all right so then
what else let's say i want to create a
third operation
and that is basically adding which is
this is a real operation in normal sense
as well so let's say i'm creating c
which is um adding a and b and the c
value obviously will be a plus b
okay now if we want to see what is in c
and we say c you see here it is not
showing
30 it just says it is a tensor
and it is of type in 32 right because
we have not executed the graph we are
still only building the graph i hope
this makes it easy to understand okay so
we are just building the graph we have
till we do remember till we do a session
and run a particular operation you're
not actually executing anything okay
you're just building the graph all right
so now let us see what are the
operations we have done a b and now c so
you will see there are three of them a b
and c okay now let's do one more
operation which is d
and here i am doing multiplication
remember we did a tf dot add now i will
do tf.multiply and i'm multiplying a and
b and i'm calling this operation as d so
a has
i think
10 and b has 20 so
d will be actually 200 when we execute
it right now it is just a tensor and it
is of shaping 32 okay and once again we
can see what are the operations abcd and
let's do one last operation here which
is e which is once again multiplication
of c and d now that c has 30 which is a
plus b and d has 200 which is a into b
so now c into d will be 30 into 200
which is which is equal to 6 000 but as
we have seen earlier that multiplication
will not happen right now so now you
have built a
fairly simple but operation graph which
consists of
a b c d e 1 2 3 for five operations okay
so you built a small it's not a very
complicated one but a simple graph now
you need to execute these operations so
what you need to do you need to create a
session okay so says dot tf is equal to
session and then you can run these
session
print says dot run e now am i missing
something do i have to initialize the
variables that's a question for you
thing can tell me do i have to
initialize the variables that remember i
ran one piece of code i think you must
have got the answer i don't have to
because i am just using all constants
here i have not used any variable here
right so i don't have to write execute
that piece of code to initialize the
variables so i can just create a session
and run any of the operations that i
want to run so in this case i am running
session e operation e right this
operation e now i can actually run
individually instead of doing directly e
i could have run only a or i could have
run b and so on and so forth but in this
case i have run e which in turn will do
all the required computations which is
for example assigning the value to a and
b and c doing the multiplication and so
on all those operations will be
performed which are required to do the
computation of e okay now there is a
small piece of code that you can use to
find out what are the various operations
that are there in this particular graph
in this case of course it was very easy
very straightforward i have created
abcde but in normal programming in real
life this can sometimes help to see
how
what is there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so i finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because i did not use
the width block so i need to close the
session as a good practice so i close
the session good so that's how the graph
works
i hope it was helpful in understanding
how variables and constants and
placeholders are created in the previous
example we saw and how exactly you
create a graph and then you actually
execute that graph that's the way
tensorflow program works that's the
structure of tensorflow program okay so
now that we understood the structure of
tensorflow programming let's take an
example and a classification example and
take some real
data from from outside external data csv
file and
try to solve a classification problem
for that let's first go back to the
slides and understand what is the
problem statement and then we will come
back okay so what is the case here we
have some census data and which has all
these features or variables like um the
age of a person
what class work class what is his
education what is his marital status
gender and so on and so forth so there
are a bunch of a bunch of features that
are available and
we have to basically classify or not
classify we have to build a model for
classifying whether the income of this
person is above 50k or below 50k okay so
there is actually a label data available
we will then try to build a model and
then see what is the accuracy so that
this is a typical machine learning
problem actually but as i said
tensorflow can be used for doing machine
learning as well so we will as a simple
example we will take machine learning so
this is how the high level the code
looks and in tensorflow programming we
also take a help of regular python
libraries like for example
it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you're doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data sets so all
that can be done using the regular
non-tensorflow libraries right so these
are like regular python libraries and
scikit-learn and so on so we use that
and then prepare the data and then use
tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tensorflow the main advantage is
that tensorflow offers high level apis
right we talked about that so in this
case we will be using i'll explain what
is in the slide but before that i wanted
to just show you what is the api that we
will be using so we will be using the
estimator api we will be using the
estimator api to create a classifier
what is known as a linear classifier now
in order to do that you need to prepare
the data and you need to prepare the
data into a certain structure or format
and the api itself needs to be fed in a
certain way so that is exactly what we
are doing before we get into the regular
tensorflow code okay so these slides
will quickly show you what exactly is
happening but i will take you into
jupiter notebook and run that code and
show you so here we are importing the
data the data is the name of the file is
census underscore data.csv it's a csv
file and then there is uh
income bracket is one of the columns
which basically is our target that is
what is used that is the label rather
but this doesn't have numeric values so
it has the income so
we need to convert that into binary
values either 0 or 1. so that's what we
are doing here and then we are splitting
using scikit learn we are doing
splitting of the data into test and
training right so this is a standard
scikit-learn people some of you who are
familiar with machine traditional
machine learning and you have done
machine learning in python using
scikit-learn will immediately recognize
this this is a sk learner's psychic
learn and there is a readily available
method to split the data into training
and test that's what we are doing here
and then you need to create what is
known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the api estimator
api that's what we are doing here and
data and also there is there are
different ways of creating the feature
columns for
numeric values and for categorical
values or rather for continuous values
and categorical values okay so that's
what has been
two types we are doing here
we will see again in the code as well
and
then you create your model so this is
basically model is equal to df.estimator
linear classifier and then you're
feeding the feature columns and also
subsequently you will call the training
by passing the input function and you
specify how many iterations to be done
for the training process and again this
is all typical machine learning process
so there is nothing specific for
tensorflow here and then you evaluate
your model because this is
classification model so you can again
take help of the scikit-learn to test
the accuracy and get the reports
evaluation perform the evaluation and
get the report like this one right so
this is the classification report and
you will see what is the prediction
recall f1 score and so on again this is
a standard machine learning process all
right so that's pretty much as far as
the code here is concerned once again
let me take you into our
lab and
we will get started with this particular
code now let me clear out the outputs so
that you can step by step you can see
the output so this is our data and
we will actually be this is just a
display here the code starts from here
so before when we start with our
tensorflow part of it as i mentioned we
now remember in the previous examples
the data was kind of cooked up
internally we created some data and we
were using it right the constants
variables and so on here is a real life
example so you are actually getting data
from outside so you know before we get
into tensorflow this is actually regular
python code so we are using pandas for
example to create our data frame so we
will import pandas and then we will
basically read our file into a pandas
data frame and this is how the data
looks right and if you do a head it will
give you about six
readings or observations five or six
observations and then you can take a
look at how your data is looking so for
example you have age work class
education and so on and so forth
and you see here this last column income
underscore bracket
it says whether the income is greater
than 50k or less than 50k so this cannot
be
understood or this cannot be fed into
our
model or
you know so that's the reason we need to
convert this this will not be understood
right so this needs to be converted
saying okay
maybe less than 50 k is 0 and greater
than 50 k is 1 so that conversion needs
to be done before we feed it into our
model so that's what we are going to do
as we move forward so this is the code
for doing that okay so we take this and
then we define a function
and then we run that function so now we
have wherever it is
less than 50k
it will have 0 and greater than 50k it
will have 1. so we have now updated the
data then the next part is to split our
data into training and test data set so
how are we going to do that we again
will take the standard python library
which is scikit-learn sk-learn library
and we use an existing
function there which is a train test
split and what we are doing here is
basically splitting the data into i'm
sorry i need to run this
and then this
okay sorry about that so
once i run this what is what are we
doing here again those are familiar with
scikit learn will immediately recognize
i am splitting this into test and train
i'm saying test size is 30 so 30 percent
of the data should go into test and
training should have 70 okay so that's
all we are doing 0.3 indicates 30
so you can again this can be individual
preferences some people do it like 50 50
some people 20 80 and in our case we are
doing
70 30. so training is 70 and test is 30.
okay all right so
we have so far we've been doing regular
non-tensorflow stuff so preparing the
data so that we can now use for
tensorflow and in tensorflow what we are
doing is we will be using the api called
estimator now estimator in order to call
estimator you need to prepare what is
known as feature columns so feature
columns have to be in a certain format
basically it is nothing but the columns
we have to put them in a certain format
and then when we are calling the the
training we need to pass what is known
as an input function again a certain way
in which you need to pass that function
so that is what we need to do before we
create the model and
run the model for training so the next
few lines will be doing that quick look
at before we even get in once again into
the tensorflow code so this is just
showing us what are the various columns
names of the columns of this data okay
so that is what is shown here and this
is more for when i was writing the code
i could copy paste from here that's the
reason i this line of code is there
instead of typing in these values okay
good so now is where
the actual tensorflow action starts so i
import tensorflow and now i will use
this feature column functionality to
create my feature columns
and there is a certain construct how you
create the feature columns again
probably the details of that is out of
scope here but just that you need to
know that we need to create feature
columns and the way you create feature
columns for continuous values and for
categorical values is slightly different
and that's the reason you have two
different blocks okay so for categorical
values you need to use what is known as
tf dot feature column dot categorical
column width vocabulary list and again
within this again there are two ways in
which you can create for categorical
values one is a vocabulary list where
you know
how many types are there so for example
gender column can have only male and
female so in such a case if there are
let's say a finite number of values for
a given column then you use a column
with vocabulary list okay so and then
you say what is the name of the column
and what are the possible values so in
this case male and female now there will
be situations where the the values that
this column can have
okay first of all it is a categorical
column that means it can have names or
some non-numerical values but the number
of values is probably unknown or
undefined so for example occupation now
occupation can have any value it can be
self-employed it can be a software
professional bank
a teacher doctor so so many
possibilities are there and we don't
know in the given data how many
occupations have been listed
right so that is where you use what is
known as categorical column with hash
bucket and you specify the hash bucket
size so what it what this says is there
can be a maximum of thousand such values
so typically if you give a safe number
safely large number so that you don't
run out of these number of occupations
so i think thousand is a safe number i
don't think there will be more than
thousand occupations in a given data so
that's the idea behind it but that's a
judgment call we need to take what
should be the size of this bucket size
right hash bucket size so these are two
different types for categorical values
for creating the feature column so we
will execute this for all the
categorical columns obviously you need
to know the type of the columns and that
is where if you see right at the
beginning this information was provided
what is the data type and you see here
the column name and what whether it is
continuous or categorical this
information is provided in the census
data wherever we pick this census data
from by the way this was picked from
online from a government website and we
stored locally so on that website it is
mentioned the details of this data were
mentioned and they have mentioned
whether each of these columns is
categorical or continuous so that
information we have to use and we have
to create feature columns using this
categorical method for the categorical
type of columns and then for numeric or
continuous values you just use
what is known as feature column dot
numeric column okay so these are all
continuous or numeric values like age
education number capital gain capital
loss hours per word these are all
numerical values or continuous values
right so you just say tf.feature
underscore column.numeric underscore
column and then give the name of the
column so once you do that i think i
have executed the previous one yeah this
one now so your feature columns are
ready and uh you need to basically
create a vector of all these columns and
we call that as feet underscore calls
which is which is like a short form for
feature columns now as you have seen
i've mentioned earlier also there are
two things that are needed one is the
feature columns and another is the input
function so feature columns to first
create the model and then to train the
model you need to create an input
function so now we have the feature
columns ready next is to create an input
function and there is a certain way in
which you need to
this construct is pretty much very
common construct so we will use that so
the input function takes these x and y
values for training and tests you
remember these are the x strain is the x
values of the training data set and
white rain is the labels of the training
data set so that's what we are using
here extreme y train and then we specify
what is the batch size batch size you
remember i mentioned this is what will
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process we don't
get the entire data in one shot we do it
in batches so what size you specify here
number of epochs in this case we just
say none but number of epochs is again
uh probably the definition is not
required here but at a very high level
how many times the entire data has to be
passed through the model right so if you
have thousand records and you pass all
the thousand records three times for
training purpose then you call that as
three epochs right so there is a
difference between the batch size and
epochs so when let's say we have
thousand records and you're saying batch
size is 100 that means there will be 10
batches right so if you take 10 batches
then that is one epoch gets completed
okay then you the training obviously
doesn't get completed in one round okay
so you need to pass this data again
maybe a second time or a third time till
you get the right accuracy that is known
as epochs okay again if you need more
details about this you may have to go
through the machine learning tutorial i
think it becomes much clearer okay so
you have your input function as well
let's execute that okay and now we are
ready to create the use the api right so
what will we do we will create the
linear classifier using
tf.estimator.linearclassifier
and this guy needs feature columns right
so that's why we created we did all that
so much of
manipulations to create this feature
columns so we have feature columns so we
pass that and we create our model there
may be a few warnings don't worry about
that so we will just ignore that and now
we use that model and we actually what
we did is we created an instance of the
model we have not really run anything we
just created a instance of the model now
we will create the node for training so
model.train and this needs the input
function remember we we created the
input function so we need to pass the
input function and then we say
the steps is now telling how many
iterations this training
has to be run so we are saying 5000 and
this may be it will probably take a
little long so we will okay but that's
fine i think we will leave it 5000.
sometimes if you have probably a less
powerful machine you can cut it down to
maybe thousand or something like that
but in this case i have a fairly
powerful system so i think it shouldn't
take much long let's uh go ahead and
give couple of minutes for it to get
over okay so let us go back yeah i think
this is done you see here the hourglass
has
disappeared that means this computation
is done yes okay this is done right
saving checkpoint for 5000 that means it
is done so training is done so now what
we have to do we need to do the
evaluation so
again this is a standard machine
learning method so
methodology rather so training has been
done with the training data set now you
need to evaluate using your test data
set so that's what we are doing here for
example you see here x underscore test
is your the test data set remember we
used scikit-learn to split the data into
training and test data set so x
underscore test and a quick question why
are we not using y underscore test here
like we did in case of uh training
obviously we are expecting the model to
predict the values y values right so
that's why we don't pass the y values
here all right so let's execute this for
doing the evaluation all right and then
we
put them in a proper format because the
output doesn't come out in a proper
format so we put it in a list format and
then we can just check yeah so this is
done and
we can check what is the first element
in this what is the probabilities and so
on so it's just
a quick way to see if the values are
there or not you can take any value here
right any element here all right now
that the testing is done what we need to
do again we will probably put them in
some kind of this is more of a
formatting thing we will just uh
run through quickly and then we will use
once again scikit-learn for finding out
the accuracy and so on because
scikit-learn offers what is known as a
classification report functionality so
we will use that and find out how well
our model has performed so you see here
again people with
machine learning background will be
immediately able to recognize this so it
gives us what is the precision what is
the recall
and f1 score
this is pretty much like you're getting
like almost 85 percent accuracy which is
pretty okay and
there are other ways to increase the
accuracy for example you can run the
training for more iterations that is one
way get more data and so on and so forth
or use
this is a linear classifier we could you
have used a non-linear classifier and so
on so again multiple ways of doing it to
increase the accuracy but the idea here
was to quickly show you a piece of
tensorflow code and that's what we have
done here we had the original tensorflow
release of 1.0 and then they came out
with the 2.0 version and the 2.0
addressed so many things out there that
the 1.0 really needed so we start
talking about tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit and you can see here where that
was all just compressed to make it run
easier you can just create a model and
do a fit on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager so if you
see the first part you're like what the
heck is all the session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross
on our list up there
and across is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.caras cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your layers
are going from one side to the other
so everything's going in a sequential
order
functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming in one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as a
more complicated tensor you have coming
in but all of it's very easy to do and
that's what 2.0 does a really good job
of and here we have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do these different layers and
values if you look at the scope and the
default name you start looking at all
the different code in there to create
the variable scope that's not even
necessary in tensorf 2.0 so you'd have
to do one before you do do what you see
the code in 2.0 in 2.0 you just create
your model it's a sequential model and
then you can add all your layers in you
don't have to pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph
in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow 1
0 the python functions were limited and
could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects so if
you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing
next let's go for hierarchy and
architecture and then we'll cover three
basic tools in tensorflow before we roll
up our sleeves and dive into the example
so let's just take a quick look at
tensorflow toolkits in their hierarchy
at the high level we have our object
oriented api so this is what you're
working with you have your tf cross you
have your estimators this sits on top of
your tf layers tf losses tf metrics so
you have your reusable libraries for
model building this is really where
tensorflow shines is between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction where you do
a linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like in the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of setup
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 percent
of your time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your premade estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on uh once you have all
that set up you have your distribution
strategy where are you going to run it
you're going to be running it on just
your regular cpu are you going to be
running it with the gpu added in
like i have a pretty high end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it or do you have a
specialized tpu setup in there that you
paid extra money for
it could be if you're
in later on when you're distributing the
package you might need to run this on
some really high processors because
you're processing at a server level for
uh let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a um to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff off your website or
maybe you're looking for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that now they have tensorflow lite so
you can actually run a tensorflow on an
android or an ios or raspberry pi a
little breakout board there in fact they
just came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's this little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that
um talking about an affordable way to
beta test a new product uh you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of end points and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at three specific pieces of
tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow in
tensorflow constants are created using
the function constant in other words
they're going to stay static the whole
time whatever you're working with the
syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals
tf.constant 5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value and then we
have our variables in tensorflow
variables in tensorflow are in memory
buffers that store tensors and so we can
declare a two by three tensor populated
by ones you could also do constants this
way by the way you can create a an array
of ones for your constants i'm not sure
why you'd do that but you know you might
need that for some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice 2x3
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that
and then you of course have sessions in
tensorflow a session in tensorflow is
used to run a computational graph to
evaluate the nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf.ad x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session you can do a session
run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects we're going to stick with
jupiter notebook
pycharm uh whatever it is you're gonna
use in here uh you have your spider and
your qt console for different
programming environments the thing to
note um it's kind of hard to see but i
have my main
pi 36
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3 6.
if you have python version 3 7 or 3 8
you're probably going to get some errors
in there
might be that they've already updated
and i don't know it now you have an
older version but you want to make sure
you're in python version 3 6 in your
environment and of course in anaconda i
can easily set that environment up make
sure you go ahead and
pip in your
tensorflow or if you're in anaconda you
can do a conda install tensorflow to
make sure it's in your package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just um
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with and we
can do that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf dot underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the we were going to dig a
little deeper into our constants and you
can do an array of constants and we'll
just create this nice array
a equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the array
right in there 4361.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where i can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you round you surround it in
print
and you can see it's a tf tensor it has
the shape the type and the and the array
on here it's a two by two array and just
like we can create a constant we can go
and create a variable and this is also
going to be a two by two array and if we
go ahead and print the v out we'll run
that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out v and b
i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens it only prints the last one
unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable so that's how it's
looking in the back end when you're
talking about the difference between a
variable and a constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
in variable we capitalize the v and with
the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple of things to note
in here
and just like any other array in math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a t f dot
concat
values and there's our a b axis on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out uh you'll see right here we end
up with a tensor so let's put it in as a
constant not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axes equals one this means
we're doing the columns um so if you had
a longer array like right now we have an
array that is like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two
axes
zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows if we
had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
um
so you know what i'm talking about is
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axis 1 you know zero one two that's
gonna be our columns uh and if you can
do columns then we also can do rows and
that is simply just changing the
concatenate uh we'll just grab this one
here and copy it we'll do the whole
thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and changes from axis one
to axis zero and if we run that
you'll see that now we concatenate by a
row as opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format i find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than
understanding
what's going on because conceptually
your mind just just too many dimensions
sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array so tensorflow is
utilizing numpy as part of their format
as far as python is concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think is filling um one of
these with zeros or ones and so you can
see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice
array of
the shape three comma four of zeros one
of the things i want to highlight here
is integer 32. if i go to the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here of 32. the reason for
this is that we want to control how many
bits are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
um and then we can take it but we want
to actually say hey we don't want that
high precision we want to be able to run
this on any computer and so we need to
control
whether it's a tf float 16 in this case
we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32 bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with uh zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand
i use this for masking you can do a lot
of work with masking you can also have
it might be that
one tensor row is massed
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it um
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as
the tensor learns so it's another form
of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four
maybe we wanna swap that to four comma
three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform uh and we'll go ahead and just
take off well we'll go and leave that
we're going to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71
and then instead of having this one it
rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you fill you a lot of times
you fill these with random numbers and
so this is the random dot uniform is one
of the ways to do that now i just talked
a little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these two integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
round it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot or then
convert it to an integer was one way to
round it off
uh kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this and we can take the
same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
our
tensor
let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff just to double check
it
in doing a demo copy and paste works
fine but sometimes be aware that copy
and paste can copy the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
uh one of the things that is important
to be able to do is to take one of these
variables we'll just take this last one
tensor as integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of rolled down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
so we come down here it's all done for
you and so there are so many times you
have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a
as a constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma 2.
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a two by two
array
but instead
we're going to do just a two by one
array and the code for that is your
tf.mat mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times 4 plus 9 times 2. and that's
where we get the 36 and 30. now i know
we're covering a lot really quickly as
far as the basic functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in
numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here we
have the 4 2 and the 5 8 3 9 and it
produces 20 32 6 18.
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have 4 times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity matrix
which is basically
your main values on the diagonal being
ones and zeros across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows
oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows uh two
columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the scripts
the script for that got a wrong button
there the script for that looks like
this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup where you can actually see
the full tensorflow in use for that
let's go back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you've got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full um
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how uh cara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports
date times warning sci pi scipy is your
math so the backend scientific math
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborn for our graphics and the
seaborne as sns is going to be set on
top of our matplot library which we
import as mpl and then of course we're
going to import our matplot library pi
plot as plt and right off the bat we're
going to set some graphic colors um
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library into
seaborne there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our
mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our matplot library is going to
be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the matplot library inline then
warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then what we want to go ahead and
do is we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under cross now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
um tensorflow underneath of it uh we
just brought in the math probably should
have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential now if you
remember from our
uh slide there was three different
options let me just flip back over there
so we can have a quick uh recall on that
and so in karass cross
we have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have a sequential where it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of like think of it as going from
left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential
and then we have our layers and let's
talk a little bit about these layers
this is where cross and tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dents
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer so there's
a lot of stuff in here we had the relu
which is the basic activation that was
listed up here for layer activations you
can change those and here we have our
core layers
and our dense layers we have an input
layer a dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long-term short-term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do
this is white cross is so popular it's
open source and you have all these tools
right at your fingertips so from cross
we're just going to import a couple
layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scalar for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv
let's go ahead and take a quick look at
that this is in open office it's just a
standard you know might do excel
whatever you're using for your
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
a number of columns a number of rows it
actually goes down to like 8 000.
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down
probably not something we're going to
work with
the second row
is bandung i'm guessing that's a
reference for the profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same uh the
same thing with the status the status is
the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
um here is the jam which i'm going to
guess is the time stamp on there so we
have a date and time
we have our o3 co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
10
without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here uh
so we're looking at air quality as far
as an area in a region and what's going
on with our date time stamps on there
and so code wise we're going to read
this into a pandas data frame so our
data frame df is a nice abbreviation
commonly used for data frames
equals pd.read csv and then our the path
to it just happens to be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bandung
the
date we have a timestamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic
pandas printing out the top five rows we
could easily have done
three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our
date time it's come in in two columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame
and the tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i and range df
shape 0.
so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
types date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df date time equals combine date time
and then i always like to uh print we'll
do df head
just to see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this uh we
now have our setup on here and of course
it's edited on to the far right here's
our date time you can see the format's
changed uh so there's our we've added in
the date time column and we've brought
the date over and we've taken this
format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this and we want to convert it into
hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that
to do that
to finish combining our date time let's
go ahead and create a a little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through uh these
conversions how do you
pull it from the panda's data frame how
do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up
uh so that it looks right on here and
you know it just takes time to get
through all that but that is usually
what the companies are paying you for
that's what the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head and df2 is we're going to
group by date time and we're looking at
the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see what we're talking about
uh we have now reorganized this so we
put in date time 03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together so there's a lot more
manageable and in the format we want and
in the right sequential order
and if we go back to um there we go our
air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
um
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
uh minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
um numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable and we'll see
right here q1
we can simply do the quantile 0.25
percent
which should match um our 25 percent up
here and we'll be looking at the min the
max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're breaking this down for
each
different
variable in there
one of the things that's kind of fun to
do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here
clean out some of our um we're going to
drop a couple things our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows
we're going to go ahead and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart
that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science
things we can look at that's important
is uh
use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now
we're looking at this and you can see
right here here's our attribute for our
o3 so we've broken it down
we have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go
back up here here's our 5 8 we've
rounded it off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go uh q1 minus
1.5 times iqr and the iqr is your q3
minus q1 so that's the difference
between our two different quarters and
this is all
data science
as far as the hard math we're really not
we're actually trying to focus on cross
and tensorflow you still got to go
through all this stuff i told you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck
uh happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and it usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outlier is found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know uh crime detection what are we
looking for we're looking for the
outliers what doesn't fit a normal
business deal and then we'll go ahead
and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness uh so we have if your max is
greater than iqr print outlier is found
what we want to do is we want to start
cleaning up these outliers and so we
want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals mini qr so
this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iqr x
equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x
max iqr is 100
min iq r is min iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column
uh then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the
run a map on there and convert the none
hum
you can see here it's this is just
cleanup uh we run we found out that
humidity probably has some weird values
in it
we have our outliers
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like um these
sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then uh converting
it over and setting it up uh method
linear
so we interpolate left
linears it's going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep we're not
actually talking about tensorflow we're
just trying to get all our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we run through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and
use a logarithmic function on the temp
value
and
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you heck do you even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not what i go look at i
don't look at air care data in fact this
is probably the first air care data set
up i've looked at but the experts come
in there and they come to you and say
hey in data science this is a
exponentially variable variable on here
so we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way usually a
phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our
uh we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
of figure figure size here's our plt
from matplot library uh and then we'll
just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas and this is a chart you would
send back to your data analysis and say
hey is this what you wanted this is how
the data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing i note
is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scales to
2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error
and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
uh and then if we go and print this let
me just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
that are going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little
set up in here we create our data set
our data set's going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back minus one
uh
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do the look back one
here's our train x our train y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
when we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x
1296 comma 1
shape of y train y
test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for we want
to look back one that's the
what we're going to train the data with
is yesterday's data yesterday says hey
the humidity was at
97
what should today's humidity be at if
it's 97 yesterday is it going to go up
or is it going to go down today of 97
does it go up to 100 what's going on
there uh and so our we're looking
forward to the next piece of data which
says hey tomorrow's is going to you know
today's humidity is this this is what
tomorrow's humidity is going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer
so we're going to add another reshape on
here let me just go down here and put it
into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're only looking at one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on uh so we're
going to do is we're going to add one
more
level on here instead of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one
1299 one one versus the 1299 one and
then the other part of the shape 432 one
one again this is our tr our x in and of
course our test x and then our y is just
a single column because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for
so now we've done our 80 percent um you
know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network
and if we're going to do that the first
thing we need is we're going to need to
go ahead and create a model and we'll do
this sequential model
and if you remember sequential means it
just goes in order that means we have if
you have two layers the layers go from
layer one to layer two or layer zero to
layer one this is different than
functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory uh and we have our input
shape uh which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm now just about every
tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation
reverse propagation error where it does
reverse propagation to program the model
so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api
layers and i always have to do a search
just search for karass api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu um your
sigmoid all the way up to soft mac soft
plus all these different choices as far
as how those are set up and what we want
to do is we want to go ahead and if you
scroll down here you'll see your core
layers and here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing uh so trying
to find objects in a picture that kind
of thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on uh long short term memory is a big
one because this is when we start
talking about text
uh what if someone says the what comes
after the uh the cat in the hat
little kid's book there
it starts programming it and so you
really want to know not only
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is now once we've built all
our different you know we built our
model we've added our different layers
we went in there
um play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might become linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which we'll use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh
scikit from python uh you'll recognize
that we have to then fit the model
uh so what are we doing in here we're
gonna send in our train x our train y
we're going to decide how many epics
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this
i'm guessing it'd probably be about two
or three hundred probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics
you might try to know what this number
is as a data scientist where i haven't
had the phd level math that says this is
why you want to use this particular
batch size you kind of play with this
number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
um
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this um
you know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations uh but yeah a
terabyte of data we're talking something
closer to days week
you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine and in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of .0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
uh you know if you're retraining the
stuff over and over again it's kind of
good to know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or the
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there
so we can test to see how good it did
when we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not 100 on its
prediction we know it has a certain
amount of error and we want to compare
the error we have on what we programmed
it with with the error we get when we
run it on new data that's never seen the
model has never seen before and one of
the things we can do we go ahead and
invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
exponential m1 the train predict and
then train y equals the exponential m1
for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score
which is your math square root times the
mean square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just feeding the data through so
we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really the code makes sense if you're
going through it line by line you can
see we're doing but the answer really
helps to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score
then we've over trained something's
really wrong at that point you got to go
back and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is
and a lot of times you actually want to
put together like a little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i'd have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
uh and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
uh and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
um you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or you have any idea what that really
means number wise and so at this point
we really want to put it in a graph so
we have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
np empty like data set train predict
plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um
the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here so we have our
train predict plot
which is going to be our look back our
length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train
train predict
so we're creating this basically we're
taking this and we're dumping the train
predict into it so now we have our nice
train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting uh we're
going to continue more of that oops
looks like i put it in here double no
it's just uh yeah they put it in here
double
um didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go um this is where the problem
was is because this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
uh test
predict plot length prediction setup on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure let's go ahead and run that
and then we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do
we're going to do the um the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
uh test predicts plot we're going to
make that red and label it test
prediction
and so forth
set our ticks up this actually just put
ticks time axes gets its ticks
the little little marks there going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little little time stamp and do
just right before and right after where
we go from train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set looked like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right uh and it's
you know there's you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty does pretty good it's pretty
right on you can get a good idea what to
expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice you
kind of flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces
all the tensorflows
and that is to build this sequential
model and we're only putting in the two
layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too haywire on that and that
you kind of learn as you go again it's
domain knowledge
um and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well the data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course uh with any
data science
putting out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders
again we want to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
now let's talk a little bit about
recurrent neural networks so neural
networks are of different types we have
cnn we have rnn and so on now rnn is one
type of neural network rnn stands for
recurrent neural network the networks
like cnn and a n are feed forward
network which means that the information
pretty much only goes from left to right
or from front to back whichever way you
call it whereas in case of recurrent
neural network there will be some
information traveling backwards as well
so that is why it is known as a
recurrent neural network and each of
these types have a specific application
so for example convolutional neural
networks or cnn are very good for doing
image processing and
object detection using for video and
images whereas recurrent neural networks
are pretty good for doing nlp or speech
recognition and so on okay so for the
next few minutes we will kind of focus
on recurrent neural networks and we will
see an example of how we can use rnn to
do a time series analysis so in a
typical neural network this is how it
looks right so where you have a neuron
and then the inputs are coming to the
neuron and then you have an output which
goes to other neurons in the other
layers in case of recurrent neural
network what happens is you have the
inputs let's say at a given point in
time but then a part of the previous
output also gets fed in along with the
inputs for the given time now this can
be little confusing so let's see if we
can take a little expanded view of this
so this is another view of one single
neuron which is what is known as in an
unfolded manner okay so if we are
getting inputs or data over a period of
time then this is how the neuron will
look remember these are not three
neurons this is one neuron and it is
what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are on we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say t minus 1 an input of x t minus 1 is
fed to the neuron and it gets a output
of y t minus one then the next instant
which is x t at a time t right there is
an input of x t and then there is an
output of y t so this is a single neuron
but is displayed in an unfolded weight
so this is like expanding it over a
period of time so let's start with this
part here this particular neuron gets an
input at at an instant t minus 1 let's
say time is equal to t minus 1 it gets
an input of x t minus 1 and it gives an
output of y t minus then when we go to
the instant t here it gets an input of x
t and it also additionally gets an input
from this previous time frame t minus 1.
so this y t minus 1 gets fed here and
that results in y t all right then when
we go to the time t plus 1 there is an
input of x t minus 1 at that given time
plus the input from the previous time
frame which is a time frame of t that
also gets fed in here and then we get an
output of y t plus one okay so let me
explain once again this is a single
neuron so these are not three different
neurons a single neuron seen over a
period of time from t minus one to t
plus one and unlike a regular feed
forward neuron which only gets x in this
case the input is x and also another
input which is coming from the previous
time frame and that is what this loop is
in this on the left hand side diagram
this loop is indicating that okay so on
the right hand side it is represented in
an unfolded way okay so the input if we
take a time frame t for example is not
only x t which is the input which is the
normal input at the time frame t but it
is also getting an input from the
previous time frame which is this yt
minus 1 which is also being fed as an
input that is the key differentiator
here okay similarly at the instant t
plus 1 it is getting a normal input of x
t plus 1 plus this y t is actually being
fed here and then the output comes as y
t plus 1 okay so this is the construct
of a recurrent neural network now
recurrent neural networks again can be
of different subtypes it can be one to
one one too many many to one and many
too many depending on what kind of
application we want to use one of the
examples is like the stock price so
you're feeding so there is only one
input only thing is it is spread over a
period of time so you're feeding the
stock price input that is what comes
here as an input and you get an output
which is again the stock price which is
probably predicted over the next two
days or three days or 10 days or
whatever so the number of outputs and
inputs is the same there is only one
input there is only one output only
thing is it is spread over a time so
variables are not many then you have one
too many so there is one input but you
are expecting multiple outputs what is
an example of this let's say you want to
caption an image so how do you want to
do that what is the input that will go
here is just an image which is one input
but what is output you are looking for
you are looking for a phrase maybe right
not just a word but a phrase so it's
like cat is sitting on a map right so
the images there is only one image which
consists of the cat sitting on a mat but
the output are like maybe three or four
words which is saying the cat is sitting
on a mat so this is one too many right
then you can have many to one examples
of this are like you're feeding some
text and you want to know the output
whether the text is what kind of
sentiment is expressed by the text it
could be positive it could be negative
so that's the output you're looking for
so you feed a large number of words
maybe the text may consist of words or
lines or whatever so that is what is the
multiple inputs but the output all it
says is the sentiment is positive so it
is just one output or the sentiment is
negative just one output right so this
is many to one then we have many too
many so what is an example of this let's
say you want to do some translation so
how do you do a translation you feed in
a sentence maybe in a particular
language english and then you want
another a sentence actually in another
language so that is like there are
multiple inputs one sentence can consist
of multiple words and the output also is
a sentence consisting of multiple words
all right so how do we implement rnn
this is an example of implementing an
rnn for a particular use case so in our
particular example we have the data
about milk production over a few months
and using rnn we want to predict because
this is time series analysis so rnn is
good to do time series analysis so using
rnn we want to predict what will be the
milk production in the future so let us
see how we can do that i will first take
you through quickly through the slides
and then i will actually run this in in
a jupiter notebook the code i will run
it in the jupyter notebook so this is
how it looks the code looks so while
this is tensorflow you still
use the standard python libraries like
numpy and pandas and even matplotlib to
do some initial processing getting the
data processing it cleaning it whatever
all that can be still done in within the
same program so that's what we're doing
here we're importing some libraries like
numpy and pandas and then we read the
data file and if we plot the data we see
here it is the data for for the years
1962 to 75 and we can see that there is
a certain trend right so this is how a
typical time series data would look
again some of you if you are not
familiar with time series and time
series analysis and so on i would
recommend you to go through some videos
around that which will make it easy to
understand this so this is our typical
time series data would look in this case
it is nothing but there is only one
variable which is milk production and it
is spread across several years so this
is going from 1962 to 75 and that value
has been plotted so if you see there is
a certain kind of a trend here which is
basically going upwards and there will
be some seasonality so time series data
has these three components right so it
will have a trend it will have a
seasonality it will have seasonality and
then it will have some randomness so
that's what this graph is showing and
now if we want to perform analysis on
this time series analysis on this first
thing we need to do is split the data
into train and test and in this case we
will just use a straightforward method
which is uh taking the data for the
first 13 years so the idea here is we
need to train our model right this is
time series data so what and we want to
predict for the future so the way we
need to use this is we have to take the
data for a certain period of time and
train our model and then we use a part
of the known data so that we can then
ask our model to predict for that
duration and compare it with the known
information so what do we mean by that
so here if you see this data i will show
you in the notebook as well jupiter
notebook as well this has 13 years of
data so what we are doing is we are
taking the first 12 years and using that
as our training set right so 12 years we
are doing and this has about i think 14
years of data so we are taking 13 years
of data for training purpose and then we
are using the last one year remaining
one year of data for testing purpose
because here what we can do is this one
year data we know the values right
because if we want to compare the
accuracy or anything like that we need
to know the value so in this case we
know the values of this one particular
year so we will use that but at the same
time we train the model for 13 years of
data and for the 14th year we will ask
our model to predict and then compare it
with this known value so that we know
how accurate our model is i hope that
makes sense okay so that's what we are
doing here 156 is nothing but 12 into 13
on a monthly basis we get the data the
next step is to scale the data this is
all regular data manipulation data
munching activity and then you split it
you are basically assigning the train
and test data to the to the scaled
variables and then you need to read the
data in batches so
it is very important as i mentioned
earlier also that instead of reading the
entire data in one shot you feed the
data in batches so in order to do that
we are writing a function for that
that's all we are doing here so that is
still here what we have done is regular
python programming there is no
tensorflow as of now here okay so so far
what we have done is preparation data
preparation data munching now what we
are doing is actually training our model
so this is where tensorflow now comes
into picture so we are importing first
step is to import the tensorflow library
so this is how you do it import
tensorflow sdf and then you can define
some variables or constants whichever
way now here of course there are a
couple of ways of doing it you can
create them as tensorflow nodes but that
is a little bit of an overhead we will
just use the regular python
variables are constant so here i am
creating regular python variables and i
am saying number of inputs is one so
instead of hard coding i'm just storing
them as variables so this is number of
inputs is one number of time steps is 12
number of neurons is hundred and so on
right and then learning rate is 0.03 and
number of iterations we are saying is
4000. then we create placeholders now we
will be storing the independent
variables in x and the dependent
variables in y and this we will read
from an external file remember i told
you placeholders are used for getting
data from outside and then feeding it to
our model so that's the reason we have
two placeholders one for reading the x
values and another for reading the y
values in this step we are only just
creating the nodes right so this is just
creating the graph and similarly we are
mentioning what is the loss function and
what is optimizer and how to run the
optimizer and once that is done you are
initializing the variables and then you
are creating a saver variable or a saver
instance so saver is basically nothing
but in machine learning you can train
your model and you can save it for later
use so that's where the saving comes
into play we will see how to use that as
well and then the last step is to create
your session and run this graph right so
we are initializing the variables
remember this we run init so which is
nothing but this one so we are
initializing the variables whatever are
there instead of hard coding remember in
earlier case we were hardcoding how many
iterations so here we are saying for the
given number of iterations which are
stored in this maybe how many iterations
we said is what is the value of
iterations this is training iterations
is 4000. so we specify that based on the
number of training iterations next batch
will basically fetch the data and then
we run the session we are basically
saying train is the node which we will
run in the session and this will
basically train our model and this is
more for printing every hundred times
you print it that's all this there's
nothing more to it so for example the
output would look somewhat like this
this is for 0 this 400 next for 200 and
so okay and then you save the model you
remember saver we created so you save
the model for later use so this is our
test data remember we are doing this on
training data right so once the training
data training is done we then try to
create the inference on the test data so
that we can compare how accurate this is
right so this is how the test set would
look and
then we will basically restore this
model okay because in the previous slide
we created the model and we stored it so
now we have to restore the model and
then run our test data against it and
see what are the values that are
predicted what are the y values and then
compare with x to see the accuracy so
train seed is what we are seeing here so
that is what will have the predicted
values and
these predicted values what we want to
do is we want to create an additional
column because remember we need to
compare because we want to find out the
accuracy of this model so we need to
compare the predicted values with the
actual value so what we are doing here
is adding another column called
generator and
assign a value to that all right so this
is the result of the prediction and then
if we need to reshape because we have to
show this in the form of a monthly
results so that's what we're doing here
and
once we generate the results and then
display it we can actually see it
month-wise here and
the actual and the generated values okay
so we create a data frame which is a
combination of the actual values and the
predicted values from the test set and
then we can plot to see how the trend is
as you can see pretty much the actual
value is in blue color and the generated
or predicted value the curve is in
yellow color the trend is maintained so
it will probably it's not a hundred
percent accurate but the trend is
maintained all right so let's do one
thing let's go into the jupiter notebook
and take a look at how this works in
tensorflow environment actually the code
i will walk you through the code this is
my jupyter notebook and
the data is taken from this particular
link in case you're interested you can
download it from there and this is the
data for the years
1962-75 the first thing we do is import
these libraries because before we start
with the actual tensorflow activity we
need to prepare the data and so on so
for that you can use your regular python
libraries which are like numpy pandas
and so on so that's what we're doing
here and then we read the data using
pandas into a data frame so this is a
data frame milk is a data frame and we
will do some quick exploratory analysis
just to see how our data is looking
initials five records that we'll get one
two three four five that is ahead so it
goes from 1960 to january to 1960 to may
once we re-change or basically we need
to split this into month specifically
separately so that's what we are doing
here date to time so we kind of do a
little bit of re-indexing and then if we
plot this this is how the data look as
you can see there is a clear upward
trend and
there is some seasonality and so on but
anyway we will not break that up into
those components we will just use rnn to
predict and test okay so the next thing
is to check some if we can do run like
info it will tell us what is the
information about this data set so let
us just run that okay so it is just
telling us how many total columns and
what is the size of the file and so on
and so forth again in case you are
interested in doing some exploratory
analysis so what we'll do next is we
will take the 13 years of data for our
training data set so what are we going
to do now let me step back so what have
we seen here we have seen that there are
168 records so which is nothing but 14
years of data we now have to split this
into our training and test data set so
how do we do that i think in case of
time series we cannot do it like 80 20
like we do in normal splitting in normal
machine learning process here it is time
series data so what we are going to do
is we will take out of this 14 years we
will take the first 13 years of data and
we will use that for training and then
we will test it with the last which is
the 14th year data we will use it for
testing okay so that's what we are going
to do here so let's uh split that so
training set will consist of my 156
records which is nothing but 12 13 into
12 right my 13 years of data i'm taking
for training and then my test set will
consist of the bottom 12 observations
which is last one year of data which is
the 14th year okay so that's now done
training and test splitting is done the
next step is to do some normalizing
which is basically we'll use our scaling
rather we will use min max scala and we
will just scale the data and now we do
it for both test as well as train now we
are ready to create our rnn model but
before that one quick thing in order to
fetch the data we have to create a
function so that's what we are doing
here we create a function called next
batch and how you want to fetch the
steps they are all defined as our
constants if you remember and that's
what this function is all about so we
define that function we will be calling
that in our training method all right so
from here onwards up to there we are
done with the preparation of the data
and whatever functions or whatever are
required from here onwards is where the
tensorflow part starts so the first
thing we do is import the tensorflow
library typically this is a very
standard way of importing the library we
say import tensorflow as tf now tf is
nothing but a name so you can change it
to tf1 or abc or xyz whatever so this
part you can change but by and large
everybody uses this so i would rather
recommend you also use the same syntax
so you say import tensorflow stf so it's
very easy for others to understand as
well and then you declare or define
a bunch of constants uh that's what we
are doing here like for example the
number of uh time steps in this case it
is 12 number of neurons there are 100
number of outputs it is only one and so
on right and then the learning rate and
all that we are declaring or defining
those variables in this particular block
next is to create placeholders you
remember the placeholders are used for
feeding the data so we have x and y x is
for the input which is the independent
variable and y is the output which is
the dependent variable and in our case
these are not different characteristics
or features but it is the same one
feature or one variable but it is over a
period of time so that's the only
difference so that's what we are doing
here and now we need to create our
network right the neural network so in
our case we said we will create a rnn
layer now there are different ways or
different formats of rnn which is
for creating our layer so each cell will
be with an output projection wrapper
there is a need for doing that and again
the details of this we will probably do
in another video where we talk in detail
about rnn so for now we are creating a
gre cell with the wrapper and the the
syntax for creating the gru cell is like
this the number of units which we we
said there should be 100 neurons what
will be the activation function in this
case it is relu and then number of
outputs in our case it is only one okay
so we create the cell here okay then we
got the gru cell and then we say what is
our output which is nothing but we get
the outputs and the states and their
states and which is uh the way we get
that is tf.nnn
dot dynamic underscore rnn so if we call
this and we pass the cell and the data
which is basically in placeholder again
remember all we are doing here is we are
creating just the nodes for the graph so
nothing is actually getting executed
from a tensorflow perspective okay all
right so once that is done now we need
to pass this calculate the outputs and
the states using the dynamic underscore
rna method and we pass the cell as a
parameter and then the x values as a
parameter and if we
run that
we will have the outputs and the states
and this is where we actually run the
training method
so
or create not really run the training
method but we create the nodes for the
training and optimizer then we have the
initialization of the variables and we
save this model we create a saver object
just to save the model because we will
then restore it and run it to do our
predictions so this is what we will do
here so that is another node and this is
where we actually create a session and
run the training okay so let's go ahead
and do that that will take a little
while because we said 4000 iterations so
we will allow it to finish we will
probably come back once the training is
completed all right so the training is
done now let's go and
run this on the test data so let's just
quickly take a look at the test data set
so this is our one year data for the
year of 1975 so
if we see this is from january february
and so on and we will pass this to our
model so what are we doing here we are
restoring the model here for example
right this is the path that we have
given when we were saving the model
let's go back once and show you let me
show you where we did the saving of the
model yes so we save the model here so
that again we will restore that and we
will use that to run it on our test data
and see how well it predicts so let's go
ahead and run this and this is just 12
records so this will not take time
remember i told you training is what
takes a lot of time the regular
inference this is called inference
doesn't take much time right so it just
depends on how much data there were only
12 records here so it was very quick but
in training what we do we pass this
multiple times there are iterations 4
000 iterations we did for example so
that takes longer and in general in
machine learning deep learning training
is what takes the maximum amount of time
all right so let's go ahead and see the
results we will in order to plot it we
will have to kind of adjust the format
of the results otherwise we will not be
able to see it in a proper way and then
we will so this is our so what we have
done is we created a data frame which
consists of the predicted value and and
the actual value so this is the data
frame so this is the actual value this 8
834 782 and so on this is what our model
has predicted so it may not be so easy
to see in a tabler format so let's go
ahead and plot it so that we can compare
these two so when we plot it you will
see that the trend is more or less
maintained right so we go from the blue
color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color
whatever is it is the one which is
generated by our model so it pretty much
is following the actual trend so not bad
for such a quick iteration and
training this tutorial is about object
detection we will walk you through a
tensorflow code using which we will do
object detection in images we will tell
you what are the libraries that are
required a little bit about the cocoa
data set and then we will show you the
implementation code itself a demo of the
code all right so let's get started so
what is the tensorflow object detection
api this is an open source framework
which is actually provided by the
tensorflow team and there are trained
models available and the sample code is
also available which we can use in order
to easily detect objects in images and
videos this is pretty robust and can
detect objects fairly quickly and this
is very easy for people to use as well
people with very less or no knowledge of
machine learning or deep learning can
also with a little bit of python
programming knowledge can actually use
this api this library to build object
detection applications this is a list of
libraries that are required and they
have been shown in the code as well the
exact purpose of each of this library
why it is required is
out of the scope of this tutorial but we
will see in the code as we walk through
some of these libraries how and why they
are used the cocoa data set coco stands
for common objects in context
so this data set consists of 300 000
images of
90 most commonly found objects like
chairs and tables and so on and so forth
so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a large part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as i said the exact
details of each and every library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe a later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and
we
also need this line of code to make sure
that once we
run this object detection the labeled
images are displayed within this
notebook and many of you by now must be
familiar with this
and we will import a few utility
libraries and you will see that we will
be using some of these
for visualization purpose so once the
objects are detected we need to display
the information what that object is and
then what percentage of confidence the
model has so all these details that's
the utility functions that stored here
and then the next part is to prepare the
model as i mentioned we will be using an
existing trained model
the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is ssd with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this url let me
just quickly take you through this url
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with the accuracy
is much higher but they take longer and
there are some where the accuracy is not
so high and they are much faster so they
are faster but the accuracy may not be
that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
ssd model which is ssd mobile at
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in the next step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as a
frozen model so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if i can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it
completes i have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping our basically
what this will do is your model as you
may be aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output
text it will give some numbers so if
there are five classes it will say okay
this belongs to modern class one or two
or three or five and so on the numbers
now each of these will obviously the
numbers will not make any sense to the
outside world so we need to do some
small mapping so in this case let's say
one maybe a chair two maybe a table
three maybe a balloon and so on so that
kind of number to text mapping we need
to do and that is what is being done in
this particular cell and then we have a
helper code which will load the image
and convert it into a numpy array so
that the number array is what gets
processed and used by the model to do
the detection part of it so that is what
this
method is all about so we will be the
later on we will be calling that
function and
next is preparation for detection so
here we are basically telling where the
images are stored and how many images or
what is the naming convention or format
of the images now if you want you can
modify this code for example currently i
have test underscore images as my folder
so let me go and show this to you so
this is under my object detection folder
i have another subfolder where i am
storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the subfolder
similarly the format of these files what
is the name and format of this files
here it is in a very simple format which
is the names of the files are like beach
one beach two b3 and so on so i have
taken beach as the theme so i have
images which are related to beaches so
this is beach one beach two and then
beach three a few others but we will use
these three for our demo and so that's
what i'm saying here the name of the
images will be beach something dot jpeg
which is jpeg format and in this curly
braces basically we will will be filled
with either
one two or three based on in this
particular for loop okay so that is what
this is doing all right so the next step
is to run inference on these images in a
loop and what we are basically doing
here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is
the function here and so let me just run
that piece of code and here is basically
where we are calling this function so we
are loading this images and then we are
calling this function for each image and
then we are displaying this using the
matplotlib library so let's run this it
will take one image at a time and then
detect the images now the beauty is that
the same format of the code can be used
for doing object detection in a video so
we have another video for doing object
detection in a video so most of the code
out there will be reused from here and
the only thing is that instead of
reading the images from the local
storage
we read the frames from the video and
there is a neat little video reader that
is available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as if each of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just uh look out for that and
actually the information about that is
uh provided in the cards the eye symbol
so that's the the video object detection
in video that's the separate uh tutorial
all right so now that we have all the
pieces together this the last cell is
where the whole action takes place so
let's run this and see how it looks so
it will take probably a little while and
there are about three images let's see
what it detects there we go so good so
the first one it has detected a person
and that too with 97 percent accuracy
which is i think pretty good
okay and then the next image it detects
umbrella and chair there are a few other
objects but it's not able to detect it
has detected umbrella with 63 percent
accuracy or confidence rather and the
chair with 58 percent again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is a
kite which is uh probably not that bad
it sees there is something in the sky
and therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all i wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about
object detection in images and in this
video i will walk you through the
tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically we are
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image io datetime and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again we could go away right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
what we are going to do is we're going
to use an existing neural network model
so we are not going to chain a new one
because that really will uh take a long
time and uh it needs a lot of
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
modules that have been trained and in
this case it is the ssd with mobilenet
that's the model that we are going to
use and this model is trained to detect
objects and it is readily available as
open source so we can actually use this
and if you want to use other models
there are a few more models available so
you can click on this
link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original traffic.mp4 and now you have
here traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and
our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and
even when the cat moves a little bit in
the other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and i'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r classes come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see
yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but
it is trying to detect something i think
it is saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and uh let's wait for some
time and see if it continues to detect
it when the cat turns around and moves
as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it thank you very much for watching this
video in this tutorial we will take the
use case of recognizing
handwritten digits this is like a hello
world
of deep learning and this is a nice
little mnist database is a nice little
database that has images of handwritten
digits nicely formatted because very
often
in deep learning and neural networks we
end up spending a lot of time in
preparing the data for training and with
mnist database we can avoid that
you already have the data in the right
format which can be directly used for
training and mnist also offers a bunch
of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are hand
written images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have hand written these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and
the data is basically these images are
stored in the form of the pixel
information as we have seen in one of
the previous slides all the images are
nothing but these are
pixels so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are 784 pixels so pixel number 1
starts here it goes all the way up to 28
then 29 starts here and goes up to 56
and so on and the pixel number 784 is
here so we take all these pixels flatten
them out and feed them like one single
line into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a soft max layer what it does
is once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10 neurons each
signifying a digit and at any given
point of time when you feed an image
only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is strained
properly
and
if you feed a number 9 like this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine
let's say this has been trained and now
if you're feeding a number nine this
will get
activated now let's say you feed one to
the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as soft max layer so that's what
we will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and
once you do this tf is tensorflow is
available as an object in the name of tf
and then you can run its methods and
accesses its attributes and so on and so
forth and mnist database is actually an
integral part of tensorflow and that's
again another reason why we as a first
step we always use this example mnist
database example so you just simply
import mnist database as well using this
line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just use pen to show what exactly
it is so when you do this one hot true
what happens is each label is stored in
the form of an array of 10 digits and
let's say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position 0 this is
at position 1 position 2 and so on and
so forth let's say this is position 7
then this is position 8 that will be 1
because our input is 8 and again
position 9 will be 0 okay so one hot
encoding this one hot encoding true will
kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on which
digit is one we know what is the label
so in this case the eighth position is
one therefore we know this sample data
the value is eight similarly if you have
a two here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as zero the zeroth position the first
position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can check how the data
is uh looking by displaying the the data
and as i mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not really see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image i will show you
in a bit and
this tells you how many images are there
in each set so the training there are 55
000 images in training and in the test
set there are 10 000 and then validation
there are 5 000 so all together there
are 70 000
images all right so let's
move on and we can
view the actual
image by
using the matplotlib library and this is
how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the c map is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value so 1 means it is
white and 0 means it is black and in
between
is it can be anywhere in between black
and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your remember these are your weights and
biases so for in our case there are 10
neurons and each neuron actually has 784
because each neuron takes all the inputs
if we go back to our slide here actually
every neuron takes all the 784 inputs
right this is the first neuron it has it
receives all the 784 this is the second
neuron this also receives all the 700 so
each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are this is a a matrix
of
784
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784 matrix because there
are 10 neurons
and similarly there are biases now
remember i mentioned
biases only one per neuron so it is not
one per input unlike the weights so
therefore there are only 10 biases
because there are only 10 neurons in
this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables are at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with w
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding b and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn soft max cross entropy with
logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a slide somewhat like
this and then you define what should be
the learning rate how fast you need to
come down that is the learning rate and
this again needs to be tested and tried
and to find out the optimum level of
this learning rate it shouldn't be very
high in which case it will not converge
or shouldn't be very low because it will
in that case it will take very long so
you define the optimizer and then you
call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kick-start the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we wanted
to run so for example in this case we
are saying thousand steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so training will run
for thousand iterations and once that is
done
we can then evaluate the model using
some of the techniques
shown here so let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can
use and
run and try the code okay so it has got
started
we will login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial uh code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and
so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walkthrough uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately and if we
just check what is the type of the data
so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float 32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5000 now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and if we take a look at the shape now
shape gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one image and just see what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
784 similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is blank so that's why you
will mostly see zero say that it is
black or white but then there are these
values are so the values are actually
they are scaled so the values are
between zero and one okay so this is
what you're seeing so
certain locations there are some values
and then other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now i
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
5000
right so
5000 has 3 similarly you can just say 5
what is in 5
5 as 8
what is in 50
again 8 so basically by the way if
you're wondering how i am executing this
code shift enter
in case you are not familiar with
jupiter notebooks shift enter is how you
execute each cell individual cell and if
you want to execute the entire program
you can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between one and zero now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10 actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned one for
each neuron so there will be 10 biases
they are stored in a variable by the
name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value
so this is another placeholder we had x
as one placeholder and white underscore
true as a second placeholder and this
will have values in the form of
10 digit 10 digit arrays
and
since we set one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating the variables and feeding
the variables and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have created the variables
how to load the data loaded the data
viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution intensive
law so the first step for
doing any execution in tensorflow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a width loop so you have a
width
tf dot session as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf dot session as says you say says
dot run init now says dot run will
execute a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run cess is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that
says and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w
is a variable and b is a variable so any
variables that we created you have to
run this code you have to run the
initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this with block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for a
thousand steps and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of performing deep
learning training you always do in
batches so we have maybe 50 000 images
but you always do it in batches of 100
or maybe
500 depending on the size of your
system and so on and so forth so in this
case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of hundred images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously they
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be 100 accurate
okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then test the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set
right so this is what we are trying to
do here the code may appear a little
complicated because if you're seeing
this for the first time you need to
understand uh the various methods of
tensorflow and so on but it is basically
comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model
is in predicting these numbers or these
digits okay so let us run this this
entire thing is in one cell so we will
have to just run it in one shot it may
take a little while let us see
and not bad so it has finished the
thousand iterations and what we see here
as an output is the accuracy so we see
that the accuracy of this model is
around 91 percent okay now which is
pretty good for such a short exercise
within such a short time we got 90
percent accuracy however in real life
this is probably not sufficient so there
are other ways in to increase the
accuracy we will see probably in some of
the later tutorials how to improve this
accuracy how to change maybe the hyper
parameters like number of neurons or
number of layers and so on and so forth
and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent we're going to dive
right into what is keras we'll also go
all the way through this into a couple
of tutorials because that's where you
really learn a lot is when you roll up
your sleeves so we talk about what is
cross cross is a high level deep
learning api written in python for easy
implement implementation
of neural networks it uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks uh is
really powerful it's really powerful to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a backend for fast
computation
while providing a user friendly and easy
to learn front-end and you can see here
we have the cross api uh specifications
and under that you'd have like tf cross
for tensorflow thano cross and so on and
then you have your tensorflow workflow
that this is all sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
the working principle of keras is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put in blue they
have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators
where we have like the percentage or in
this case in python that's usually your
left your remainder
or multiplication uh you might have the
operator of x to the power of 0.3 and it
uses useful for calculating derivatives
by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
uh this makes it really easy to do that
without
really having not banging your head and
having to hand write everything it's
easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems
specify input and outputs and make sure
all nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation in any of these
setups this should look familiar you
should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code as you can see how easy
it is
uh we have a layer that's dense your
layer one
has an activation now they're using the
relu in this particular example and then
you have your name layer one layer dense
relu name layer 2 and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your cross
or you'll find yourself running this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi input and multi
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dan 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
and one way you could think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full-sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one note because it's
looking for one thing and then only into
one node for the other one and so you
can start to get kind of an idea that
there's a lot of use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want it to send it through the same
neural network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data and
how you fork the models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex uh models coming in uh we have
our image inputs which is a 32 by 32 by
three or three channels or four if
you're having an alpha channel uh
you have your dense your layers dense is
64 activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at cross
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks uh but it's
always good to get on the same page and
for those people who don't fully
understand neural networks to dive into
them a little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models
they're kind of uh when you first start
using them they're like a black box you
put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with cross the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
uh what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands-on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and
showing people especially shareholders
it really helps because it's a nice
visual so let me go and flip over to our
anaconda and the anaconda has a lot of
cool two tools they just added data lore
and ibm watson studio cloud into the
anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook i'm gonna do jupiter
notebook for this because i use the lab
for like large projects with multiple
pieces because multiple tabs where the
notebook will work fine for what we're
doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter helps our
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python 3 and it creates an
untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this
cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
um i mentioned sklearn or your scikit if
you're installing sklearn the sk learn
stuff it's a scikit you want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2 100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at
and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more
complicated information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and create if you look
here we have random integers
trading the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data
and if you if i mean you can certainly
ask for a copy of the code from
simplylearn they'll send you a copy of
this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples of pin
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on uh that had to do with errors
following a bell shaped curve on
a standard distribution error and so
what do i do i generate the data on a
standard distribution error to see what
it looks like and how my code processes
it since that was the baseline i was
looking for in this we're just doing
generating random data for our setup on
here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples
and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
19
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that um let's
see 50 up here 1000. yeah so there's
1000 here 1000 numbers we generated and
we could also if we wanted to find that
out we can do a quick print the length
of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
uh so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms
zero none and so we want to go ahead and
take our train labels and we'll convert
it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle this is just a neat
feature you can do in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
so we have our so
it just randomizes it that's all that's
doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that that you know the input doesn't
follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh and then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're gonna go
ahead and fit and transform the data
uh so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data
to 0 and 1. otherwise you create a bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated um
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook is that if you have
a variable you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.919
so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data is sent
to me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
tensorflow
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start uh back
in 2011 google brain built disbelief as
a proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defactos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it it's got like a huge following there
are some other setups like um the side
kit under the sk learn has their own
little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool
so we can leverage both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of
tensorflow uh and then we have the rest
of this is all cross here from number
two down
uh
we're gonna import from tensorflow the
cross connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential it's a specific
kind of model we'll look at that in just
a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
uh and then we have from tensorflow
cross layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize
your data when you first do it atoms as
good as any atom is usually there's a
number of optimizer out there there's
about there's a couple of main ones but
atom is usually assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day at the end
of the story how good does your model do
and we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes the fun part um i actually
like to spend hours messing with these
things
and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code
uh what we have here i'm gonna explain
that in just a second we have a model
and it's a sequential model if you
remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be our
input
it's going to be what they call dense
which is
usually just dense and then you have
your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape
what's the activation and this is where
it gets interesting
because we have in here
relu
on two of these and soft max activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things um
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a
inverse tangent activation or the 10 h
activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
you'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh it let me do this
rayleigh there we go relu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like is you build
your uh what they call you build to fail
and it's an interesting uh design setup
oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept to build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out that the
quality of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go it was right above me there we go
we start doing your cross entropy and
stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say spend a huge
amount of time on pre-processing data is
probably 80 percent of your programming
time
well between those two it's like 80 20
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things
and we can do a simple model summary
here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built
the next thing we're going to want to do
is we're going to go ahead
and train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here
this a lot of times it's just paired
with the model because it's so
straightforward
it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the key word in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
the setup is your learning rate so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate set to
0.00
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate
can overfit and underfit
so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and underfitting that are
really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell keras how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit
most of the time though a batch size is
between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and
put the verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
here's our loss
now if you remember correctly up here we
set the loss let's see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss so it's looking at the
sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much
how how much does the
error go down
is the best way to look at that and you
can see here the lower the number the
better it just keeps going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to one
but we also the loss is
more important because
it's a balance
you can have 100 accuracy and your model
doesn't work because it's over fitted
again you won't look up over fitting and
under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through
30 epics it's always fun to kind of
watch your code going
to be honest i
usually uh uh the first time i run it
i'm like oh that's cool i get to see
what it does and after the second time
of running it i'm like i'd like to just
not see that and you can repress those
of course in your code uh repress the
warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transformed down here
instead of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose and now we
have our predictions in here and we
could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and
the prediction on this age versus what
is what we think it's going to be but
what we think is going to they're going
to have
symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want to
yes no answer
so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max
for prediction so it just goes to 001
and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrix is for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the site kit
the sk learn metrics
site kit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matplot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
um and then we'll go ahead and call it
cm for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
but we do have here is we're gonna do a
plot confusion matrix there's our cm our
classes normalize false title confusion
matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest cmap titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this uh
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders you don't want to do this
on the fly you want to take the time to
make it look really nice like our guys
in the back did and let's go ahead and
do this forgot to put together our cm
plot labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195. had side effects
200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted that 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a hundred uh
you can do the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show uh
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a uh i spent a lot of time
on some of the parts uh but you can see
here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we get a lot more complicated let me
flip back on over here because we're
going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with cross after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it
learn on training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
[Music]
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
and put that information in here and it
goes through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative and so the
blue ones uh we want those to be the
biggest numbers because those are the
better side and then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so i had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now uh saving and loading models with
carrass we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you can say oh that was a lot of
complication before well if you broke it
down we randomized some data we created
the um cross setup we compiled it we
trained it we predicted and we ran our
matrix
so we're going to dive into something a
a little bit more fun is we're going to
do a face mask detection with cross so
we're going to build a cross model to
check if a person is wearing a mask or
not in real time and this might be
important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own
and this is just such a wonderful
example of this setup on here
so before i dive into the mass detection
uh talk about being in the current with
a covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks this particular example i had to
go ahead and update to a python 3.8
version uh it might run in a three seven
i'm not sure i kind of skipped three
seven and installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a 3 python 38
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the um they call functional
layers with that's where they split if
you remember correctly from back uh
let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through uh our next example which
includes
uh multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code
and we'll open up a new python three
oops python three
it's working on it there we go
and then we want to go ahead and train
our mask we'll just call this train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's
safe mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross stand point we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them
so we have in here
we go alt d there we go
have something to draw with a little bit
here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here the
underline that
uh deals with how do we bring images in
because most images
are like a
square grid and then each value in there
has three values for the three different
colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listening and
figuring out what's going to go on
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when as you get more and
more into cross and tensorflow
it will auto drop out certain nodes that
way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die
they find that they actually create more
of a bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a one
dimensional array instead of a two by
two by three
dense input we did that in the other one
so that should look a little familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing in the
data in
uh more pre-processing with image to
array loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of works you have to import all
these different modules in here but the
truth is is it does everything for you
you're not doing a lot of pre-processing
you're letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category zero one doesn't
really mean anything it's like true
false
label binarizer the same thing
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train test split
classification report
our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit setup and tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the
second piece when we reload up the data
and hook it up to a video camera we're
going to do that on this round
but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
uh and resize them and then the matplot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just the straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epics to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate to the negative
4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics the epics is how
many times we're going to go through all
the data
now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this no matter what
so it doesn't matter
so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
um and then you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
and then we have the opposite let me go
back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of a skew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had a
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a 32 gig hard drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even 8 gigs would
easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert the size of the image so it
resizes all the images that way our data
is all identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
uh and then we need to change it to the
one not hot encoding
and this is going to take our um
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask one zero one zero so on
one being they have a mask and zero no
mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one so
zero
is uh do they have a mask on zero do
they not have a mask on one so this is
the same as what we saw up here without
mask one equals
the second value is without mass so with
mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a 0 1
output
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual uh linear value or regression
values or not actual numbers
if they represent a thing and so now we
need to go ahead and do our train x test
x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20
percent of it for testing and the rest
for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean
well if i rotate the data around and i
zoom in i zoom out i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as i do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
so that you can better train your model
and so we go and run this and then we're
going to load
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have got an error if you
hadn't put this piece in right here
i haven't run it myself because the guys
in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this what we this is a big thing
right here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
size of the pictures and the weights for
input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults
just saying hey we're going to auto
shape some of this stuff for you you
should be aware that with this kind of
imagery we're already augmenting it by
moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flatten
so we're flattening the data
so this is all
processing and flattening the images and
the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dents just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a dropout
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from forming so it's really
a cool feature in here they discovered
this a while back
we have another dense mode this time
we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here softmax is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so is a relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas uh and why
what their different uses are and how
they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them uh just because they're
some of the basic setups it's a good
place to start
uh and then we have our model equals
model inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i
i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and
specifically in stock data i wanted to
iterate through the first set of 30 data
before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which will have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model uh so train the
head of the network print info training
head run
now i skipped a little time because it
you'll see the run time here is um at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're while it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and trading y go in
there's some randomness going on there
and is jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
of course we're batch sizing it so it's
going through whatever we set for the
batch values how many we process at a
time
and then we have the steps per epic
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our test x and test y where
we're sending that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you've trained it and your accuracy is
higher on your actual test data then
something in there is probably uh has a
bias and it's overfitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we go ahead and go down
here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either zero or one it's a
zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh not wearing uh wearing a mask
not wearing a mask
and so we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and change those
predictions to a
0 or 1 coming out
and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision it's 97 with the mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mask 97 percent
so that's pretty high set up on there
you know you three people are going to
sneak into the store who
are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
um so there you have it and of course
one of the other cool things about this
is if someone's walking in to the store
and you take multiple pictures of them
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff
so we're going to go ahead and take our
model and we're going to save it
so model save massdetector.model we're
going to give it a name
we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
save the model they upload the model now
they can use it for whatever and then if
i get more information
and we start working with that at some
point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on uh
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
scikit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence is our loss and our accuracy
come together and also up here and this
is why i'd run it more than just two
epics as you can see they still haven't
converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our
mobile net v2 import pre-processing
input so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of this stuff is going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little open cv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of
the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here
and then we're going to create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
uh so we're going to detect and predict
the mask we have frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have a frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know
what we're going to be processing
through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
uh so these this is what's going on here
this is that model we just created we're
going to send that in there and i'll
show you in a second where that is but
it's going to be under face net
and then we go ahead and initialize our
list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mass network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
what happens if you have a crowd of
faces
so we're looping through the detections
and the shapes going through here
and probability associated with the
detection
here's our confidence of detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum
confidence so we've set it remember zero
to one so 0.5 would be our minimum
confidence probably is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box uh the box sets
it around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
so we create a box around what's going
to be hope is going to be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times i
forgot to check the order colors when
working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red uh and we're gonna
go ahead and resize it process it frame
it
face frame
setup again the face the cbt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start x dart y
and x
boy that was just a huge amount and i
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face
and that box because the open cv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
uh
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32.
uh so these different images of where
we're guessing where the face is are
then going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction
that's the big thing that we're working
for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously going to put it in a
different path depending on where you
have it or however you want to do it and
how you saved it on the last one where
we trained it
and then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equal
dot read cb2.dnn.readnet
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling on all the different pieces
we need for our model
and then the next part is we're going to
create open up our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
video set up
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
uh so we're going to go ahead and open
up our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos is that when you start
working with images and videos it's all
like right there in front of you it's
visual and you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start that means it's
k grabbing my main camera i have hooked
up
and then you know starting video you're
going to print it out
here's our video source equals 0 start
loop over the frames from the video
stream
oops a little redundancy there
let me close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so
so while true we're going to grab the
frame from the threaded video stream and
resize it to have the maximum width of
400 pixels so here's our frame we're
going to read it
from our visual
stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we returned from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mast net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask l0 225 and you know it's
going to make a lot more sense when i
hit the run button here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv to im
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our
our model we've loaded it up into our
distributed
code here we've got a hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we see the data coming down
here and we're waiting for the pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky head set on
uh
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen uh you can see my no
mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you have this really neat setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or
public transportation or whatever it is
where they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the karass
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see that the model
works we actually have this working
model that hooks into the video camera
which is just pretty cool a lot of fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh
demo up above for just pulling in across
and then we went into a cross model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application
what is in it for you today we're going
to cover what is keras
computational graphs
what are neural networks sequential
models and then we'll do a hands-on demo
so you can see what's going on with
sequential models and keras
so what is keras
cross is a high-level python deep
learning api
which is used for easy implementation of
neural networks it has multiple
low-level back-ends like tensorflow
fano
pi torch etc which are used for fast
computation
so you can think of this as cross being
almost its own little programming
language
and then it sits on neural networks in
this case uh the ones listed were
tensorflow thano and pytorch which can
all integrate with the cross model
this makes it very diverse and also
makes it very easy to use and switch
around with different things
cross is very
user friendly as far as neural network
software goes as a high level api
computational graphs
so computational graphs are really the
heart and soul of neural networks
we talk about a computational graph
they are a visual representation of
expressing and evaluating mathematical
equations
the nodes and data flow in a graph
correspond to mathematical operations
and variables
you'll hear a lot
some of the terms you might hear are
node and edge the edge being the data
flow in this case
it could also represent an actual value
they have
oh i think in spark they have a graph x
which works just on computing edges
there's all kinds of stuff that has
evolved from computational graphs we're
focusing just on keras and on neural
networks so we're not going to go into
great detail on everything a
computational graph does
it is a core component of a neural
network is what's important to know on
this
so cross offers a python user-friendly
front-end while maintaining a strong
computation power by using a low-level
api
like tensorflow pi torch etc which use
computational graphs as a back end
so one this allows for abstraction of
complex problems while specifying
control flow
if you've ever looked at some of the
backend or the original versions of
tensorflow
it's really a nightmare you have all
these different settings you have to put
in there and create
it's a lot of a lot of back in
programming this is like the old
computers when you had to
tell it how to dispose of a variable and
how to properly re-allocate the memory
for use
all that is covered nowadays in our
higher level programming well this is
the same thing with keras is it covers a
lot of this stuff and does things for
you that you could spend hours on just
trying to figure out
it's useful for calculating derivatives
by using back propagation
we're definitely not going to teach a
class on derivatives uh in this little
video
but understanding uh a derivative is the
rate of change so if you have a
particular function you're using in your
neural network
a lot of them is just simple
y equals mx plus b
your euclidean geometry where you just
have a simple slope times the intercept
and they get very complicated they have
the inverse tangent function for
activation as opposed to just a linear
euclidean model and you can think about
this as you have your data coming in and
you have to alter it somehow
well you alter it going down to get an
answer you end up with an error and that
error goes back up and you have to have
that back propagation with the
derivative you want to know how it
changed so that you can figure out how
to adjust it for the error
a lot of that's hidden so you don't even
have to worry about it with cross and in
today's cross you'll even if you create
your own
formula for computing an answer it will
automatically compute the back prop the
the derivative for you in a lot of cases
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
so cross is really nice way to package
it and get it off on different computers
and share it and it allows parallelism
which means that two operations can run
simultaneously
so as we start developing these back
ends it can do all kinds of cool things
and utilize multiple cores gpus on a
computer
to get that parallel processing up
what are neural networks
well like i said there are already we've
talked about in computational edges you
have a node and you have a connection or
your edge so neural networks are
algorithms fashioned after the human
brain which contain multiple layers each
layer contains a node called a neuron
which performs a mathematical operation
they break down complex problems into
simple operations
so one an input layer takes in our data
and pre-processes it
when we talk about pre-processing when
you're dealing with neural networks uh
you usually have to pre-process your
data so that it's between
minus one and one or zero and one
um into some kind of value that's usable
that occurs before it gets to the neural
network in fact 80 of data science is
usually in prepping that data and
getting it ready for your different
models
two you have hidden layer performs a
non-linear transformation of input
now it can do a hidden a linear
transformation it can use just a basic
um euclidean geometry and you could
think of a node adding all the different
connections coming in uh so each
connection would have a weight
and then it would add to that weight
plus an intercept in the note itself so
you can actually use euclidean geometry
but a lot of these get really
complicated they have all these
different formulas and they're really
cool to look at but when you start
looking at them look at how they work
you really don't need to know the high
math behind it
to figure them out and figure out what
they're doing
which is really cool that means a lot of
people can use this without having to go
get a phd in mathematics
number three the output layer takes the
results from hidden layer transform them
and gives a final output
so sequential models
so what makes this a sequential model
sequential models are linear stacks of
layers where one layer leads to the next
it is simple and easy to implement and
you just have to make sure that the
previous layer is the input to the next
layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output
tensor and this is what tensorflow is
named after is each one of these layers
is like a tensor
each node is a tensor and the layer is
also considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about uh this is something this
is a teapot this is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating um
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars uh the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas and different notations when
you're in data science so when we talk
about time series we'll talk about
sequential that is something very
different sequential in this case means
it goes from the input to layer 1 to
layer 2 to the output so it's very
directional
it's important to note this because if
you have a sequential model can you have
a non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers
you can have another model where you
have an input coming in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of nodes maybe they're doing a
yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a zero or a one a classifier
and the other one might be regression
it's just processing numbers and then
you recombine them for the output that's
what they call across the cross api
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that we're just focusing on
the basic cross model with the
sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do and do a demo on here
today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo on whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python
i'm actually using anaconda and then i'm
using jupyter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created environment you can come in here
to open a terminal window
and if you don't have the different
modules in here you can do your conda
install whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a seaborn in it which i
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then i'm
going to go back
and start up my jupiter notebook
where i already created a new
python project python3 i'm in python 3.8
on this particular one
sequential model for flowers so lots of
fun there
so we're going to jump right into this
the first thing is to make sure you have
all your modules installed
so if you don't have numpy pandas
matplot library and seaborn and the
cross
an sk learn or site kit it's not
actually sklearn you'll need to go ahead
and install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
i get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
right off the bat though we have numpy
pandas matplot library seaborn these are
built on top of each other panda's the
data frame and built on top of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our sklearn or
scikit this is the scikit setup sci
kit
even though you use sklearn to bring it
in it's a scikit and then our cross we
have our pre-processing the images image
data generator
our model this is our basic model our
sequential model
uh and then we bring in from cross
layers import dents
optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now um adam
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our sgd which is uh
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data
and i'm not going to go into all of
these
different optimizers we didn't even use
these in the actual demo you just have
to be aware that they are different
optimizers and the digger the more you
dig into these models
you'll hit a point where you do need to
play with these a little bit but for the
most part leave it at the default when
you're first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have dropout they have
flatten they have activation
they have the convolutional
layer 2d max pooling 2d
batch normalization
what are all these layers and when we
get to the model we're going to talk
about them a lot of times when you're
just starting you can just
import cross dot layers and then you
have your drop out your flattened
your convolutional
neural network 2d
and we'll we'll cover what these do in
the actual example when we get down
there
what i want you to take from here though
is you need to run your imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow tf because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally import random is rn
just for random generation
and then we get down here we have our
cv2
that is your
open image or your opencv they call it
for processing images that's what the
cvd2 is
we have our tqdm
the tqdm is for um it's a progress bar
just a fancy way
of adding when you're running a process
you can view the bar going across in the
jupiter
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
we want to shuffle some files uh again
these are all different things pill is
another
um
image processor it goes with the cv2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all
in and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so when we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an x and a z
and the x is the date of the image and
the z is the tag for it what kind of
flower is this
and the image size is really important
because we have to resize everything if
you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks let me
flip back to that slide
we look at this slide we have two input
nodes here with an image you have an
input node
depending on how you set it up for each
pixel and that pixel has three different
color schemes usually in it sometimes
four so if you have a picture that's 150
by 150
you multiply 150 times 150 times three
that's how many nodes input layers
coming in i mean so this is a massive
input a lot of times you think oh yeah
it's just a small amount of data or
something like that
no it's a full image coming in
and then you have your hidden layers a
lot of times they match what the image
size is coming in so each one of those
is also just as big and then we get down
to just a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so i'm just setting the directories
that's all this is
archive flowers daisy sunflower tulip
dandelion rose
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
uh and then we want to go ahead and we
need to assign labels remember we
defined x and z
so we're just going to create a
definition here
and the first thing is uh return flower
type okay
it just returns it what kind of flower
it is i guess a sign label to it
but we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here the
first one is we're just appending right
onto our numpy array the image
we're going to let numpy handle all that
different
aspects as far as 150 by 150 by three
we just dump it right into the numpy
which makes it really easy we don't have
to do anything funky on the processing
and we want to leave it like that and
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
and then of course we have to have the
string append the label on there and i
want you to notice right here
we're going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones
this is something that's so important is
when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data
so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory uh print
length of x so here we go let's go and
run that
and we're just loading up the flower
daisy so this is going all in there and
it's setting
it's adding it in to the our setup on
there to our x and z setup
and we see we have 769
and then of course you can see this nice
bar here this is the bar going across is
that little added uh code in there that
just makes it really cool for doing
demos uh not necessarily when you're
building your own model or something
like that but if you're going to display
this to other people
adding that little what was it called
tqdm i can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just
created an array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and i want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them uh and
so when we get all the way down to
the
where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
going in here there's a couple things
you can do and we're just going to um oh
it wasn't there it is there's our error
i knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now i can do a couple things one i could
go back into our definition
and i can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion this is where
the error is coming from
uh just skip it that's one way to do it
when you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end you just say okay i lost
three points who cares
or you can go in there and try to delete
it
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right alone and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about jupiter notebook
is that i can just continue on there and
the x and z which we're creating
is still
running and we'll just go right into the
next flower rose so all these flowers
are in there
that's just a cool thing about jupiter
notebook
and then we can go ahead and just take a
quick look
and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with
the other people and showing them stuff
this is just kind of fun where we can
display it on the plot library here
and we're just going to go through
let's see what we got here
uh looks like
we're gonna do like five of each of them
i think
is that how they set this up um
plot library five by two okay oh i see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data
no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150
you can see how it really blurs this one
up here on the tulip
that is that resize to 150 by 150
and these are what's actually going in
these are all 150 by 150 images you can
check the dimensions on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like i said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different uh information so we need
to go ahead and take our labels
uh and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just gonna le is a label
encoder one of the things we imported
and then we always use the fit
um to categorical y comma five x here's
our array
um x so if you look at this here's our
fit we're gonna transform z
that's our z array we created
and then we have y which equals that and
then we go ahead and do to categorical
we want five different categories
and then we create our x
in p array of x x equals x over 255
so what's going on here there's two
different transformations one we've
turned our categories into
0 1 2 3 4 5 as the output
and we have taken our x array
and remember the x array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
um color arrays and those color arrays
range from zero to 250. so when we take
the x equals x over 255
i'm sorry range from zero to 255
this converts all those pixels to a
number between 0 and 1.
and you really want to do that when
you're working with neural networks
now if you do a linear regression model
it doesn't affect it as much so you
don't have to do that conversion if
you're doing straight numbers but when
you're running neural networks if you
don't do this you're going to create a
huge bias
and that means it'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
x and y values
x being the data in y being our known
output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training
so we have x train
we have our x test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your x train and your y test
corresponds to your x test the outputs
and this is when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random's always good this
is such a good tool i mean certainly you
can do your own division um
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever do
the length of the data not real hard to
do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what i will do
is i'll just split the data into three
parts
and then i'll test it on two with one
being the
or trained on two of those parts with
one being the test and i rotate it so i
come up with three different answers
which is a good way of finding out just
how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
x train x test and the sk learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an np random seed
from 42 and we get a nice rn number
and then we do tf random we set the seed
so you can set your randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the
tf.random.set
is so that's a lot of prep
all this prep and then we finally get to
the exciting part
um this is where you probably spend once
you have the data prepped and you have
your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate a sequential
they have the api which is across the
cross tensorflow api versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of
bringing it back together so it's not a
huge step to go from this to an api
and the first thing we're going to look
at is
our convolutional neural network in 2d
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here
the default for well let's start with
the beginning what is a convolutional 2d
network
well convolutional 2d network creates a
number of small windows and those small
windows float over the picture
and each one of them is our own neural
network and this basically
becomes like a
a categorization and then it looks at
that and it says oh if we add these
numbers up a certain way
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is five by five so
we're looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a five by five it's a two d
so it has your x y coordinates
um and we look at this five by five
remember each one of these is is
actually looking at five by five by
three
uh so we're actually looking at fifteen
by fifteen different um pixels
and padding is just um
usually just ignore that
activation by default is relu we went
ahead and put the relu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller
when you remember i mentioned atom when
you have a lot of datum data use an atom
kind of activation or using atom
processing
we're using the relu here
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a zero and then it kind of shoots
off at an angle
very common it's the most common one and
then of course here's our input shape
150 by 150 by three pixels
and then we have to pool it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2d
layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into a neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat this
so we're going to add another network
here
one of the cool things if you look at
this is that it as it comes in it just
kind of automatically assumes you're
going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null network 2d
here's our max pooling again we're going
to do that again max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
changed the number of filters and so
each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flattened so we added we just
flatten it remember this is 150 by 150
by three
well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flattened just puts
that into a 1d array
so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the the pixels and
everything it's just flat
and then the dense
is just another activation on there
by default it is probably relu
as far as its activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents
and there's a lot of different
activations but rayleigh is the most
common one and then we also see a soft
max
soft max
is similar
but it has its own kind of variation
and one of the cool things you know what
let me bring this up because if we if
you don't know about these activations
this doesn't make sense
and i just did a quick google search on
images of tensorflow activations
um i should probably look at which
website this is
but this is the output of the values uh
so as your x as it adds in all those uh
weighted x values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
that's a sigmoid activation and you can
see it goes between zero and one and has
a nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives
and if we come down the seven popular
activation functions nonlinear
activations there's a lot of different
options on this let me see if i can find
the
let's make sure we can find the specific
to relu
so this is a leaky rayloo
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between uh going
up it has a little leaky there otherwise
your rayleigh loses some nodes they just
become inactive
but you can see there's a lot of
different options here here's a good one
right here with the rayleigh you can see
the rayleigh function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the leaky
railway over here on the right which is
very commonly used also
one of the things i use with processing
language is the sig as the exponential
one or the tangent h the hyperbolic
tangent because they have that nice
funky curve that comes in that has a
whole different meaning and captures
word use better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time
playing with different models
for our basic model we'll stick to the
relu and the softmax on here and we'll
go ahead and run and build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there
we need to go ahead and have a batch
size on here
128
epix10
this means that we're going to send 128
rows of data or flowers at a time to be
processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to loop through all the data
reduce
the values and
verbose verbose equals 1 means that
we're going to show what's going on
value monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to 0
you don't have to watch it train the
model
although
it is kind of nice to actually know
what's going on sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator
this is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing
most the time you can actually just
ignore most of this vertical flip so you
can randomly flip pictures you can
randomly horizontally flick them
you can shift the picture around this
kind of helps gives you multiple data
off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that
setup because we already have a huge
amount of data
if you're short data you can start
flipping like a horizontal picture and
it will generate it's like doubling your
data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias that is the downside of
that
and so we have our model comp model
compile and this you're going to see in
all the cross we're going to take this
model here we're going to take all this
information as far as how we want it to
go and we're going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and i want you
to notice uh
learning
rate very important this is the default
zero zero one
there's there you really don't this is
how
slowly it adjusts to find the right
answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number
with larger with you have a very small
sample of data you might go even larger
than that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is how how much it improves the
model is improving is what this number
means or yeah that's that's important on
there and then the accuracy we want to
know just how good our model is on the
accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
is you can run the model summary
i do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as
while it fits
the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that
it doesn't really matter it does the
same thing and we'll go ahead and just
run that
and you can see while it's running right
here we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
six to 25.
here's our loss we're printing that out
so you can see how it's improving and
our accuracy the accuracy gets better
and better and this is six out of 25.
this is going to take a couple minutes
to process
because we are training 150 by 150 by 3
pixels across
six layers or eight layers whatever it
was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because i did
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are and if you set the
verbose to
zero instead of one it won't show what's
going on in the behind the scenes as
it's training it
so we look at this epic 10 epic so we
went through all the data 10 times
if i remember correctly there's roughly
a gig of data there so that's a lot of
data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the 270 seconds
that's how much each of those epics took
to run
and so if you divide 60 in there you
roughly get about five minutes worth of
each epic so if i have 10 epics that's
50 minutes almost an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer
i actually have what is it uh
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in
and it still takes it five minutes for
each one of these epics so you start to
see that if you have a lot of data this
is going to be a problem if you have a
number of models you want to find out
how good the models are doing what model
to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact i have a model
i'm running now that takes over
takes about a day and a half to test
each model
it takes four days to do with the whole
data
so what i do is i actually take a small
piece of the data
test it out to find out
get an idea of how the different setups
are going to do
and then i increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and i
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then i need to add in more dense layers
or whatever
so you can do a small chunks of data
then figure out what it costs to do a
large set of data and what kind of model
you want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a
user-friendly number other than
the more it trends down the better and
so if you continue to see the loss going
down eventually get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit
the accuracy just turns us into
something that
we can use
and so the accuracy is what percentage
of guesses in this case is categorical
so this is a percentage of guesses are
correct
um value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy um just rounds
it off basically and so a lot of times
you come down here and you go okay we're
doing 0.5.6
0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in this
case 68.4
accuracy that's a very usable number and
it's very important to have
if you're identifying flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance and knowing what
flower you're identifying
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not you might want to rethink
it a little bit or re-key how you're
building your model
so
if i'm working with a
a group of clients
shareholders in a company or something
like that
you don't really want to show them this
you don't want to show them hey you know
this is what's going on with the
accuracy these are just numbers and so
we want to go and put the finishing
touches just like when you are building
a house and you put in the frame and the
trim on the house it's nice to have
something a nice view of what's going on
and so we'll go ahead and do a pie plot
and we'll just plot the history of the
loss
the history of the
value loss
over here
epics train and test and so we're just
going to compute these
this is really important and what i want
you to notice right here is when we get
to about oh
five epics a little more than five six
epics you see a cross over here
and it starts crossing as far as the
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming over fitted
and so when you put these two together
uh right around five and six you start
to see how it does this this switch over
here and that's really where you need to
stop right around five yeah six um
it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box
uh see but you know that right around
here if you're saving your model after
each run you want to use the one that's
right around five epics because that's
the one that's going to have the least
amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop
it also is you know i don't show people
this mess up here
i show somebody this kind of model i say
this is where the training and the
testing comes in on this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them uh within about you know
68 70
accuracy whether it's going to be a
dahlia sunflower cherry blossom rose a
lot of other things you can do with your
output as far as a
different tables to see where the errors
are coming from and what problems are
coming up
and we're going to take a look at image
classification using cross and the basic
setup and we'll actually look at two
different demos on here
what's in it for you today
what is image classification
intel image classification data
creating neural networks with keras and
the vgg16 model
what is image classification
the process of image classification
refers to assigning classes to an entire
image images can be classified based on
different categories like weather
it is a night time or daytime shot what
the image represents etc you can see
here we have mountains looking for
mountains well i should be doing some
pictures of scenery and stuff like that
in deep learning we perform image
classification by using neural networks
to extract features from images and
classifies them based on these features
and you can see here where it says like
what computer sees and says oh yeah we
see mostly forests maybe a little bit of
mountains because the way the image is
and this is really where
one of the areas that neural networks
really shines
if you try to run this stuff through
more like a linear regression model
you'll still get results but the results
kind of miss a lot of things as the
neural networks get better and better at
what they do with different tools we
have out there
so intel image classification data
the data being used is the intel image
classification data set which consists
of images of six types of land areas
and so we have forest building glaciers
and mountains sea and street
and you can see here there's a couple of
the images out of there as a setup in
the
intel image classification data that
they use
and then we're going to go into creating
a neural networks with cross
the convolutional neural network that we
are creating from scratch looks uh as
shown below
you'll see here we have our input layer
um
they haven't listed max pooling so you
have
as you're coming in with the input layer
and this the input layer is actually
before this but the first layer that
it's going to go into is going to be a
convolutional neural network
then you have a max pooling that pulls
those the the convolutional neural
networks returns
in this case they have two of those that
is very standard with convolutional
neural networks
one of the ones that i was looking at
earlier that was standard being used by
um
i want to one of the larger companies i
can't remember which one for doing a
large amount of identification had two
convolutional neural networks each with
their max pooling and then about 17
dense layers after it
we're not going to do that heavy duty of
a of a code but we'll get you head in
the right direction and that gives you
an idea of what you're actually going to
be looking at when you look at the
flattened part and then the dents we're
talking like 17 dense layers afterwards
i find that a lot of the stuff i've been
working on i end up maxing it out right
around nine dense layers it really
depends on what you have going in and
what you're working with
and the vgg16 model
vgg16 is a pre-trained cnn model which
is used for image classification it is
trained on a large varied data set and
fine-tuned to fit image classification
data sets with ease
and you can see down here we have the
input coming in
the convolutional neural network one to
one one to two and then pooling and then
we do two to one two to two
convolutional network than pooling three
to two and you can see there's just this
huge layering of convolutional neural
networks and in this case they have five
such layers going in and then three
dents going out or uh more
now when they
took this setup this actually won an
award back in 2019 for this particular
setup
and it does it does really good except
that again
we only show the three dense layers here
and as you find out
depending on your data going in what you
have set up
that really isn't enough on one of these
setups and i'm going to show you why we
restricted it because it does take up a
lot of processing power in some of these
things
so let's go ahead and roll up our
sleeves and we're going to look at both
the setups we're going to start with the
the first classification
and then we'll go into the vgg16 and
show you how that's set up
now i'm going to be using anaconda and
let me flip over to my anaconda so you
can see what that looks like
now i'm running in the anaconda here
you'll see that i've set up a main
python
3 8. i always put that in there this is
where i'm doing like most of my kind of
playing around
uh this is done in python version 3.8
we're not going to dig too much into
versions at this point you should
already have
cross installed on there usually cross
takes a number of extra steps
and then our usual
setup is the numpy the pandas
your sk your scikit which is going to be
the sk learn your seaborn and i'll show
you those in just a minute
and then i'm just going to be in the
jupiter lab where i've created a new
notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook
now there's a couple cool things to note
in here is that
um one i use the the
anaconda jupiter notebook setup because
it keeps everything separate
except for cross
cross is actually running separately in
the back i believe it's a c program
uh what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multiprocessors on the
computer and i'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the code
and when we look in here a couple things
to note is here's our
oops
i thought i'd grab the other drawing
thing
but here's our numpy and our pandas
right here and our operating system
this is our psi kit you always import it
as sklearn for the classification report
uh we're going to be using well usually
import like seaborn brings in all of
your pie plot library also
kind of nice to throw that in there i
can't remember if we're actually using
seaborne if they just the people in the
back just threw that together
and then we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our matplot
library that the seaborn is pretty much
built on
um cv2
if you're not familiar with that that is
our image
module for importing the image
and then of course we have our
tensorflow down here which is what we're
really working with
and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
if you're doing a demo and you're
working with the partners or the
shareholders
this tqdm is really kind of cool it's an
extensible progress bar for python and
i'll show you that too
remember data science is not i mean you
know muscle's code when i'm looking
through this code i'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody i'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works
so we need to go ahead and import those
different
setup on there and then the next thing
is we're going to go ahead and set up
our classes
uh now we remember if we had mountain
street glacier building c and forest
those were the different images that we
have coming in
and we're going to go ahead and just do
class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of ifri
class name
equals the class names so our labels are
going to match the names up here
and then we have the number of classes
and the print the class names and labels
and we'll go ahead and set the image
size this is important that we resize
everything because if you remember with
neural networks
they take one size data coming in and so
when you're working with images you
really want to make sure they're all
resized to the same
setup it might squish them it might
stretch them that generally does not
cause a problem in these
and some of the other tricks you can do
with if you if you need more data
and this is one that's used regularly
we're not going to do it in here is you
can also take these images and not only
resize them but you can tilt them one
way or the other crop parts of them
so they process slightly differently and
they'll actually increase your accuracy
of some of these predictions
and so you can see here we have mountain
equals zero that's what this class name
label is street equals one glacier
equals two buildings equals three c four
four s equals 5.
now we did this as an enumerator so each
one is 0 through 5.
a lot of times we do this instead as
0 1 0 1 0 1 so you have five outputs and
each one's a zero or a one coming out
so the next thing we really want to do
is we want to go ahead and load the data
up
and just put a label in there loading
data
just just so you know what we're doing
i'm going to put in the loading data
down here
make sure it's well labeled uh and we'll
create a definition for this
and this is all part of your
pre-processing
at this point you could replace this
with all kinds of different things
depending on what you're working on
and if you once you download you can go
download this data set uh send a note to
the simply learn team here in youtube
and they'll be happy to direct you in
the right direction and make sure you
get this path here um so you have to
write whatever wherever you saved it a
lot of times i'll just abbreviate the
path or put it as a sub thing and just
get rid of the directory
but again double check your paths we're
going to separate this into a segment
for training
and a segment for testing and that's
actually how it is in the folder let me
just show you what that looks like
so when i have my lengthy path here
where i keep all my programming simply
learn this particular setup we're
working on image classification
and image classification
clearly you probably wouldn't have that
lengthy of a list
and when we go in here
you'll see sequence train sequence test
they've already split this up this is
what we're going to train the data in
and again you can see buildings forest
glacier mountain sea street
and if we double click let's go under
forest
you can see all these different forest
images and there's a lot of variety here
i mean we have winter time we have
summer time
so it's kind of interesting
you know here's like a fallen tree
versus
a road going down the middle
that's really hard to train and if you
look at the buildings
a lot of these buildings you're looking
up a skyscraper we're looking down the
setup
here's some trees with one and i want to
highlight this one it has trees in it ah
let me just open that up so you can see
it a little closer
the reason i want to highlight this is i
want you to think about this
we have trees growing is this the city
or a forest
so this kind of imagery makes it really
hard for a classifier and if you start
looking at these you'll see a lot of
these images do have trees and other
things in the foreground
weird angles
really a hard thing for a computer to
sort out and figure out whether it's
going to be a forest or a city
and so in our loading of data
one we have to have the path the
directory
we're going to come in here we have our
images and our labels
so we're going to load the images in one
section the labels in another
and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders
in fact let me do this let me
there we go uh as we look at this we're
just going to loop through the three to
the six different folders that have the
different landscapes and then we're
going to go through and pull each file
out
and each label
so we set the label we set the folder
for file and list
here's our image path
join the paths this is all kind of not
general stuff
so i'm kind of skipping through it
really quick
and here's our image setup if you
remember we're talking about the images
we have our cv2 reader so it reads the
image in
it's going to go ahead and take the
image and convert it
to
from
blue green red to red green green blue
this is a cv2 thing almost all the time
it imports it and instead of importing
it as a standard that's used just about
everywhere it imports it with the bgr
versus rgb
rgb is pretty much a standard in here
you have to remember that with cv2
and then we're going to go ahead and
resize it this is the important part
right here we've said that we've decided
what the size is and we want to make
sure all the images have the same size
on them
and then we just take our images and
we're just going to pin the image pin
the label
and then the images it's going to turn
into a numpy array this just makes it
easier to process and manipulate
and then the labels is also a numpy
array and then we just return the output
append images and labels and we return
the output down here
so we've loaded these all into memory
we haven't talked too much there'd be a
different setup in there because there
is ways to feed the files directly into
your cross model
but we want to go ahead and just load
them all because really
for today's processing and what our
computers can handle that's not a big
deal
and then we go ahead and set the
train images train labels test images
test labels and that's going to be
returned in our output append and you
can see here we did
images and labels set up in there and it
just loads them in there so we'll have
these four different categories let me
just go ahead and run that
so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on there
and then if you remember from before uh
we imported just go back up there
shuffle here we go here's our sk learn
utilities import shuffle
and so we want to take these labels and
shuffle them around a little bit
um just mix them up so it's not having
the same if you run the same process
over and over uh then you might run into
some problems on there
and just real quick let's go ahead and
do uh
um a plot so we can just you know we've
looked at them as far as from outside of
our code we pulled up the files and i
showed you what that was going on we can
go and just display them here too
and i tell you when you're working with
different people
this should be highlighted right here
this thing is like when i'm working on
code and i'm looking at this data and
i'm trying to figure out what i'm doing
i skip this process
the second i get into a meeting and i'm
showing what's going on to other people
i skip everything we just did
so
and go right to here where we want to go
ahead and display
some images and take a look at it
and in this display
i've taken them and i've resized the
images to 20 by 20.
[Music]
that's pretty small
so we're going to lose just a massive
amount of detail
and you can see here these nice
pixelated images
i might even just stick with the folder
showing them what images were
processing uh
again this is
you gotta be a little careful this
maybe resizing it was a bad idea
in fact let me try it without resizing
and see what happens oops so i took out
the image size and then we put this
straight in here
one of the things again this is um
but the d there we go one of the things
again that we want to know
whenever we're working on these things
uh is the cv2
there are so many different uh image
classification setups it's really a
powerful package when you're doing
images
but you do need to switch it around so
that it works with the pie plot and so
make sure you take your numpy array and
change it to a u integer eight format uh
because it comes in as a float
otherwise you'll get some weird images
down there
um and so this is just basically we've
split up our we've created a plot
we went ahead and did the plot 20 by 20
or
the plot figure size is 20 by 20
and then we're doing 25 so a 5 by 5
subplot
nothing really going on here too
exciting but you can see here where we
get the images
and
really when you're showing people what's
going on this is what they want to see
so you skip over all the code and you
have your meeting you say okay here's
our images of the building
don't get caught up in how much work you
do get caught up in what they want to
see so if you want to work in data
science that's really important to know
and this is where we're going to start
having fun
here's our model this is where it gets
exciting
when you're digging into these models
and you have here
let me get
there we go
when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
2d
and
2d is an image you have two different
dimensions x y and even though there's
three colors it's still considered 2d
if you're running a video you'd be
convolutional neural network 3d
if you're doing a series going across
a time series it might be 1d
and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional neural network
if you look here there's a lot of really
cool settings going on
to dig into
we have our input shape so everything's
been set to 150 by 150
and it has of course three different
color schemes in it that's important to
notice activation
default is relu this is
small amounts of data are being
processed on a bunch of little
neural networks
and right here is the 32 that's how many
of these convolutional null networks are
being strung up on here
and then the three by three
uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at a little three by
three square on each image
and so that's what's going on here and
with convolutional neural networks the
window floats across
and adds up all these numbers going
across on this data and then eventually
it comes up with 30 in this case 32
different
feature options that it's looking for
and of course you can change that 32 you
can change the 3x3 so you might have a
larger setup
you know if you're going across 150
by 150 that's a lot of steps so we might
run this as 15 by 15.
there's all kinds of different things
you can do here
we're just putting this together again
that would be something you would play
with to find out which ones are going to
work better on this setup
and there's a lot of play involved
that's really where it becomes an art
form is guessing at what that's going to
be
the second part i mentioned earlier and
i can only begin to highlight this
when you get to these dense layers
one is the activation is a relu they use
a relu and a softmax here
it's a whole a whole setup just
explaining why these are different
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact
there's just a ton of these and you can
build your own custom activations
depending on what you're doing
a lot of different things go into these
activations
uh there are two or three major thoughts
on these activations and
relu and softmax are
well relu
you're really looking at just the number
you're adding all the numbers together
and you're looking at euclidean geometry
ax plus b
x 2 plus c x 3
plus a bias
with soft max this belongs to the party
of um
it's activated or it's not except it's
they call it soft max because when you
get the the to zero instead of it just
being zero
uh it's actually slightly
a little bit less than zero so that when
it trains it doesn't get lost
um there's a whole series of these
activations
another activation is the tangent
um
where it just drops off and you have
like a very narrow area where you have
from minus one to one or exponential
which is zero to one
so there's a lot of different ways to do
the activation
again we can do that would be a whole
separate lesson on here
we're looking at the convolutional
neural network
and we're doing the two pools
this is so common you'll see two two
convolutional neural networks stacked on
top of each other each with its own max
pool underneath let's go ahead and run
that so we built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
compile the model so let's go ahead and
do that
we're going to use the atom
optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on there just some other
optimizer but i think atom's a default
um i don't really play with the
optimizer too much that's like the
if once you get a model that works
really good you might try some different
optimizers atoms usually the most and
then we're looking at loss
pretty standard we want to minimize our
law we want to
maximize the loss of error
and then we're going to look at accuracy
everybody likes the accuracy i'm going
to tell you right now
i
i start talking to people and i'm like
okay what's what's the loss on this and
that and as a data science yeah i want
to know how the lot what's going on with
that we'll show you why in a minute
but everybody wants to see accuracy we
want to know how accurate this is
uh and then we're going to run the fit
and i wanted to do this just so i can
show you
even though
we're in a python
setup in here where jupiter notebook is
using only a single processor
i'm going to bring over my little cpu
tool uh this is eight cores on 16
dedicated threats so it shows up as 16
processors
and actually i got to run this and then
move it over
so we're going to run this
and hopefully it doesn't destroy my mic
uh and as it comes in you can see it's
starting to go through the epics and we
said i set it for five epics
and then this is really nice because
cross uses all the different uh threads
available
so it does a really good job of doing
that
uh this is going to take a while if you
look at here it's uh
eta
two minutes and 25 seconds 24 seconds so
this is roughly two and a half minutes
per epic
and we're doing five epics
so this is going to be done in roughly
15 minutes
i don't know about you but i don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching the green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run
and
there we go
there was our 15 minutes it's actually
less than that
because i did when i went in here
realized that uh
where was it
here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flip
fit
and here's our epics so i did four epics
so a little bit better a little more
like 10 to 11 minutes instead of uh
doing the full
uh 15. and
when we look at this here's our model we
did we talked about the compiler uh
here's our history we're going to click
history equals the model fit
we'll go into that in just a minute
and we're looking at is we have our
epics
here's our validation split
so as we train it
we're weighing the accuracy versus
you kind of pull some data off to the
side
uh while you're training it
and the reason we do that is that
you don't want to overfit
and we'll look at that chart in just a
minute
here's batch size
this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time
the larger the batch it actually
increases the processing speed
and there's reasons to go up or down on
the batch size because of the uh the the
smaller of the batch
there's a certain point where
you get too large of a batch and it's
trying to fit everything at once uh
so i yeah 128 is kind of big
depends on the computer you're on what
it can handle
and then of course we have our train
images and our train labels going in
telling it what we're going to train
on then we look at our four epochs here
uh here's our accuracy we want the
accuracy to go up and we get all the way
up to 0.83
or 83 percent now this is actual
percentage based pretty much and we can
see over here our loss we want our loss
to go down really fluctuates 55 1.2 0.77
0.48
so we have a lot of things going on
there
let's go ahead and graph those
turn that up
and our team in the back did a wonderful
job of putting together
this basic plot set up
here's our subplot coming in we're going
to be looking at
from the history we're going to send it
the accuracy and the value accuracy
labels and set up on there
and we're going to also look at loss and
value loss
so you can see what this looks like
what's really interesting about
this setup and let me let me just go
ahead and show you because
without actually seeing the plots it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
it's just basic plotting of uh of the
data using the pi plot library
and i want you to look at this this is
really interesting
when i ran this the first time i had
very different results
um and they vary greatly and you can see
here our accuracy continues to climb
um
and there's a crossover here
put it in here
right here's our crossover
and i point that out because as we get
to the right of that crossover where our
accuracy
we're like oh yeah i got point eight
percent
we're starting to get an overfit here
that's what this this switch over means
as our value
as a training set versus the value
accuracy stays the same and so that this
is the one we actually really want to be
aware of and where it crosses
is kind of where you want to stop at um
and we can see that also with the train
loss versus the value loss right here we
did one epic and look how it just
flatlines right there with our loss
so really
one epic
is
probably enough
and you're gonna say wow okay point
eight percent um certainly if i was
working with the shareholders um
telling them that it has an eighty
percent accuracy isn't quite true and
and we'll look at that a little deeper
it really comes out here that the
accuracy of our actual values is closer
to 0.41
right here
even after running it this number of
times
and so you really want to stop right
here at that crossover
one epic would have been enough
so the date is a little over fitted on
this when we do four epics
and uh whoops there we are
okay
my drawing won't go away um let's see if
i can get there we go
for some reason i've killed my drawing
ability and my recorder
all right took a couple extra clicks
uh so let's go ahead and take a look at
our actual test loss
so you see where it crosses over that's
where i'm looking at
that's where we start overfitting the
model
and this is where
if we were going to go back and
continually upgrade the model
we would start taking a look at the
images and start rotating them
we might start playing with the
convolutional neural network instead of
doing the three by three window
um we might expand that or you know find
different things that might make a big
difference as far as the way it
processes these things
um so let's go ahead and take a look at
our our test loss now remember we had
our training data
now we're going to look at our test
images and our test labels
for our test loss here and this is just
model evaluate
just like we did fit up here
where was it
one more
model fit with our training data going
in now we're going to evaluate it on the
and and this data has not been touched
yet so
this model has never seen this data this
is on
completely new information as far as the
model is concerned of course we
already know what it is from the labels
we have
and this is what i was talking about
here's the actual accuracy right here
0.48
or four eight four seven
so this forty nine percent of the time
guesses what the image is
uh and
i mean really that's the bottom dollar
uh does this work for what you're
needing does 49 work do we need to
upgrade the model more
in some cases this might be
oh what was i doing i was working on
stock evaluations
and
we were looking at what stocks were the
top performers
well if i get that 50 correct on top
performers
uh i'm good with that um that's actually
pretty good for stock evaluation
fact the number i had for stock was more
like
30 something percent as far as being a
top performer stock
much harder to predict
but at that point you're like well
you'll make money off of that so again
this number right here
depends a lot on the domain you're
working on
and then we want to go ahead and bring
this home a little bit more
as far as looking at the different setup
in here and one of the
from sk learn if you remember actually
let's go back to the top
uh we had the classification report and
this came in from our sklearn or scikit
setup
and that's right here you can see it
right here on the um
see there we go
classification report right here uh
sklearn metrics import classification
report this we're going to look at next
a lot of this stuff uh depends on who
you're working with
so when we start looking at um precision
you know this is like for each value i
can't remember what one one one was
probably mountains so if 44
is not good enough if you're doing like
um you're in the medical department and
you're doing cancer is it is this
cancerous or not i'm only 44 accurate
not a good deal
you know i would not go with that um
so it depends on what you're working
with on the different labels and what
they're used for facebook
you know 44 i'm guessing the right
person
i hope it does a little bit better than
that um but here's our main accuracy
this is what almost everybody looks at
they say oh 48 that's what's important
again it depends on what domain you're
in and what you're working with
and now we're going to do the same model
oops somehow i got my there it goes i
thought i was going to get stuck in
there again uh
well this time we're going to be using
the
vgg16 and remember this one
uh all those layers
going into it so it's basically a bunch
of convolutional neural networks getting
smaller and smaller on here
uh and so we need to go ahead and
import all our different stuff from
cross we're importing the main one is
the v
g 16 set up on there let me just aim
that there we go
there's kind of a pre-processing images
applications pre-process input this is
all part of the vg g16 set up on there
and once we have all those we need to go
ahead
and create our model
and we're just going to create a vgg16
model in here
inputs model inputs outputs model inputs
i'm not going to spend as much time as
they did on the other one
we're going to go through it really
quickly
one of the first things i would do is if
you remember in cross you can treat
treat a model like you would a layer
and so at this point i would probably
add a lot of dense layers on after the
vgg16 model and create a new model with
all those things in there and we'll go
ahead and run this
because here's our model coming in and
our setup
and it'll take it just a moment to
compile that
what's funny about this is i'm waiting
for it to download the package since i
pre-ran this
it takes it a couple minutes to download
the vgg16 model into here
and so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict that we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here
and then i told you it's going to create
another model too and the people in the
back did not disappoint me they went
ahead and did just that
and this is really an important part um
this is worth stopping for i told you i
was going to go through this really
quick
so here's our uh
we we have our model 2
um coming in and we've created a model
up here with the vgg16 model equals
model inputs model inputs and so we have
our vgg16 this has already been
pre-programmed
uh and then we come down here i want you
to notice on this
right here
layer model 2 layers minus 4 to 1 x
layer x
we're basically taking this model and
we're adding stuff onto it and so
we've taken we've just basically
duplicated this model we could have done
the same thing
by using
model up here as a layer
we could have the input go to this model
and then have that go down here so we've
added on
this whole setup
this whole block of code from 13 to 17
has been added on to our vgg16 model
and we have a new model uh with the
layer m input and x down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it and that was a lot to go through
right there when you're building these
models this is the part that gets so
complicated
did you get stuck playing in and yet
it's so fun uh it's like a puzzle how
can i loop these models together
and in this case you can see right here
that the layers
we're just copying layers over and
adding each layer in
this is one way to build a new model
and we'll go ahead and run that
like i said the other way is you can
actually use the model as a layer i've
had a little trouble playing with it
sometimes when you're using the straight
model over
you run into issues
it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come up
let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it again here's
our metrics accuracy sparse categorical
loss
pretty straightforward just like we did
before we got to compile the model
and just like before we're going to take
our create a history
the history is going to be
a new model fit train 128
and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff
we're going to have to go ahead and it's
going to light up our setup on here and
this is going to take a little bit to
get us all set up it's not going to just
happen in a couple minutes so let me go
ahead and pause the video and run it and
then we'll talk about what happened
okay now when i ran that these actually
took about six minutes each um
so it's a good thing i put it on whole
we did four epics i actually had to stop
it says at 10 and switch it to forks i
didn't want to wait an hour
and you can see here our accuracy
and our loss numbers going down
and just at a glance
it actually performed if you look at the
accuracy
0.2658
so our accuracy is going down or you
know 26 percent um 34 35
and you can see here at some point it
just kind of kicks the bucket again this
is overfitting
that's always an issue when you're
running on
programming these different neural
networks
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot the accuracy
history we built that nice little
subroutine up above so we might as well
use it
and you can see it right here
there's that crossover again
and
if you look at this look how the how the
the red shifts up how the
our loss functions and everything
crosses over we're overfitting after one
epic um we're clearly
not helping the problem or doing better
um we're just gonna it's just gonna
baseline this one actually shows with
the training versus the loss
value loss maybe second epic so on here
we're now talking more between the first
and the second epic and that also shows
kind of here so
somewhere in here it starts overfitting
and right about now you should be saying
oh
something went wrong there i thought
that
when we went up here and ran this
look at this we have the accuracy up
here it's hitting that 48
and we're down here um
you look at the score down here that
looks closer to
20 percent not nearly
anywhere in the ballpark of what we're
looking for
and we'll go ahead and run it through
the uh the actual test features here and
there it is um we actually run this on
the unseen data and everything
point uh one eight or eighteen percent
um i don't know about you but i wouldn't
want you know at 18 this did a lot worse
than the other one
i thought this was supposed to be the
super model the
model that beats all models the vgg-16
that won the awards and everything
well the reason is is that
one we're not
pre-processing the data so it needs to
be more there needs to be more
as far as like rotating the data at you
know 45 degree angle taking partials of
it
so you can create a lot more data to go
through here um and that would actually
greatly change the outcome on here and
then we went up here we only added a
couple dense layers
we added a couple convolutional neural
networks
this huge pre-trained setup is looking
for a lot more information coming in
as far as how it's going to train
and so
this is one of those things where i
thought it would have done better and i
had to go back and research it and look
at it and say why didn't this work why
am i getting only uh 18 here instead of
44 or better
and that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in
and again you can make your own training
data so it's not that we have a shortage
of data it's that that some of that has
to be switched around and moved around a
little bit
and this is interesting right here too
if you look at the precision
we're getting it on number two and yet
we had zero on everything else
so for some reason it's not seeing
uh the different variables in here so
it'd be something else to look in and
try to track down
and that probably has to do with the
input but you can see right here we have
a really good solid 0.48 up here and
that's where i'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in
where's the setup on there
and that is the art of data science
right there is finding out which models
work better and why deep learning
interview questions and we're going to
go from the very basics of neural
networks and deep learning into some of
the more commonly used models so you can
have understanding of what kind of
questions are going to come up and what
you need to know in interview questions
we'll start with a very general concept
of what is deep learning this is where
we take large volumes of data in this
case on cats and dogs or whatever a lot
of times you use
a training setup to train your model
remember it's kind of like a magic black
box going on there then we use that to
extract features or extract information
and in this case classify the image of a
cat and a dog so the primary takeaway
we're talking about deep learning is it
learns from large volumes of structured
and even unstructured data and uses
complex algorithms to train neural
network it also performs complex
operations to extract hidden patterns
and features and if we're going to
discuss deep learning in this very
simplified overview and we also have to
go over what is a neural network this is
a common image you'll see of a drawing
of a forward propagation neural network
and it's it's a human brain inspired
system which replicates the way humans
learn so this is inspired how our own
neurons in our brain fire but at a much
simplified level obviously it's not
ready to take over the human uh
population and be our leader yet not for
many years it's very much in its infant
stage but it's inspired by how our
brains work and they use a lot of other
inspirations you can study brains of
moths and other animals that they've
used to figure out how to improve these
neural networks the most common one
consists of three layers of network and
this is generally how you view these
networks is you have an input you have a
hidden layer and an output and the
neural network is broken up into many
pieces but we focus just on the neural
network it's always on the hidden layers
that we're making all the adjustments
and figuring out how to best set up
those hidden layers for their functions
to both train faster and to function
better when we look at this of course we
have our input hidden and output each
layer contains neurons called as nodes
perform various operations and you can
see here we have the list of the nodes
we have both our input nodes and our
output nodes and then our hidden layer
nodes
with what is a multi-layer perceptron or
mlp a lot of times they're referred to
and you'll see these abbreviations i'll
be honest i have to write them down on a
piece of paper and go through them
because i never remember what they all
mean even though i play with them all
the time what is a multi-layer
precipitant well if you look at the
image on the right it's very similar to
what we just looked at you have your
input layer your hidden layer and your
output layer and that's exactly what
this is it has the same structure of a
single layer perceptron with one or more
hidden layers except the input layer
each node in the other layers uses a
non-linear activation function what that
means is your input layer is your data
coming in and then your activation
function is based upon all those nodes
and weights being added together and
then it has the output mlp uses
supervised learning method called back
propagation for training the model very
key word there is back propagation
single layer perceptron can classify
only linear separable classes with
binary output 0 1 but the mlp can
classify non-linear classes so let's
break this down just a little bit the
multi-layer perceptron with an input
layer and a hidden layer and an output
layer as you see that it comes in there
it has adds up all the numbers and
weights depending on how your setup is
that then goes to the next layer that
then goes to the next hidden layer if
you have multiple hidden layers and
finally to the output layer the back
propagation takes the error that it sees
so whatever the output is it says hey
this has an error to it it's wrong and
then sends that error backwards from
where it came from and there's a lot of
different functions used to uh train
this based on that error and how that
error goes backwards in the notes so
forward is you get your answers backward
is for training you see this every day
even my uh google pixel phone has this
it they train the neural network which
takes a lot more data to train than it
does to use and then they load up that
neural network into in this case i have
a pixel 2 which actually has a built-in
neural network for processing pictures
and so it's just the forward propagation
i use when it processes my photos but
when they were training it use the back
propagation to train it with the errors
they had we'll be coming back to
different models that are used for right
now though multi-layer perceptron mlp
but then down is your vocabulary word
and of course back propagation
what is data normalization and why do we
need it this is so important we spend so
much time in normalizing our data and
getting our data clean and setting it up
so we talk about data there's a
pre-processing step to standardize the
data so whatever we have coming in we
don't want it to be a you know one
gigabyte file here a two gigabyte
picture here and a three kilobyte text
there even as a human i can't process
those all in the same group i have to
reformat them in some way that loops
them together so the standardized format
we use this uh data normalization in
pre-processing to reduce it and
eliminate data redundancy a lot of times
the data comes in and you end up with
two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly
because one pixel is really bright it
doesn't know what to do but when we
start rescaling it we put all the values
between say minus one and one and we
change them and refit them to those
values it helps get rid of that bias
helps fix for some of those problems and
then finally we restructure the data and
improve the integrity we want to make
sure that we're not missing values or we
don't have partial data coming in one
way to look at this is uh bad data in
bad data out
so you want clean data in and you want
good answers coming out one of the most
basic models used is a boltzmann machine
so let's address what is a boltzmann
machine and if you know we just did the
mlp multi-layer perceptron so now we're
going to come into almost a simplified
version of that and in this we have our
visible input layer and we have our
hidden layer the boltzmann machines are
almost always shallow they're usually
just two layer neural nets that make
stochastic decisions whether a neuron
should be on or off true false yes no
first layer is a visible layer and
second layer is the hidden layer nodes
are connected to each other across
layers but no two nodes of the same
layer are connected hence it is also
known as restricted boltzmann machine
now that we've covered a basic mlp or
multi-layer perceptron and we've gone
over the boltzmann machine also known as
the restricted boltzmann machine let's
talk a little bit about activation
formulas and this is a huge topic that
can get really complicated but it also
is automated so it's very simple so you
have both a complicated and a simple at
the same time so what is the role of
activation functions in a neural network
activation function decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not that's the
most basic one and that actually changes
a little bit because it's either whether
fired or not in this case activation
function or what value should come out
when it's fired but in these models
we're looking at just the boltzmann
restricted layers so this is what causes
them to fire either they don't or they
do it's a yes or no true false all or
nothing it accepts a weighted sum of the
inputs the bias as input to any
activation function so whatever
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on that
model and let's just go back to that
model real quick and then you always
have to add a bias and you can look at
the bias if you remember from your
euclidean geometry you draw a straight
line formula for that line has a
y-coordinate at the end it's always
cx plus m or something like that where m
is where it crosses the
coordinates if you're doing a straight
line with these weights it's very
similar but a lot of times we just add
it in as its own weight we take it as a
node of a one value coming in and then
we compute its new weight and that's how
we compute that bias just like we
compute all the other weights coming in
the node which gets fires depends on the
y value and then we have a step function
and the step function this is where
remember i said is going to get
complicated and simple all at the same
time we have a lot of different step
functions we have the sigmoid function
we have just the standard step function
we have the relu it's pronounced like re
the
from the sun and liu like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent h
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be
one value or the other they force it to
be in the case of the first three is
zero or one and in the last one it's
either a minus one or a one and you can
easily convert that to a zero one yes no
true false and on this one of the most
common ones is the step function itself
because there is no middle value there
is no
uh discrepancy that says well i'm not
quite sure but as you get into different
models probably the most commonly used
used to be the sigmoid was most commonly
used but i see the relu used more often
really depending on what you're doing
you just have to play with these and
find out which one works best
depending on the data and your output
the reason to have a non-zero one answer
or something kind of in the middle is
when you're looking at this and it's
coming out you can actually process that
middle ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the rayleigh function says hey this
is only a 0.6 not a 1. and even though
the 1 is what's going into the next
neural network or the next hidden layer
as an input the 0.6 value might also be
going in there to let you know hey this
is not a straight up one or straight up
zero it's someplace in the middle this
is a little uncertain what's coming out
here so it's a very powerful tool open
the basic neural network you usually
just use the step function it's yes or
no let's take a
big step back and take a kind of an
overview the next function is what is a
cost function that we're going to cover
this is so important because this is
your end result that you're going to do
over and over again and use to decide
whether the model is working or not
whether you need to try a different step
function whether you need to try a
different activation whether you need to
try a fully different model used
so what is the cost function cost
function is a measure to evaluate how
good your model's performance is it is
also referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function c equals half of y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is um you know real
quick if you haven't done statistics
this is not a percentage it's not a
percentage of how accurate it is it's
just a measurement of the error and we
take that error for training it and we
push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it um this
is a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for training and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we've got to look at
both the local and the global setup it
might work great to test your data on
what you have on your computer but
that's different than in the field so
when we're talking about all these
different tests in the error test as far
as your loss you don't you want to make
sure that you're in a closed environment
when you do initial testing but you also
want to open that up and make sure you
follow up with the testing on the larger
scale of data because it will change it
might not fit the larger scale there
might be something in there in the way
you brought the data in specifically or
the data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's overfitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to
figure out the error on it based on the
square means usually although there's
other functions used so we want to talk
about what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or global
minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the cop based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data i just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line of
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
cost of each piece of data coming in and
figure out the global one how we're
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we wanted to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in but this of course uh we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our predicted
y coming out and then we have since it's
a training set we already know the
answer and the answer comes back and
based on case of square means was one of
the functions we looked at one of the
activation functions based on cost
function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them we'll change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the way it's going to the next
hidden layer and then it computes an
error level on that and sends that back
up and you're going to say well if it
computes the air into the first hidden
layer and fixes it why would it stop
there well remember we don't want to
create a biased neural network so we
only make small adjustments on these
weights we don't make a big adjustment
that changes everything right off the
bat so no matter how far back you go
you're always going to have a small
amount of error and that's still going
to continue to go all the way back up
the hidden layers for right now focus on
the back propagation is taking that
error moving it backwards on the neural
network to change the weights and help
program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right but let's just take a
little detour let's see what is the
difference between a feed forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the cnn a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
google is probably most known for their
cnn where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
goes into a regular feed forward neural
network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the cnn today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
cnn is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in one
direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our
input and for some reason they always do
the recurrent neural network
in reverse from bottom up in the images
kind of a standard although i'm not sure
why your x goes into your hidden layer
and your hidden layer the answer for
part of the answer from that it
generates feeds back into the hidden
layer so now you have an input of both x
and part of the hidden layer and then
that feeds into your output now if we go
back to the forward let me just go back
a slide and we're looking at our forward
propagation network one of the tricks
you can do to use just a forward
propagation network is if you're in a
what they call a time sequence that's a
good term to remember are a time series
meaning that a sequential data each term
comes after the other you can trick this
by creating your input nodes as with the
history so if you know that you have
values one five and seven going in and
you know what the output is from one
what those outputs are you can expand
the input to include the history input
that's one of the ways to trick a
forward propagation network into looking
at that but when you deal with the
recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the rnn can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that i could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what i'm doing so would no
longer be positive so when you're
looking at a sentence knowing the order
of the words is as important as the
meaning of the words you can't just
count how many good words there are
versus bad words to get some positive
sentiment you now have to know what
they're addressing and there's lots of
other different uses uh kids are playing
football or soccer as we call it in the
us rn can help you caption an image so
based on previous information coming in
it refeeds that back in and you have a
image setter and then time series
problems like predicting the prices of
stocks in a month or quarter or sell a
product can be solved using an rnn and
this is a really good example you have
whatever your stocks were doing earlier
this month will have a huge effect on
what they're doing today if you're
investing so having an rnn model a
recurrent neural network feeding into
itself what's happening previously
allows it to take that model and program
in the whole series without having to
put in the whole a month at a time of
data you only put in one day at a time
but if you keep them in order it will
look back and say oh this because what
happened yesterday i need some
information from that and i'm going to
use that to help predict today's and so
on and so on we're going to go back to
our activation functions remember i told
you rayleigh was one of the most common
functions used uh so let's talk a little
bit more about relu and also softmax
softmax is an activation function that
generates the output between zero and
one it divides each output such that the
total sum of the outputs is equal to one
it is often used in the output layers
soft max l of the n equals e to l on the
n over the absolute value of e to the l
so what does this function mean i mean
what is actually going on here so we
have our output nodes and our output
nodes are giving us let's say they gave
us 1.2 0.9 and 0.4 as a human being i
look at that and i say well the greatest
value is 1.2 so whatever category that
is if you have three different
categories maybe you're not just doing
if it's a cat or it's a dog or oh let's
say it's a cow and we had cats and dogs
earlier why the cats and dogs are
hanging out with a cow i don't know but
we have a value and it might say 1.2 is
a cat 0.9 is the dog and 0.4 is a cow
for some reason it thinks that there's a
chance of it being any one of these
three items and that's how it comes out
of the output layer well as a human i
can look at 1.2 and say this is
definitely what it is it's definitely a
cat or whatever it is maybe it's looking
at different kinds of cars might be a
bitter whether it's a car truck or a
motorcycle maybe that'd be a better
example well from a computer standpoint
that might be a little confusing because
they're just numbers waving at us and so
with the soft max we want all those
numbers to always add up to one so when
i add three numbers together i want the
final output to be one on there and so
it goes through this formula changes
each of these numbers in this case it
changes them to 0.46 0.34 and 0.20 they
all add up to 1. and that's a lot easier
to register because it's very set it's a
set output it's never going to be more
than one it's never going to be less
than 0. and so you can see here that
there's probably a pretty high chance
that it's the first one so you're a
human being we have no problem knowing
that but this output can then also go
into say another input so it might be
an automated car that's picking up
images and it says that image in front
of us is probably a big truck we should
deal with it like it's a big truck it's
probably not a motorcycle um or whatever
those categories are that's the soft max
part of it but now we have the relu well
what where is the relu coming from well
the relu is what's generating the 1.2
and the 0.9 and the 0.4 and so if you
remember our relu stands for rectified
linear unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent h the step function
remember i said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a
zero or one but the ray loop if you have
that as your output you now have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of x if x is positive and 0 otherwise so
it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between 0 or 1 and then the
usually unless it's really uncertain the
output's usually a 1 or 0s and then you
have that little piece of uncertainty
there that you can send forward to
another network or you can look at to
know that there's uncertainty involved
and is often used in the hidden layers
this is what's coming out of the hidden
layers into the output layer usually or
as we reference the convolutional neural
network the cnn you'd have to go to
another video to review the relu is the
most common used
for
convolutional part of that network it
has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the rayleigh works really
good for that like i said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between 0 1 so it's very
standardized so we have our soft max we
looked at that let's go back one we
looked at that here where it transforms
the numbers and then we have our relu
function which takes the information and
the summation and puts it between a zero
and a one where it's either clearly a
zero or depending on how confident our
model is it'll go between the zero and
one value what are hyper parameters well
this is a great interview question hyper
parameters when you are doing neural
networks this is what you're playing
with most the time once you've gotten
the data formatted correctly a
hyperparameter is a parameter whose
value is set before the learning process
begins determines how a network is
trained and the structure of the network
this includes things like the number of
hidden units how many hidden layers are
you going to have and how many nodes in
each layer learning rate learning rate
is usually multiplied once you've
figured out the error and how much you
want to change the weights we talked
about or i mentioned it early just
briefly you don't want to just make a
huge change otherwise you're going to
have a biased model so you only take
some little incremental changes and
that's what the learning rate is is
those small incremental changes epics
how many times are you going to go
through all the data in your training
set so one epic is one trip through all
the data and there's a lot of other
things depending on which model you're
working with and which programming
script you're working with like the
python sk learn package will have a
slightly different than say google's
tensorflow package which will be a
little bit different than the spark
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
can get an unbiased model or we can have
a better prediction on it it matches our
data closer what will happen if learning
rate is set too low or too high we have
a nice couple graphs here we have one
over here so the learning rate set to
load you can see that it slowly works
its way down the curve and on the right
you can see a learning rate set too high
it's just bouncing back and forth when
your learning rate is too low that's
what we studied at two slides over
that's what the learning rate was
training of the model will progress very
slowly as we are making very tiny
updates to the weights we'll take many
updates before reaching the minimum
point so i just mentioned epic going
through all the data you might have to
go through all the data a thousand times
instead of 500 times for it to train
learning rate too high causes
undesirable divergent behavior to the
loss function due to drastic updates and
weights at times it may fail to converge
or even diverge so if you have your
learning rate set too high and it's
training too quickly maybe you'll get
lucky and it trains after one epic run
but a lot of times it might never be
able to train because the weights are
changing too fast they they flip back
and forth too easy and you see down here
we've introduced two new terms converge
and diverge a converge means that our
model has reached a point where it's
able to give a fairly good answer for
all the data we put in all those weights
have adjusted and it's minimized the
error diverged means that the data is so
chaotic that it can never manage to to
train to that data the data is just too
chaotic for it to train so we have two
new words there converge and diverge are
important to know also what is dropout
and batch normalization dropout is a
technique of dropping out hidden and
visible units of a network randomly to
prevent overfitting of data it doubles
the number of iterations needed to
converge the network so here we have our
standard neural network and then after
applying dropout now it doesn't mean we
actually delete the node the node is
still there and we're still going to use
that node what it means is that we're
only going to work with a few of the
nodes
a lot of times i think the most common
one right now used is 20 percent uh so
you'll drop out 20 of the nodes when you
do your training you reverse propagate
your data and then you'll randomly pick
another 20 nodes the next time you go
through an epic data training so each
time you go through one epic you will
randomly pick 20 of those nodes not not
to mess with and this allows for
less overfitting of the data so by
randomly doing this you create some i
guess it just kind of pulls some nodes
off to the side it says we're going to
handle the data later on so we don't
over fit batch normalization is a
technique to improve the performance and
stability of neural network the idea is
to normalize the inputs in every layer
so that they have mean output and
activation of zero and standard
deviation of one this question covers a
lot of different things which is great
it's a great uh interview question
because it pulls in that you have to
understand what the mean value is so a
mean output activation of zero that
means our average activation is zero so
when you normalize it remember usually
we're going between minus one and one on
a lot of these it's a very standard
setup so you have to be very aware that
this is your mean output activation of
zero and then we have our standard
deviation of one so we wanna keep our
error down to just a one value the
benefits of this doing a batch
normalization is it provides
regularization it trains faster higher
learning rates and weights are easier to
initialize what is the difference
between batch gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent batch gradient computes
the gradient using the entire data set
it takes time to converge because the
volume of data is huge and weights
update slowly so you can look at the
batches a lot of times if you're using
big data batch the data in but you still
go through a full epic you still go
through all the data on there so batch
gradient descent means you're going to
use it to fit all the data and look for
convergence there stochastic gradient
descent stochastic gradient computes the
gradient using a single sample it
converges much faster than batch
gradient because it updates weight more
frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when the model
learns the details and noise and the
training data to the degree that it
adversely impacts execution of the model
on the new information it is more likely
to occur with non-linear models that
have more flexibility when learning a
target function an example of this would
be if you're looking at say cars and
trucks and motorcycles it might only
recognize trucks that have a certain
box-like shape it might not be able to
notice a flatbed truck unless it's only
a specific kind of flatbed truck or only
ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and great on maybe a small test amount
of data but when you go to use it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and start
and is not very functional outside of
your small area your slow laboratory
data coming in under fitting doing the
opposite when you under fit your data
underfitting alludes to a model that is
neither well trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less and
improper data to train a model has a
verb performance and accuracy so if
you're using underfitted data and you
generate a model and you distribute that
in a commercial zone you'll have a lot
of people unhappy with you because it's
not going to give them very good answers
so we've explained overfitting and under
fitting so now we want to ask how to
combat them combating overfitting and
underfitting resampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy k-fold
cross-validation having a validation
data set to evaluate the model so we do
the resampling we're randomly going to
be picking out data and we'll run it a
few times to see how that works
depending on our random data and how we
sample the data to generate our model
and then we want to go ahead and
validate the data set by having our
training data and then keeping some data
on the side testing data to validate it
how are weights initialized in a network
initializing all weights to zero all the
weights are set to zero this makes your
model similar to a linear model so if
you have linear data coming in doing a
basic setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and w equals np
random random in layer size l layer size
l minus one this is the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
cnn convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so go into detail exactly how
the c the convolutional layer works on
the cnn as far as creating a number of
smaller picture windows to go over the
data the second step is as a rayleigh
layer relu brings non-linearity to the
network and converts all the negative
pixels to zero output is rectified
feature map so it goes into a mapping
feature there pooling layer pulling is a
down sampling operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map so we
have all our relu layer which is pulling
all these little maps out of our
convolutional layer it's taking that
picture and little creating little tiny
neural networks to look at different
parts of the picture uh then we need to
pull it together and then finally the
fully connected layer so we flatten our
pulling layer out and we have a fully
connected layer recognizes and
classifies the objects in the image and
that's actually your forward propagation
reverse propagation training model
usually i mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in cnn and how does it
work
pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a cnn performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix i mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you see here they
have a rectified feature map and so each
one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the a smaller
little neural network using the relu
you'll look at it'll just kind of go
over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a two seven eight five each one of
those is a map so it might be the first
one might be a map looking for cat ears
the second one looking for human eyes
when it does this you then have this
rectified feature map looking at these
different features and the max pooling
with the two by two filters in a stride
a two stride means instead of skipping
every pixel you're gonna go every two
pixels you take the maximum values and
you can see over here we look at a
pulled feature map one of the features
says hey i had a max value of eight so
somewhere in here we saw a human eye
labeled as eight pretty high label and
maybe seven was a human hand and maybe
four was cat whiskers or something that
we thought might be cat whiskers four is
kind of a low number in this particular
case compared to the other ones so you
have your full pool feature map you can
see the process here is we have our
stepping we look for the max value and
then we create a pool feature map of the
max values how does a lstm network work
that's long short term memory so the
first thing to know is that an lstms are
a special kind of recurrent neural
network capable of learning long-term
dependencies remembering information for
long periods of time is their default
behavior we did look at the rnn briefly
talked about how the hidden layer feeds
back into itself with the lstm as a much
more complicated feedback and you can
see here we have the hidden layer of t
minus one and hidden layer that's what
the h stands for hidden layer of t and
the formula is going in as we can see
here we have the hidden layers we have t
minus one and then h of t where t stands
for time so this is a series remember
working with series we want to remember
the past and you can see you have your x
your input of t and that might be a
frame in a
video as the frame comes in they usually
use in this one the tangent h activation
formula but you also see that it goes
through a couple other formulas the
omega formula and so when it combines
these that then goes into the next layer
your next hidden layer that then goes
into the data that's submitted to the
next input so you have your x of t plus
one so when you have that coming in then
you have your h values coming forward
from the last process and depending on
how many of these omega structures you
put in there depends on how long term
the memory gets so it's important to
remember this is more for your long-term
recurrent neural networks the three
steps in an lstm step one decides what
to forget and what to remember step 2
selectively update cell state values so
based on what we want to remember and
forget we want to update those cell
values and then decides what part of the
current state make it to the output so
now we have to also have an output on
there what are vanishing and exploding
gradients this is a great question that
affects all our neural networks while
training an rnn your slope can become
either too small or too large and this
makes the training difficult when the
slope is too small the problem is known
as vanishing gradient so our slope we
have our change in x and our change in y
when the slope decreases gradually to a
very small value sometimes negative and
makes training difficult when the slope
tends to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially you can see a nice graph
of that here issues in gradient problem
long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between epic batch and iteration and
deep learning epic an epic represents
one iteration over the entire data set
so that's everything you're going to go
ahead and put into that training model
batch we cannot pass the entire data set
into the neural network at once so we
divide the data set into a number of
batches and then iteration if we have 10
000 images as data and a batch size of
200 then the epic should run 10 000
times over 200 so that means we have our
total number over the 200 equals 50
iteration so in each epoch we're running
over all the data set we're going to
have 50 iterations and each of those
iterations includes a batch of 200
images in this case why tensorflow is
the most preferred library in deep
learning well first tensorflow provides
both c plus plus and python apis that
makes it easier to work on has a faster
compilation time than other deep
learning libraries like cross and torch
tensorflow supports both cpus and gpus
computing devices so right now
tensorflow is at the top of the market
because it's so easy to use for both
programmer side and for hardware side
and for the speed of getting something
up and running what do you mean by
tensor in tensorflow tensor is a
mathematical object represented as a
rays of higher dimension these arrays of
data with different dimensions and ranks
that are fed as input to the neural
network are called tensors and you can
see here we have a tensor of dimensions
five comma four so it's a two
dimensional tensor coming in you can
look at an image like this that each one
of those pixels is a different value if
it's a black and white so it might be
zero and ones and then each one
represents a black and white image in a
color photo you might
either find a different value system or
you might have a tensor value that has
the xy coordinates as we see here plus
the colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tenser to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensorflow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf.constant command
example a equals tf.constant 2.0 tf
float32 so it's a tensorflow value of
32. b equals tf constant 3.0 print a b
if we did a print of a b we'd have
tf.constant and then of course b is that
instance of it variables variables allow
us to add new trainable parameters to
graph to divide a variable we use
tf.variable command and initialize them
before running the graph in session
example w equals tf variable 0.3 d type
tfloat32 or b equals the tf variable
minus three comma d type float32
placeholders placeholders allow us to
feed data to a tensorflow model from
outside a model and permits a value to
be assigned later to define a
placeholder we use tf placeholder
command example a equals tf placeholder
b equals a times two with the tf session
as sess result equals session run b
comma feed dictionary equals a 3.0 print
result uh so we have a nice example
there replace holder session a session
is run to evaluate the nodes this is
called as the tensorflow run time so for
example you have a equals tf constant
2.0 b equals tf constant 4.0 c equals a
plus b and at this point you'd go ahead
and create a session equals tf session
and then you could evaluate the tensor c
print session run c that would input c
as an input into your session what do
you understand by a computational graph
everything in tensorflow is based on
creating a computational graph it has a
network of nodes where each node
performs an operation nodes represent
mathematical operation and edges
represent tensors since data flows in a
form of a graph it is also called a data
flow graph and we have a nice visual of
this graph or graphic image of a
computational graph and you can see here
we have our input nodes our add multiply
nodes and our multiply node at the end
and then we have the edges where the
data flows so we have from a going to c
a going to d you can see we have a two
flowing four flowing explain generative
adversarial network along with an
example suppose there is a wine shop
that purchases wine from dealers which
they will resell later we have a dealer
going to the wine or shop owner that
then sells it for a profit but there are
some malfactor dealers who sell fake
wine in this case the shop owner should
be able to distinguish between fake and
authentic wine the forger will try to
different techniques to sell fake wine
and make sure certain techniques go past
the shop owner's check so here's our
forager fake wine shop owner the shop
owner would probably get some feedback
from the wine experts that some of the
wine is not original the owner would
have to improve how he determines
whether a wine is fake or authentic goal
of forger to create wines that are
indistinguishable from the authentic
ones goal of shop owner to accurately
tell if the wine is real or not there
are two main components of generative
adversarial network and we refer to as a
noise vector coming in we have our
forger who's going to generate fake wine
and then we have our real authentic wine
and of course our shop owner has to
figure out whether it's real or fake the
generator is a cnn that keeps producing
images that are closer in appearance to
the real images while the discriminator
tries to determine the difference
between real and fake images the
ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator learn to identify real and
fake images what is an auto encoder the
network is trained to reconstruct its
inputs it is a neural network that has
three layers here the input neurons are
equal to the output neuron the network's
target outside is same as the input it
uses dimensionality reduction to
restructure the input input image comes
in we have our latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we have our training
data and our test data very standard
thing to do then we're going to randomly
select data into the bags and train your
model separately so we might have bag
one model one bag two model two bag
three model three and so on in boosting
the emphasis is to select the data
points which give wrong output in order
to improve the accuracy so in boosting
we have our data set again we split it
to test data and train data and we'll
take a bag one and we'll train the model
data points with wrong predictions then
go into bag two and we then train that
model and repeat so we've covered a
number of questions that you might get
during an interview hopefully this helps
you get land that perfect job we want to
thank you for joining us here at simply
learn again wwe
get certified get ahead we have a number
of other resources out there so if you
want to learn more about the rnn
recurrent neural network or the cnn the
convolutional neural network is one of
the main things we have a tensorflow out
there you can come and research a number
of our other youtube videos or come
visit us for more information at
www.simplylearn.com
you